ASSEMBLY TRANSPORTATION
COMMITTEE IS NOW CALLED ORDER.
WE'RE GONNA START AS A SUB
COMMITTEE AS WE DO NOT HAVE A
QUORUM.
HOW MISTER OBERNOLTE?
YOUR FIRST UP.
SO MY ASSUMPTION IS THAT YOU
PRESENT WITH AB TWO TWENTY FIVE
THIRTY FIVE FIRST.
THEN YOU'RE A FALL FALL FOR THE
OTHER BILL.
PLEASE PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE READY
THANK YOU SIR.
I THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
WE ARE AS A SOCIETY WITH
INCREASING FREQUENCY ARE RELYING
ON AUTOMATED TECHNOLOGY TO
ASSIST IN ISSUING VIOLATIONS OF
OUR TRAFFIC SAFETY LAWS. AND A
GOOD EXAMPLE OF THIS RECENTLY
HAS BEEN. THE AUTOMATIC ISSUANCE
OF CITATIONS FOR TOLLING
VIOLATIONS WHICH HAS HAD A LOT
OF SUCCESS IN RECENT YEARS.
A NEW TECHNOLOGIES EMERGING
THAT WILL ALLOW LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS TO ENFORCE.
HIGH OCCUPANCY VEHICLE LANES
OCCUPANCY RULES WITH.
SOME AUTOMATION AND IT'S REALLY
REMARKABLE TECHNOLOGY USES A
COMBINATION OF ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE AND MACHINE
LEARNING. TO BE ABLE TO IN AN
AUTOMATED WAY DETERMINE HOW MANY
OCCUPANTS THEY ARE IN A CAR. AND
ISSUE A VIOLATION AUTOMATICALLY
IF THE NUMBER OF OCCUPANTS DOES
NOT MEET THE THRESHOLD FOR THE
HIGH OCCUPANCY LIAM IN WHICH
VEHICLES TRAVELING SO. RECENT
STUDIES HAVE INDICATED THAT THIS
TECHNOLOGY HAS ABOUT A NINETY
FIVE PERCENT ACCURACY RATE. AND
ABOUT A ONE POINT FOUR PERCENT
PAUSES TO A FALSE POSITIVE RATE
YOU THINK ABOUT THAT IT'S IS
THAT IS REMARKABLE ACCURACY I
DON'T THINK THAT A HUMAN. COULD
DO EQUALLY WELL IF THEY SPENT A
SMALL AMOUNT OF TIME ON EACH
PHOTOGRAPH IS THESE ARE MACHINES
DO HOWEVER THAT IS SMALL
CONSOLATION IF YOU'RE ONE OF THE
ONE AND TWENTY. PEOPLE THAT WERE
ISSUED ONE OF THE CITATIONS THAT
REALLY DON'T DESERVE TO BE
ISSUED A CITATION.
SO CURRENT STATE LAW REQUIRES
CERTAIN INFORMATION BE GIVEN TO
A CONSUMER ALONG WITH THE
VIOLATION THAT WAS GENERATED IN
AN AUTOMATED FASHION. AND THIS
BILL.
AB TWENTY FIVE THIRTY FIVE WILL.
ANTI REQUIREMENT THAT IF THE
AUTOMATED TICKET IS ISSUED FOR A
HIGH OCCUPANCY VEHICLE VIOLATION
THAT THAT VIOLATION NOTICE ALSO
INCLUDE THE PHOTOGRAPHIC
EVIDENCE THAT WAS USED TO
DETERMINE THE VIOLATION. AND
THIS IS GOING TO DO TWO THINGS
FIRST OF ALL IT'S GOING TO
INCREASE CONSUMER ACCEPTANCE.
OF THE USE OF THIS TECHNOLOGY
BECAUSE IT'S PRETTY HARD TO
ARGUE WITH SOMETHING WHEN YOU'RE
GIVEN A PICTURE OF YOUR VEHICLE
YOU CAN SEE CLEARLY YOU'RE THE
ONLY ONE IN THE VEHICLE AND YOU
WERE IN THE HIGH OCCUPANCY
VEHICLE AND THAT'S PRETTY HARD
ARGUMENT. WITH BUT THE OTHER
THING IT WILL DO IS IF YOU'RE
ONE OF THE. FIVE PERCENT OF
PEOPLE WHO WERE ISSUED A
VIOLATION IN ERROR IT'S GOING TO
GIVE YOU A TOOL TO CONTEST THE
VIOLATION WHICH I THINK IS ONLY
FAIR SO I HOPE THIS IS WORTHY OF
YOUR SUPPORT I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST. AND I GO OUT ON AB
TWENTY FIVE THIRTY FIVE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER DO YOU
HAVE ANY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF
YOUR BILL NO SIR. THE MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF YOUR.
THE POOR THE AUTHORS BILL.
THE MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WHO
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION.
OR SHARE AN OPINION ON THE
AUTHORS BILL.
SEEING NONE ANY QUESTIONS OF THE
COMMITTEE.
WE HAVE A MOTION.
WELL THAT'S OKAY FIFTY. SO I'LL
SAYS WHERE'S WHICH I TO CLOSE
IT'S WE DON'T HAVE A QUORUM
SOMEONE ONE THAT'S APPROPRIATE
AND HAVE A QUORUM THAT BILL. WAS
THAT IF YOU
DISABILITIES HAD INSTALLED
CHARGING INFRASTRUCTURE IN THE
STE IN THE SPACES IT WAS
APPROPRIATE TO RESTRICT THE USE
OF THOSE SPACES.
PART TWO ONLY ELECTRIC VEHICLES
HOWEVER THOUGHT THAT IGNORES A
COUPLE OF ITEMS OF STANDING
PRACTICE IN STATE CODE ONE OF
WHICH IS THAT.
VEHICLES WITH.
WELL I'LL MEET WITH A HANDICAP
ACCESSIBLE PARKING PLACARDS ARE
ALREADY.
ALLOWED TO PARK IN A WIDE
VARIETY OF DIFFERENT RESTRICTED
PARKING SITUATIONS FOR EXAMPLE
THEY'RE ALLOWED TO PARK IN
METERED PARKING WITHOUT PAYING
THE METER THEY'RE ALLOWED TO
PARK IN LIMITED DURATION PARKING
SUCH AS A LOADING ZONE. WITHOUT
A OBEYING THOSE LIMITS AND
THEY'RE ALSO ALLOWED TO PARK IN
RESTRICTED PARKING AREAS FOR
THINGS LIKE.
.
TENANTS ONLY PARKING FOR A
BUILDING THAT WORRY IS CERTAIN
BUSINESS ONLY PARKING SO WE
ESTABLISHED THOSE THOSE.
.
THOSE EXEMPTIONS BECAUSE WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT THOSE
CONSUMERS HAVE THE ABILITY TO
ACCESS THOSE VEHICLE SPACES. AND
ALL THAT'S SOMETHING THAT WE
HAVE DONE I AS PRACTICE IN THIS
LEGISLATURE SO THIS BILL SIMPLY.
ESTABLISHES A VERY NARROWLY
TAILORED EXEMPTION TO THE
ELECTRIC VEHICLE ONLY PARKING
SPACES.
NOT ONLY IN THE CASES OF
VEHICLES THAT ARE EQUIPPED WITH
THE DRAFT.
BOB OR WITH A LEFT FOR A. A
WHEELCHAIR ACCESSIBLE VEHICLE
AND ONLY IN THE OCCASIONS WHERE
THAT SPACE IS BEING USED FOR
VEHICLE USING THOSE DEVICES TO
ON MOTOR OFF LOSE. AN OCCUPANT
WITH A WHEELCHAIR SO IT'S A VERY
NARROWLY TAILORED DECEPTION AND
I WOULD HOPE WOULD BE WORTHY OF
YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU SO MEMBER DO YOU HAVE
ANY WITNESSES WERE YOUR BILL YES
I DO. PLEASE IT TO A STATUE NAME
IN THE REPRESENT PLEASE.
JENNIFER HANNAH HELL WITH
READING ASSOCIATES ON BEHALF OF
THE TAXI CAB PARA TRANSIT
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA. I'M
IT'S A LITTLE KNOWN FACT THAT
MANY TAXI COMPANIES ARE THE PAIR
TRANSIT PROVIDERS IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES.
IT'S OFTEN TAXI COMPANIES THAT
ARE CONTRACTED WITH.
THAT CONTRACT WITH REGIONAL
CENTERS OR HOSPITALS TO PROVIDE
PAIR TRAINED TRANSIT SERVICES
AND HAVE VEHICLES EQUIPPED THAT.
AT SUCH MENTIONED IN THIS BILL.
I AB TWENTY EIGHT OH SIX IS A
COMMON SENSE MEASURE THAT WILL
ALLOW THE BEST USE OF THOSE THE
OFTEN LIMITED SPACE AVAILABLE
FOR LOADING AND UNLOADING
DISABLED TRAVELERS AND WE
REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH ANY OTHER
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WHO WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
THE AUTHORS BILL.
SEEING NONE ANY MEMBERS THE
PUBLIC THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION OR VOICE
AN OPINION ON THE OTHERS.
SEEING NONE QUESTIONS OF THE
COMMITTEE OF THE AUTHOR.
MR.
CITIZENSHIP.
AND TAKE YOUR MISTER CHAIR THIS
IS JUST FOR.
LOADING AND UNLOADING.
NOT FOR AN EXTENDED.
TIME OF PARK IN THAT SPACE ARE.
NOT EXACTLY IT ALLOWS PARKING IN
A SPACE.
ONLY INDICATIONS WELL WHERE THE
VEHICLES BEING USED TO LOAD AND
UNLOAD SO FOR EXAMPLE IF THE. BY
HANDICAP PERSON WITH A
WHEELCHAIR WORK TO USE ONE OF
THE SPACES USING RAP TO OFFLOAD
THEIR WHEELCHAIR GO INTO A
BUSINESS FREQUENT THE BUSINESS
AND THEN COME BACK OUT. TO THE
VEHICLE COULD BE PART IN THAT
SPACE FOR THE DURATION.
NO I DO HAVE A LITTLE
RESERVATION ABOUT THIS HIGH I
MEAN THIS IS REALLY A WELL
INTENDED THROUGH THE VEIL.
AND THE.
TO PROVIDE MORE PARKING SPACE
FOR THE DISABLED COMMUNITY.
I THINK IT'S A CRITICAL BUT
BECAUSE. IT IS ALSO CRITICAL TO
PROVIDE CHARGING SYSTEM FOR A
LOT OF FOR. THOSE OF YOU BE OR
OR OR CARS AND AND AND DO DIRECT
VISION COMES HAVE SO THEY'RE
EQUALLY. CRITICAL TO ME THE
RESERVATIONS BECOME MAN BECAUSE.
WHAT PAY SO MUCH MONEY FOR THE
CHARGING CSUS THIS THE SYSTEM?
WANNA MAKE SURE THAT WE HELP
THAT PASSED USE.
I MEAN TO MAKE MORE PARKING
SPACE HANDICAP PARKING SPACE
AVAILABLE I'M I'M TOTALLY YOU IN
THE AGREE WITH IT. BUT TO PUT A
VERY EXPRESSIVE SPACE
AND AND THEN LIMITED USE BY THE
EVENING IS.
IT'S WORTH IT WHO RESERVATION
COMES SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
THIS BILL THANK YOU. ASSEMBLYMAN
I SHARE YOUR RESERVATION AND
THAT IS WHY WE TOOK SUCH CARE TO
SO NARROWLY.
A TAILOR THE BILL.
NOT ONLY FOR THOSE CERTAIN TYPES
OF VEHICLES AND I WE HAD ANOTHER
MOTIVATION FOR DOING THAT WHICH
IS THAT A RECENT APPELLATE COURT
DECISION HAS ESTABLISHED THAT.
CITIES HAVE LIABILITY UNDER THE
AMERICANS WITH DISABILITIES ACT
FOR FAILURE TO PROVIDE ON ST
HANDICAP ACCESSIBLE PARKING.
SO THE EXEMPTIONS FOR OTHER
KINDS OF VEHICULAR SPACES FOR
THOSE KINDS OF USES HELP CITIES
AVOID THAT KIND OF LIABILITY AND
WE'RE ALSO HOPING TO HELP THEM
AVOID THE LIABILITY WITH RESPECT
TO THE EVEN ONLY SPACES.
BUT THAT'S WHAT WE TARA WOULD
TEAR TAYLOR DID SO NEARLY.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER OBERNOLTE WE'RE
GONNA LITTLE HOUSEKEEPING AT
THIS POINT WE SORT OF A QUORUM
MADAM SPEAKER. PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
FRAZIER AYE HERE FONG.
AND WE ARE CURRENT.
BAKER.
BERMAN.
CHIU.
DALY NEAR FRIEDMAN.
GIPSON.
WHERE?
HARPER.
MATHIS.
DOES IT MEDINA RESIDENT.
NAZARIAN.
O'DONNELL.
THANK YOU MISTER ALTERNATE
OBERNOLTE FOR YOUR PATIENCE
ENJOYED CLOSE.
BUT CERTAINLY.
I'M SORRY THAT YOU THAT'S OKAY.
THANK YOU MISTER OBERNOLTE FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD I'M
STRUGGLING WITH THIS BILL AS
WELL. AND I'M OBVIOUSLY I MEAN I
CAN SEE BOTH SIDES OF IT.
AND.
WOULD LIKE TO DO MORE RESEARCH
ON IT BEFORE.
.
JUST TO SEE WHAT MORE IF WE IF
THERE'S ANY OTHER ADDITIONAL
IMPACTS ON THIS PROPOSAL.
BUT.
YOU STRUGGLE WITH THE RETARDED
STATIONS I'VE STRUGGLE WITH OF
THE DISABILITY DISABLED PARKING.
I WILL SUPPORT YOUR BILL TODAY
BUT I'M IN A RESERVE MY RIGHT
TO.
HOA WITHHOLD MY VOTE ON THE
FLOOR.
I APPRECIATE THAT AND WE WILL
CERTAINLY CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
ALL THE PARTIES AS THE BILL
MOVES MOVES FORWARD THANK YOU.
MEDINA GIVE QUESTIONS OF THE
AUTHOR I DO AND AND I'M SORRY
IF.
YOU PRIORITY ANSWERS BUT I CAME
IN LATE IS IT OFFERS THEM THAT I
HAVE.
WELL. AS PARKING OR JUST
DROPPING OFF OR IT IS PARKING
ALTHOUGH IT IS NARROWLY TAILORED
TO BE ONLY PARKING THAT INVOLVES
THE LOADING AND OFFLOADING. OF
SOMEONE WITH A WHEELCHAIR THAT
USES A LEFT WHERE HE RAN.
SO IT IS VERY NARROWLY TAILORED
TO THOSE USES.
SO THE THE THE VEHICLE WOULDN'T
STAY THERE ONCE THE THE PERSON
IS
HONOR OFF.
WELL I I THINK IT WOULD DEPEND
ON TO THAT THERE'S NOTHING IN
THE THE EXEMPTION THAT REQUIRES
IT TO ONLY BE LOADING AND
OFFLOADING SO IF THE ONLY
OCCUPANT OF THE VEHICLE WAS
SOMEONE. IN A WHEELCHAIR THE WHO
DRIVES THAT THE VEHICLE AND THEN
USES A LIFT TO OFFLOAD CLEAR
THEIR WHEELCHAIR OBVIOUSLY.
THE VEHICLE WOULD STAY THERE
WELL THEY DID WHATEVER THEY NEED
TO DO THANK YOU.
BACK.
WELL FIRST BY BAKER SECOND BY
MATHIS.
ALWAYS LIKED CLOSE UP I'D JUST
RESPECTFULLY REQUESTS DRIVE OF.
THANK YOU MISTER OBERNOLTE A. AS
YOU KNOW ADDRESSING THE NEEDS OF
THE JUST ABLE COMMUNITY IS A
TRUE PASSION OF MINE.
HOWEVER WELL WELL WELL INTENDED
I BELIEVE THIS BILL IS
PREMATURE.
S. MIGHT LIMIT OPPORTUNITIES
REVIEW OWNERS.
TO CHARGE OUR VEHICLES AND
UNFORTUNATELY TREAT SEGMENTS OF
THE DISABLED DISABLED COMMUNITY
DIFFERENTLY.
EVERY DISABLED PERSON MUST HAVE
ACCESS TO PARKING AND I DO NOT
THINK THIS BILL RESULTS IN THAT
PERFECT APPROACH.
HOWEVER I PLAN TO SUPPORT THE
BILL TODAY.
WITH THE RIGHT TO RESERVE MY
VOTE ON THE FLOOR AND URGE YOU
TO WORK WITH STAKEHOLDERS.
CRAFT SOMETHING THAT WILL
ACTUALLY.
MANIFEST INTO SOMETHING THAT
ACTUALLY WORKS AND DOESN'T
SEGMENT THE DISABLED POPULATION.
AND ADDRESS THE ISSUE OF PARKING
ACCESSIBILITY FOR ALL SEGMENTS
SO. LOOKING FORWARD TO YOU
WORKING WITH THE.
THE COMMUNITY AND.
AND HOPEFULLY COME UP WITH. A
SOLUTION THAT WORKS TIME
CERTAINLY COMMITTED TO THAT
ALSO.
WITH THAT MANSARD A PLEASE
KALRA.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS FRAZIER.
AYE FRAZIER IPHONE.
AGUIAR CURRY AYE AYE AND WE ARE
CURRY AYE BAKER. BAKER AYE
BERMAN.
CHIU.
CHIU AYE DALY. DALY AYE
FRIEDMAN.
GIPSON. GIPSON AYE HARPER.
MATHIS. MATHIS AYE MEDINA.
MEDINA AYE THIS AREA. O'DONNELL.
O'DONNELL I.
THANK YOU MISTER.
THERE'S NINE WILL LEAVE RULED
THE FRAPH SOME MEMBERS.
BUT FOR THOSE SENIORS ALLS THEY
CAN.
HOW WOULD YOU LIKE TO TAKE UP
THE OTHER BILL WITH WELL I'M
HERE OR? YES SO.
.
WE HAVE THE.
I THINK.
AB TWENTY FIVE THIRTY FIVE.
TOM.
SINCE YOU'RE HERE WILL GO HEAD
ROLLED BACK.
.
WE HAVEN'T MOTION BY MISTER
COUSIN CHU AND.
SECONDLY I WOULD A YEAR CURRY.
I GUESS I'LL DO MY CLOSING.
OF.
SO THANK YOU FOR PRESENTING THIS
BILL I UNDERSTAND THE BILL'S
ABOUT PROPER NOTIFICATION TO
VIOLATORS AND NOT ABOUT
AUTOMATED ENFORCEMENT HOTLINES.
I WILL SUPPORT I WILL BE
SPORTING A BILLS BECAUSE DRIVERS
DESERVE TO BE PROPERLY NOTIFIED
IF THEY'RE BEING TICKETED.
HOWEVER
I THINK THERE MAY BE.
STILL SOME ISSUES TO.
BE RESOLVED.
AROUND AUTOMATED ENFORCEMENT
COLLEAGUES AND I HOPE ARE RESULT
BEFORE YOU THIS IS PUT INTO
PRACTICE.
LOOKING FORWARD TO ANOTHER.
SOLUTION FOR HOTLINES.
THERE SO VALUABLE IN A LOT OF
THE REGIONS AND ALSO HAVE TO BE
ABLE TO PAY THEIR BOND THAT.
AND SO LOOKING FORWARD TO.
HELPING THEM WITH THAT. MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
EMOTIONS DO PASSED TO THE
ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE FRAZIER. FRAZIER AYE
FONG.
I AGREE ARE CURRY ON AND WE ARE
CURRY AYE BAKER. BAKER AYE
BERMAN.
CHU CHU AYE DALY. DALY AYE
FRIEDMAN.
GIPSON. GIPSON AYE HARPER.
MATHIS. MATHIS AYE MEDINA MEDINA
I'M ITS ARIANE. O'DONNELL.
O'DONNELL I.
THAT JUST SHOWS NINE WILL LEAVE
A WILL PUT TRAPS MEMBERS WE GO
AHEAD MOVE A LITTLE MORE
HOUSEKEEPING BEFORE CALL MISTER
LACKEY.
WE HAVE ANNOUNCEMENTS.
MEASURES ON CONSENT.
FILE ITEM NUMBER THREE AB TWENTY
SEVEN THIRTY FOUR FRAZIER.
FILE ITEM NUMBER FIVE MAYBE
THIRTY SEVENTEEN ACOSTA.
FILE ITEM NUMBER SIX A. B.
THIRTY ONE SIXTY THREE FRAZIER.
FILE ITEM NUMBER SEVEN ACR ONE
EIGHTY ONE FLORA.
FILE ITEM NUMBER EIGHT ACR ONE
EIGHTY FIVE.
BIGELOW.
WITH A MEMBER LIKE TO REMOVE AN
ITEM FOR THE CONSECUTIVE.
TRAVIS FIRST PLAGUE AND ASSEMBLY
MEMBER OF THE KANSEN CHU AND THE
SECOND WAS MISTER GIPSON.
OUR MEMBERS ARE GETTING PLEASE
TAKE THE ROLE ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR PLEASE.
FRAZIER.
FRAZIER AYE FONG.
AND WE ARE CURRY. AND WE ARE
CURRY AYE BAKER.
BAKER AYE BERMAN.
CHU. CHU AYE DALY.
DALY AYE FRIEDMAN.
GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE HARPER.
MATHIS. MATHIS AYE MEDINA.
MEDINA INEZ AARON.
O'DONNELL.
O'DONNELL I.
THAT IT.
BECAUSE THEY KILLED ORDER HAS
NINE WILL LEAVE THE ROLE THEN
PERHAPS A MEMBERS.
I WILL MOVE ON TO OTHER MISTER
LACKEY.
AB TWENTY FIVE FORTY FOUR.
THANK YOU MISTER LACKEY COME.
KLONOPIN.
WHEN YOU'RE READY. PLEASE
PROCEED.
WE CARE MEMBERS.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT AB TWENTY FIVE FORTY
FOUR.
IS JUST A.
A SIMPLE CLEAN UP TO LAST
YEAR'S AB FIVE ALL THREE.
WHICH ESTABLISHED THE PAPER
PROGRAM FOR LOW INCOME DRIVERS
WHO ACQUIRE PARKING TICKETS.
AB TWENTY FIVE FORTY FOUR MAKE
CLEAR THE INTENT OF AB FIVE A
THREE.
WHICH IS TO MAKE PARKING TICKETS
ISSUED TO LOW INCOME
INDIVIDUALS.
ELIGIBLE
FOR THE PARKING TICKET PROGRAM
CREATED IN AB FIVE ALL THREE
EVEN IF THEY WERE ISSUED.
THOSE CITATIONS PRIOR TO THE
JULY FIRST TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
COMPLIANCE STATE.
THIS WAS ALWAYS.
THE INTENT OF AB FIVE OF THREE
WHICH IS TO RECEIVE.
ZERO WHICH RECEIVED ZERO NO
VOTES AND.
THIS COMMITTEE LAST YEAR WITH
ME TODAY IS MY CAROL FROM THE
WESTERN CENTER FOR LAW AND
POVERTY TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MY CAROL
AGAIN WITH WESTERN CENTER ON LAW
AND POVERTY.
YES I THINK ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ACCURATELY DESCRIBE THIS BILL
LAST YEAR WAS TO CREATE A WAY
FOR PEOPLE TO BE ABLE TO PAY OFF
THEIR PARKING TICKETS. BE ABLE
TO KEEP THEIR CAR REGISTERED BE
LEGAL ON THE STREET ALL THINGS
WE AGREE THAT WE WANT TO HAVE
DONE. WHEN THE BILL WENT THROUGH
WE THOUGHT THAT IT WOULD APPLY
TO ALL PARKING TICKETS.
AS WE STARTED TO GO THROUGH THE
IMPLEMENTATION PHASE WITH LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS A COUPLE OF LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TOLD US THAT THEY
WERE NOT GOING TO ALLOW PEOPLE
HAVE A TICKET IN ADVANCE OF JULY
ONE. TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN BE
ABLE TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THE
NEW PROVISIONS OF LAW.
AND THIS SEEMED ON NOT WHAT WE
THOUGHT WE HAD NEGOTIATED FOR
AND FURTHERMORE NOT GOOD POLICY
IN THAT A SUBSTANTIAL PART OF
THE POPULATION WOULD HAVE NO
REMEDY AT ALL.
THE BACK UNDER THE OLD LAW SO
WE THINK THIS IS A VERY SIMPLE.
CONSISTENT FIX OF WHAT WE DID
LAST YEAR WE ARE TONIGHT VOTE.
SECOND.
THE FIRST IN A SECOND.
FOR SOON MR MEDINA SEX RIGHT
HERE CURRY.
MISTER LIKE YOU DO YOU HAVE ANY
OTHER MEMBERS OF THE. PUBLIC
THAT YOU WOULDN'T THINK HAVE
TESTIFIED SPREE BILL.
HE MOVES THE PUBLIC LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THE
AUTHORS BILL PLEASE STATE YOUR
NAME IN THE REPRESENT PLEASE MY
INGRAM ACLU OF CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
THE MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO
THE OFFICE DOOR VOICE OUR
OPINION.
WE STATE YOUR NAME AND WHO YOU
REPRESENT SIR PLEASE.
GOOD AFTERNOON.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN DAVID
JONES ABOUT THE CITY SACRAMENTO.
ARE WE DON'T THINK THIS IS A
SIMPLE BILL.
THESE ARE ALL DULY ISSUED
CITATIONS THAT PEOPLE BUT NOBODY
FOR SOMEBODY TO GET A PARKING
TICKET YOU HAVE TO MAKE A
VIOLATION OF LAW. WE HAVE
APPROXIMATELY TWENTY ONE
THOUSAND TICKETS THAT WE HAVE
FILED WITH THE DMV FOR
COLLECTION WE PAID THREE DOLLARS
OF CITY MONEY. FOR THAT TICKET
TO BE PUT ON THE THAT DMT
COLLECTION OF DOCKET. IF THIS
BILL PASSES WE WOULD HAVE TO A
REFILE THE VAST MAJORITY THOSE
TWENTY ONE THOUSAND CITATIONS
FOR COLLECTION.
OF WE WE THINK IT'S A
SIGNIFICANT ADMINISTRATIVE
BURDEN AND COST A LOCAL
GOVERNMENT WE ASK FOR NO VOTE.
ANY OTHER MEMBERS THE PUBLIC
LIKES TESTIFYING OPPOSITION OVER
SHOW THEIR OPINION ON THE OFFICE
BILL
SEEING NONE. MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE HAVE ANY QUESTIONS OF
THE OTHER MISTER O'DONNELL. JUST
THANK YOU ARE IN MY COMMENTS
MAYBE ALONG THE LINES OF.
.
THE CITY SACRAMENTO THERE I
ACTUALLY FROM WHAT I'M HEARING
FOR THE CITY LONG BEACH IS LAST
YEAR THERE WAS AN UNDERSTANDING.
.
MAY LAST YEAR AND SOME AGO SHE
ASIANS WITH EIGHTY FIVE A THREE.
THAT HAD THE BILL ONLY
REQUIRING.
TO TICKETS TICKETS ISSUED AFTER
JANUARY FIRST TWENTY EIGHTEEN.
IN OTHER WORDS THERE ARE
MEETINGS HELD CONVERSATIONS HAD
AND THAT UNDERSTANDING FROM WHAT
I'M HEARING FROM THE CITY LONG
BEACH.
WAS ESTABLISHED.
DO YOU WISH TO COMMENT ON THE.
THAT'S CLEARLY A
MISUNDERSTANDING OF THAT WAS THE
IMPRESSION THAT WAS.
.
RECEIVED IT WAS NOT THE INTENT
BUT THAT'S HOW THE BILL WAS
WRITTEN.
SO.
I JUST WANT TO SHARE WITH YOU
BECAUSE THAT THE CITY LONG BEACH
WILL DOES HAVE SOME.
SIGNIFICANT CONCERNS WITH THIS
NEW APPROACH.
WE WHERE. WE WOULD TO TEST THIS
IS NOT A NEW APPROACH THAT THIS
WAS THE INTENT ALTHOUGH FROM THE
VERY BEGINNING WHAT THEY'RE
SAYING IS THAT ACTUALLY.
NOT
AND WHERE ARE YOU WHERE BONE
THAT'S THEIR PERCEPTIONS OF THAT
WAS NOT THE CASE AGREED THAT'S
WHAT WE'RE BACK HERE TO MAKE YOU
WANT TO CHANGE.
PRIOR TO CLEAN WE JUST WANT TO
CLARIFY ITS NOT CHANGE.
THERE IS A DIFFERENCE.
BLOOM OF.
IT WAS YOUR THIRD ENFORCEMENT.
MOST MATHIS HAVE QUESTIONS OF
HEALTH.
I USED.
THEN M. MADE INTERESTED IN HIS
OPPOSITION FROM THE CITY.
OKAY BECAUSE I'VE SEEN BEFORE
OUR CITIES WILL HAVE A PROBLEM
WAYS.
COMPANIES THAT THEY CONTRACT
WITH TO DO THE TICKETS.
SO I AND MY MY THOUGHT IT HOW
COME THEY'RE NOT RENEGOTIATING
THE CONTRACTS WITH THESE
AGENCIES THAT THEY HIRE.
DO THEM I'M IN THE THE BILL
CLEARLY IS JUST.
SIMPLIFICATION TO GO BACK AND.
I JUST WHAT WAS ALREADY DONE TO
CLARIFY.
SO FOR ME IT KIND OF COMMON
SENSE THAT IF YOU GOT A
CONTRACT.
IT'S DOINGTHAT THE PARKING
TICKETS OR ANY OF THE TICKETS.
ITS THE I MEAN. QUIETLY QUESTION
FOR FOR THE OPPOSITION.
BUT NOW I'M I'M JUST CURIOUS
BECAUSE I'VE SEEN DIFFERENT
THINGS AND I'VE SEEN THINGS
HAPPEN WITH WITH SOME OF MY
CITIES WHERE THEY'VE HAD.
ISSUES WITH ONE FIRM IN THAT IT
SWITCHING OVER TO ANOTHER FIRM
THAN PEOPLE GETTING TICKETS
TWICE AND THREE TIMES A. RIGHT
IT'S IT'S A MASSIVE SELL.
MANY CITIES DO CONTRACT BUT
SACRAMENTO DOES IT ITSELF SO WE
DO IT INTERNALLY SO THERE'S NOT
A QUESTION OF CONTRACT
COMPLIANCE.
SIMILAR DAY CHARGING YOURSELF
THREE DOLLARS WE'RE PAYING THE
DMV THREE DOLLARS TO PROCESS OUR
OWN PARKING TICKETS WE WOULD
LIKE TO GET PAID AND THE ONLY
POINT WE CAN GET THESE FOLKS
THAT. HAVE THERE'S NO QUESTION
IT'S A VIOLATION THAT BIG THEY
EARNED A PARKING TICKET OR TWO.
OF THE ONLY WAY WE CAN GET IT
COLLECTED IS AT THAT STOP
POINTING DMB WHEN THEY HAVE TO
GO REGISTER THEIR VEHICLE.
SO WE'VE HAD IT EASY PAYMENT
PLAN FOR YEARS.
I DON'T DISAGREE WITH THAT
ASPECT OF FIVE WITH YOU FROM
LAST YEAR BUT THIS IS
RETROACTIVE IT'S NOT IT WAS NOT
OUR UNDERSTANDING THAT WOULD BE
RETROACTIVE TO. TWENTY ONE
THOUSAND CITATIONS THAT WE'RE
NOW IN JEOPARDY FOR US.
IT'S A VERY SIGNIFICANT GUYS
ZERO CORRECT I OWN I'M SURE THE
AUTHOR WOULD LOVE TO SIT DOWN
AND WORK THAT OUT.
THANK YOU MISTER DOLE YOU HAVE
YOUR EX ONE ASK QUESTION UP FROM
THE REPRESENTED FROM THE CITY
SACRAMENTO.
SO WHAT ARE YOUR CONCERNS THE
SAME AS THE CITY LONG BEACH IS
PRESENT CORRECT.
VERY LARGE IT HAS TO THE GOING
BACK.
YES NO WE YOU KNOW WE HAVE THIS
GROUP
WE WE HAVE ALWAYS TICKETS THAT
WE'VE ALREADY FILED WITH THE DMV
TO COLLECT. SO WE PAY THE THREE
DOLLARS THAT'S
SEVENTY THOUSAND DOLLARS WE PAID
APPROXIMATELY.
WOULD WE IF THIS BILL PASSES
WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO GO BACK AND
RE FILE THEM IN THE DIEM KEEP
THE FEE FOR FOUGHT FOR
COLLECTING PARKING TICKETS
INCIDENTALLY WENT UP BY A
DOLLAR.
SO IT COST US FOUR DOLLARS TO
COLLECT THE TWENTY ONE THOUSAND
TICKETS THAT WE ARE DO WE OWED
SO WE PAY SEVEN DOLLARS.
TO TRY TO GET THE SIX CLICK.
SO FOR US IT'S A VERY
SIGNIFICANT COSTS WERE.
YOU KNOW VERY SURPRISED AT THAT.
DISPLAY OF WHAT THIS BILL DOES
OR DOES NOT DO BUSINESS CLEARLY
WHICH WE SHARED ONE BEACHES
UNDERSTANDING ABOUT THE BILL.
FROM FROM LAST YEAR GETS PER
THANK YOU.
THIS BAKER.
Q. AND.
I WONDER IF FOR.
JUST TO BE TODAY THE OP I'M
SORRY YOU JUST LEFT I'M SORRY
ABOUT THAT.
YOU'LL EXERCISE TODAY.
WE'RE YOU.
THANK YOU FOR YOU INVOLVED IN
NEGOTIATIONS DIRECTLY WITH THE
AUTHORS OFFICE WAS THAT
CONDUCTED THROUGH YES I WAS.
AGAIN AND AGAIN MAINLY WHAT THE
STAFF THE CITY'S LIKE RUN ON THE
LOBBYIST BUT.
STAFF THE CITY SACRAMENTO THE
PARKING A A PERSON WAS INVOLVED
IN THE DISCUSSIONS FRIENDLY NOT
FOR THE LEAGUE. NO.
AND WHAT PROVISIONS SPECIFICALLY
DO YOU FEEL MAKES IT WHERE THIS
WASN'T THE CASE LAST YEAR AND
THIS IS A CLARIFYING WHEN
LOOKING AT THE BILL IT LOOKS
CLARIFYING TO ME WELL IT'S. IT'S
OBVIOUS THAT HE NEEDS THIS BILL.
TO MAKE IT CLEARLY RETROACTIVE
AND WE CAN THINK LAST YEAR STILL
WHAT I'M ASKING A DIFFERENT
QUESTION
IT WILL WHEREIN THE BILL DO YOU
THINK THIS ISN'T ALREADY COVERED
BY LAST YEAR THAT IS A
CLARIFYING.
DO YOU HAVE IT IN FRONT OF YOU
WHERE. I DON'T HAVE A RIGHT FOR
TO BE BUT I KNOW THAT THE ONE IF
THERE'S VERY FEW CHANGES IN THE
BILL SO IT IT'S ONLY THE CHANGES
THAT SAYS. YOU KNOW LET'S MAKE
IT CLEAR THAT THIS IS
RETROACTIVE WE DIDN'T THINK IT
WAS.
WELL I I GUESS I I WOULD I WOULD
DISAGREE I'M JUST LOOKING AT
PAGE TWO.
THAT THE AMENDMENTS AND AREA IT
DOES LOOK LIKE CLARIFYING
LANGUAGE TO MYSELF BUT IT ABBY
WELCOME. YOU KNOW I I HOPE THIS
WILL GET OUT TODAY WE WELCOME TO
HAVE US ESTABLISH WHERE IT'S NOT
STRICTLY CLARIFYING IF YOU HAVE
THE ACTUAL LANGUAGE UKRAINIAN
AND TRISTATE GROUNDED IN WHAT
THAT LANGUAGES.
THANK YOU.
HAVE QUESTIONS OF THE AUTHOR.
MR LIKE YOU WOULD LIKE TO
CLARIFY.
THE INTENT OF YOUR BILL. YES
CERTAINLY IF THERE IS A FEW AND
ADDITIONAL FEE I DON'T KNOW WHY
THAT WOULDN'T BE IMPOSED UPON.
THE PERSON RESPONSIBLE FOR
PAYING THE FEE WE'RE NOT TRYING
TO GET PEOPLE OUT OF PAYING
THEIR. WHAT THEY WHAT THEY NEED
TO PAY WHAT WHAT WE'RE WHAT IS
JUST A REASONABLE PAYMENT PLAN?
AND.
THIS IS NOT AMNESTY THIS IS
JUST TO ALLOW PEOPLE TO NOT LOSE
THEIR VEHICLES.
BECAUSE THEIR FINANCIAL
SITUATION DOESN'T FOR THEM TO DO
THAT ALL WENT PAYMENT.
AND SO WE BELIEVE THAT WAS
ALWAYS THE INTENT.
AND
WOULD ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER LIKE IF BRING
THIS BILL TO OUR COMMITTEE.
.
THIS IS HOW I READ THE BILL
YOU'RE GIVING OPPORTUNITY FOR
THOSE WHO ARE LESS FORTUNATE.
HOW YOU LEGISLATION LASHER
STRUCK A GOOD BALANCE BETWEEN
REQUIRE ME IMAGE OF INDIVIDUALS
TO PAY THEIR FINES WILL
PROVIDING OPTIONS?
UNNECESSARY WORDS OPTIONS TO LOW
INCOME PEOPLE TO REPAY THEIR
DEBT WITHOUT RUINING.
THEIR LIVELIHOOD.
THIS BILL MAKE SURE PROCESSING A
AGENCIES STICK TO THE INTENT
BEHIND THE LAW.
JUST CLEAR WHAT I SEE WILL BE
SPORTING YOUR BILL TODAY BUT I
WOULD ASK THAT YOU.
MAKE SURE THAT THE TO OUR
MEMBERS.
THEM OF THE DROSS THIS HAVE
THEY HAVE OAK FULL UNDERSTANDING
THAT THERE IS SOMETHING THAT CAN
BE TIGHTENED UP.
THEY'D LIKE TO SEE AND I WOULD
APPRECIATE IT IF YOU WORK
TOWARDS THAT AS A MOVE OR. A TO
MAKE SURE THEY'RE COMFORTABLE.
BECAUSE I THINK THE INTENT IS IS
AS WELL VALUE WE GIVE IT OUR
BEST MAKE YOU. WITH THAT I.
HELP THAT SECRETARY CULTURAL
PLEASE.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE FRAZIER AYE FRAZIER
AYE FONG. FONG AYE AGUIAR CURRY.
AYE AGUIAR CURRY AYE BAKER.
BAKER AYE BERMAN. BERMAN AYE
CHU.
CHU IDEALLY. DALY AYE FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN AYE GIPSON.
GIPSON NOT VOTING HARPER. HARPER
AYE MATHIS. MATHIS AYE MEDINA.
MEDINA AYE THIS AREA. NAZARIAN
AYE O'DONNELL.
O'DONNELL I.
THANK YOU.
THE BILL IS THIRTEEN.
WILL LEAVE THE ROLE CONFERENCE
TIME BEING OF THANK YOU GO AHEAD
AND.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH JUST LIKE
YOU WE'RE GONNA GO AHEAD AND AND
CALL THE ROLL ON ROOM FOR THE
ABSENT MEMBERS THAT WERE.
DURING THE LOCAL.
THAT'S A VERY PLEASE.
PROCEED.
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR THE
CURRENT VOTERS NINE TO ZERO
FONG.
FONG I BERMAN.
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR. BERMAN
AYE. FRIEDMAN. FRIEDMAN AYE
HARPER. HARPER AYE NAZARIAN.
NAZARIAN AYE FINAL VOTE ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR FOURTEEN TWO
ZERO.
FILE ITEM FOR THE MOTION IS TO
PASS THE CURRENT VOTERS NINE TO
ZERO FONG.
FONG I AM BERMAN. BERMAN AYE
TREATMENT.
FRIEDMAN NOT VOTING HARPER.
HARPER AYE NEWS AREA.
IT'S VIOLATE FOR AB TWENTY EIGHT
OF SEX.
NAZARIAN AYE.
FINAL VOTE THIRTEEN TWO ZERO.
FILE ITEM ONE.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE CURRENT VOTERS NINE TO
ZERO FONG.
FONG I AM BERMAN.
BERMAN AYE FRIEDMAN. FRIEDMAN
AYE HARPER. HARPER AYE SYRIAN.
NAZARIAN AYE FINAL VOTE FOURTEEN
TO ZERO.
SO LEGISLATIVE BUSINESS BEFORE
THE ASSEMBLY TRANSPORTATION
COMMITTEE IS NOW COMPLETE WE'RE
GOING TO.
.
A DURING THIS. COMPOSER THE
HEARING AND WE WANT TO OUR.
HEARING FOR HIGH SPEED RAIL
DRAFT BUSINESS PLAN
SO WE'RE GONNA MOVE FORWARD IN
CALL THIS HEARING TO ORDER.
COMMITTEE OVERSIGHT HEARING OF
TWENTY EIGHTEEN DRAFT HIGH SPEED
RAIL BUSINESS PLAN.
IF ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRAY OR
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CELLS PERSON IN
THE AUDIENCE WOULD LIKE WELCOME
TO THE PODIUM I'M TO THE DICE.
SAYING THAT THEY'RE NOT HERE.
THE WAY TO GET STARTED.
GOOD AFTERNOON JONES.
TODAY'S HEARING IS AN OVERSIGHT
HEARING TO PREVIEW TO REVIEW THE
CALIFORNIA HIGH SPEED RAIL
AUTHORITIES TWENTY EIGHTEEN.
CRAFT BUSINESS PLAN.
THE AUTHORITY IS REQUIRED TO
SUBMIT THE PLAN EVERY TWO YEARS.
AMONG OTHER THINGS THE PLEA THE
PLAN IS TO INCLUDE AN UPDATED
SCHEDULE AND COST ESTIMATE.
UPDATE FINANCIAL SCENARIOS AND
DISCUSSION OF ALL REASONABLY
FORESEEABLE RISKS.
AUTHORITY HAS A DIFFICULT TASK
IN DELIVERING HIGH SPEED RAIL
SYSTEM.
THEY MUST.
BUILDING OPERATE A HIGH SPEED
RAIL SYSTEM UNDER VERY SPECIFIC
DESIGN RESTRICTIONS SET FORTH.
IN THE BOND MEASURE.
AND THAT'S INCLUDING OPERATING
WITHOUT PUBLIC SUBSIDIES.
BILL THE INITIAL SEGMENT WITHIN
VERY TIGHT PARAMETERS REQUIRED
FOR THE USE OF FEDERAL DOLLARS.
COMPLETE ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEWS
AND ACQUIRE PROPERTY WITHIN A
VERY LITIGIOUS ATMOSPHERE.
AND.
CLEAR SOME VERY REAL VERY
INTIMIDATING ENGINEERING
CHALLENGES.
IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHT THE VOTERS
APPROVED PROPOSITION ONE A.
TO PROVIDE NINE BILLION DOLLARS
IN BONDS TO HELP BUILD THE
SYSTEM.
NOW AT THAT TIME THE ESTIMATE
FOR THE FULL COST OF THE HIGH
SPEED RAIL PROJECT WAS FORTY
FIVE BILLION.
SINCE THAT TIME THE COST OF
FLUCTUATED BETWEEN HIGH OF
NEARLY ONE HUNDRED BILLION
DEPENDING ON WHO YOU TALK TO.
AND DOWN TO SIXTY FOUR BILLION
AND NOW THE MOST RECENT ESTIMATE
OF SEVENTY SEVEN BILLION IN THIS
DRAFT PLAN.
GOVERNOR BROWN HAS THROWN HIS
FULL SUPPORT BY THE PROJECT.
COMMITTED TO MOVING FORWARD.
MEMBERS.
AS THE FUNDING PARTNER IN THIS
EFFORT WE THE LEGISLATURE SHARE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR THIS
MONUMENTAL EFFORT.
AND MEMBERS LET'S BE VERY FRANK.
THE PROJECT IS AT A CROSSROADS.
TODAY WE WILL HEAR FROM THE
AUTHORITY OF OTHERS AND AND OUR
OTHER PANELISTS THAT THEY DO NOT
HAVE THE FUNDS TO COMPLETE THE
INITIAL. OPERATING SEGMENTS OF
THE WAYS DOES THE I. U. S..
THIS IS TO GET HIGH SPEED TRAINS
UP AND RUNNING.
THIS SHOULD BE OUR MAIN FOCUS.
AND AGAIN WE ARE THE FUNDING
PARTNERS IN THIS PROJECT.
AS SUCH WE MUST PROVIDE
APPROPRIATE OVERSIGHT ANY PART
OF THE DECISION MAKING. ABOUT
ITS FUTURE.
TODAY'S HEARING IS ABOUT TWO
THINGS.
TAKING A LOOK AT THE STATUS OF
THE PROJECT AND TO FULLY DISCUSS
WHAT WILL BE EXPECTED FROM US
THE LEGISLATURE.
IF THE PROJECT IS
TO PROCEED.
MEMBERS LAST TIME THIS COMMITTEE
HEARD FROM THE AUTHORITIES WHEN
WE REVIEWED THE DRAFT TWENTY
SIXTEEN BUSINESS PLAN.
THE TWENTY SIXTEEN PLAN SIGNALED
A MAJOR SHIFT IN THE DEVELOPMENT
OF THE HIGH SPEED RAIL SYSTEM.
THE PLANTS WHICH THE IOWA AS THE
INITIAL OPERATING SYSTEM FROM
SOUTH.
TWO NORTH.
DO CAN EXAMINE IS A DOUCHE AFTER
IN NORTH NORTHERN KERN COUNTY.
THE PLAN ALSO LAID OUT A MORE
REALISTIC FUNDING SCHEME
ALTHOUGH. THERE WERE MANY.
RISKS INVOLVED.
AND A LOT HAS HAPPENED SINCE
THEN.
CONSTRUCTION CENTRAL VALLEY
CONTINUES TO MOVE FORWARD.
MAJOR STRUCTURES HAVE BEEN
COMPLETED BY MORE THAN SIXTEEN
HUNDRED CRAFTS.
CRAFTSMAN IN THAT PROCESS.
I HAVE BEEN TO THE VALLEY TO SEE
THE PROJECT AND IS VERY
IMPRESSIVE.
IT ALSO HAS IT ALSO HAS MADE AN
UNDENIABLE IMPACT ON THE PEOPLE
AND THE ECONOMY. RIGHT NOW IN
THE CENTRAL VALLEY.
THE AUTHORITY SUCCESSFULLY MET
THE DEADLINES FOR FEDERAL
RECOVERY ACT FUNDS.
AND BEGAN SPENDING THE
PROPOSITION ONE EIGHT BOND FUNDS
I'M CONSTRUCTION.
TO BOOK IN PROJECTS CALTRAIN IN
THE NORTH AND THE ROSECRANS.
MARK.
MARK
MY QUIRK REAL. GREAT I ALWAYS
CALL ROSECRANS
GREAT SO SEPARATION IN THE SOUTH
ARE MOVING FORWARD.
THE AUTHORITY ITSELF HAS BEEN
THROUGH SOME CHANGES.
WITH FORMER CAST A.
SECRETARY BRIAN KELLY REPLACING.
FORMER DIRECTOR.
CHAU JUST MORALES.
AND BRINGING IN NEW MANAGEMENT
STAFF WITH EXPERIENCE BOTH IN
OVERSEEING LARGE CONSTRUCTION
PROJECTS.
AND COMPLEX.
ORGANIZATIONS.
AND MOSTLY IMPORTANT.
THE AUTHORITY UNDER TOOK A
COMPREHENSIVE COST REVIEW FOR
ONGOING CONSTRUCTION.
IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY.
THIS REVIEW PREVENT PRODUCE WHAT
THEY CALL A TRUE COST TO
COMPLETE.
NUMBER FOR THE EXISTING
CONSTRUCTION PACKAGES.
WITH COUPLE CAVIAR.
AND THE AUTHORITY ANNOUNCED A
TWO POINT EIGHT BILLION DOLLAR
INCREASE OVER THE PREVIOUS
ESTIMATE OF SEVEN POINT EIGHT
BILLION.
WELL THIS IS TROUBLING TO HEAR
IT IS WHAT IT IS.
AND NECESSARY TO ACT TO BE
ACCURATE AND TRANSPARENT ABOUT
THE PROJECT GOING FORWARD.
THESE NEW COST ESTIMATES OR
INCLUDED AND IN THE TWENTY
EIGHTEEN DRAFT BUSINESS PLAN.
THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN DRAFT
BUSINESS PLAN CONTINUES THE
COMMITMENT TO A NORTHERN IOS OR
SILICON VALLEY TO CENTRAL VALLEY
LINE. WHICH IS EXTENDED.
SO THAT IT STARTS IN SAN
FRANCISCO AND ENDS IN
BAKERSFIELD BAKERSFIELD.
THE COST OF THE IOS IS ESTIMATED
TO BE TWENTY NINE POINT FIVE
BILLION DOLLARS.
AND THIS INCLUDES THE CURRENT
TEN POINT SIX BILLION FOR THE
ONGOING CENTRAL VALLEY
CONSTRUCTION.
THERE I WAS WOULD BE FUNDED BY A
COMBINATION OF PROP PROPOSITION
ONE A BONDS.
FEDERAL FUNDS CAP AND TRADE PAY
AS YOU GO. AND CAP AND TRADE
FINANCING.
THIS IS THE SAME FUNDING SCHEME
THAT WAS LAID OUT IN THE TWENTY
SIXTEEN BUSINESS PLAN.
WHICH HINGES ON A SUCCESSFUL
LONG TERM FINANCING OF FUTURE
CAP AND TRADE FUNDS.
THE A F. ORDEAL OUTLINES THREE
CRITICAL ELEMENTS TO MAKE THIS
FINANCING WORK.
THREE THINGS THE LEGISLATURE
MUST DO.
STAN CAP AND TRADE THROUGH.
TWENTY FIFTY.
PROVIDE A MINIMUM GUARANTEE OF
FUNDS EVERY YEAR TO THE
AUTHORITY FROM CAP AND TRADE OR
OTHER STATE FUNDS.
ENSURE FUTURE CAP AND TRADE
FUNDS FOR THE AUTHORITY.
WILL WILL NOT BE RESTRICTED
REDISTRIBUTED OR. IMPAIRED.
NOT ANY OF THESE ARE EASY.
FACT ALL WOULD BE EXTREMELY
DIFFICULT AND MAY REQUIRE A VOTE
OF THE PEOPLE.
THIS IS EXACTLY WHY WE NEED TO
FULLY UNDERSTAND THE OPTIONS IN
IMPLICA IMPLICATIONS.
OF OF INACTION.
MEMBERS.
WE HAVE TO GO INTO THIS WITH OUR
EYES WIDE OPEN.
WE CONTINUE.
TO EVALUATE.
WELL PREVIOUS BUSINESS PLANS
HAVE PROVIDED SOME UPDATE TO THE
VISION OF HEIS HOW HIGH SPEED
RAIL COULD BE ACCOMPLISHED.
WE'RE APPROACHING A POINT WHERE.
WE DECIDE TO MAKE THE SACRIFICES
AND COMMITMENTS NECESSARY TO SEE
THIS THROUGH.
OR WE COME UP.
WITH ALTERNATIVES.
THIS BUSINESS PLAN LAYS OUT THE
NEEDS AND RISKS OF MOVING
FORWARD.
AND WE NEED TO REALLY CONSIDER
BOTH IN THE SYRIAN AND
APPRECIATE MISTER KELLY'S.
PULLING THE BANDAID OFF ON THIS
BUSINESS PLAN.
THIS IS REAL.
THIS NO SMOKING MIRRORS INVOLVED
IN THIS ONE.
WE WILL HEAR TODAY FROM BRIAN
KELLY THE HIGH SPEED RAIL
AUTHORITIES CHIEF EXECUTIVE
OFFICER.
WE'VE ASKED CEO KILLER TO BRIBE
PROVIDE US A BRIEF OVERVIEW OF
THE BUSINESS PLAN.
AND I UNDERSTAND YOUR STAFF WITH
HIM TODAY.
THE CAN HELP ANSWER ANY
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS WE MIGHT
HAVE.
WE'VE ALSO ASK HIM.
TO THEN WALK US THROUGH CLEARLY
IN DIRECT THE FINANCIAL PLAN FOR
THE SYSTEM.
WE WILL THEN HEAR FROM
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE AND
WE HAVE THEIR CAP AND TRADE
EXPERT.
HERE FOR ANY QUESTIONS OF THE
COMMITTEE.
WE'LL ALSO HEAR FROM THE HIGH
SPEED RAIL PEER REVIEW GROUP.
WHOSE WORK WE SHALL SHOULD ALL
BE GRATEFUL FOR.
THESE PRIVATE CITIZENS ARE
PUTTING THEIR YEARS OF EXPERTISE
INTO HELPING US GOVERN THIS
MONUMENTAL PROJECT.
AND WE OWE THEM A GREAT DEBT OF
GRATITUDE.
FINE WE WILL HEAR FROM
REPRESENTATIVES OF OUR REGIONAL
PARTNERS WITHOUT WHOM HIGH SPEED
RAIL SIMPLY COULD NOT WORK.
WE'VE ASKED OUR PANELISTS
HASSAN.
GET OUT.
NICARAGUA WITH HIS GAG IN JIM
HER NOT FROM CALTRANS UPDATES
ON.
THE PROGRESS OF THEIR ONGOING
BOOK IN PROJECTS CALTRAIN IN THE
NORTH.
AND BOTH OF ROSECRANS MARKET.
GREAT SEPARATION LOS ANGELES LOS
ANGELES UNION STATION PROJECT IN
THE SOUTH.
MEMBERS.
PROCEEDING WITH THIS PROJECT.
WILL NOT BE FOR THE FAINT
OF HARD.
SO WHAT'S GOING TO FULLY
INFORMED.
WITH A CLEAR UNDERSTANDING OF
WHAT WE WILL TAKE.
GET READY TO BUCKLE UP.
MR FUNG IF YOU HAVE ANY COMMENTS
I'D. LIKE TO INCLUDE YOU RIGHT
NOW.
I THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I'LL BE
VERY BRIEF SINCE OUT WE WANT TO
GET INTO THE QUESTIONS OF THE
PRESENTATIONS BUT HOW I THINK
THE PANEL MEMBERS FOR BEING HERE
TODAY TO DISCUSS THE REAL
CHALLENGES FACING. HIGH SPEED
RAIL AUTHORITY OF AS ELECTED
OFFICIALS IT IS OUR DUTY TO
ENSURE THAT STATE AGENCIES
OPERATE IN A TRANSPARENT MANNER
AND THAT TAXPAYERS MONEY IS
BEING USED EFFICIENTLY.
CALIFORNIANS WORK HARD FOR THEIR
MONEY.
AND WE MUST WORKING JUST AS HARD
TO PROTECT IT.
I HOPE THAT TODAY'S HEARING CAN
PROVIDE THE ANSWERS TO THESE
PRESSING QUESTIONS AND I
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK.
THANK YOU VICE CHAIR.
SO WE HAVE THE PANELISTS AT THE.
THE.
AT THE READY WE HEAR FROM EACH
OF THEM AND THEN I'M GOING TO
ASK THEM ALL TO STAY AT THE
TABLE.
AT WE HAVE ARTISTS
OR PRESENTATIONS. LIKE HAVE YOU
ALL AVAILABLE FOR ROUND TABLE
DISCUSSIONS FOR YOUR BRIEF
PRESENTATIONS. MEMBERS LET'S TRY
TO HOLD OFF ON OUR QUESTIONS
UNTIL WE GET THROUGH ALL THE
PRESENTATIONS.
AND FOR THE PUBLIC THERE WILL BE
AMPLE TIME.
TO HEAR FROM YOU FOLLOWING THE
PANEL DISCUSSION.
BECAUSE I SUSPECT MANY OF YOU
WANT TO SPEAK A MASS I'M GONNA
ASK TO MAKE.
I ASK YOU TO MAKE YOU COME
COMMENTS COMPLETE BUT SO ST.
AND IF IT MIRRORS ANOTHER
PERSON'S COMMENT PLEASE JUST SAY
DITTO AND WITH THAT PERSON'S
NAME.
AND TO THE EXTENT YOU CAN HELP
US FOCUS ON SPECIFIC ITEMS
DISCUSSING TODAY THAT WOULD BE
VERY MUCH APPRECIATED.
WITH THAT.
LET'S GET IT ON THE.
MISTER CHAIR.
MISTER MC OWNER.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN.
I'M BRIAN KELLY SEE OVER THE.
CALIFORNIA HIGH SPEED RAIL
FORTY.
PLEASE BE HERE TODAY AND
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TALK ABOUT THE DRAFT TWENTY
EIGHTEEN BUSINESS PLAN.
ON MARCH NINTH THE AUTHORITY
RELEASED THIS PLAN UP FOR PUBLIC
REVIEW.
AND COMMENTED DRAFT TWENTY
EIGHTEEN A PLAN.
PREVENTS OUR SITE PRESENTS
PRESENTS A VISION FOR
IMPLEMENTING. THE NATION'S FIRST
HIGH SPEED RAIL SYSTEM IN THE
FACE OF CHALLENGES.
THAT PROJECTS AROUND THE WORLD
OF SIMILAR MAGNITUDE AND
COMPLEXITY HAVE FACED AND
SUCCESSFULLY ADDRESSED.
FOR THE FIRST TIME IN THIS DRAFT
PLAN THE AUTHORITIES ASSIGNING
COSTS.
TO THE RISKS PREVIOUSLY
IDENTIFIED IN PRIOR PLANTS.
AND REPORTS AND PRESENT A
BASELINE COST ESTIMATE. FOR ALL
PROJECTS SECTIONS.
ALSO FOR THE FIRST TIME.
THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN DRAFT
PLANNED DISCONTINUES THE PAST
PRACTICE
OF ESTIMATING PROJECT COSTS WITH
THE SPECIFIC DOLLAR ESTIMATE.
INSTEAD THE PLAN ESTIMATES COST
UTILIZING A BASELINE ESTIMATE
AND RANGES.
CONSISTENT WITH BEST INDUSTRY
PRACTICES FOR MEGA PROJECTS.
THE REVISED BASELINE COST
ESTIMATES
SHOWN INCREASING COSTS LARGELY
DRIVEN BY THE EFFECTS OF
INFLATION.
INCREASED CONTINGENCY IN
PREVIOUSLY IDENTIFIED
CONSTRUCTION DELAYS IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY.
THESE AREAS MAKE UP ABOUT EIGHTY
THREE PERCENT OF THE COST
INCREASES ASSOCIATED.
WITH THE FULL PHASE ONE SYSTEM
BILL THEM.
THE SCHEDULE FOR THE VALUE
VALLEY SERVICE FROM SAN
FRANCISCO TO BAKERSFIELD IN THE
FOR FACE ONE SERVICE. FROM SAN
FRANCISCO TO LOS ANGELES IN
ANAHEIM.
OR PUSHED OUT BY FOUR YEARS
RESPECTIVELY.
SCHEDULED TO BE AFFECTED
PRIMARILY BY THE TIMING AND
AVAILABILITY OF FUNDING. FOR
PROJECT IMPLEMENTATION.
THE DRAFT PLAN ALSO OUTLINES A
FINANCING STRATEGY CONSISTENT
WITH THE ONE OUTLINED IN THE
TWENTY SIXTEEN BUSINESS PLAN.
TO BETTER ALIGN THE TIMING IN
AVAILABILITY OF CAP AND TRADE
FUNDS.
SO THE PROJECT CAN BE DELIVERED
IN A MANNER THAT PROVIDE
BENEFITS TO CALIFORNIANS AT THE
EARLIEST POSSIBLE TIME.
IN THE FACE OF THESE CHALLENGES
THE DRAFT PLAN PROPOSES TO
CONTINUE.
A STRATEGIC INVESTMENT STRATEGY
THAT BUILDS INFRASTRUCTURE.
THAT WILL BE LINKED OVER TIME TO
PROVIDE MOBILITY ECONOMIC AND
ENVIRONMENTAL BENEFITS THE
CALIFORNIANS.
AND INITIATE HIGH SPEED RAIL
SERVICE IS SOON AS POSSIBLE.
TOWARD THAT END. THE DROUGHT
BUSINESS PLAN IDENTIFIES THE
FOLLOWING INVESTMENT PRIORITIES
IAN ARE CONSTRAINED FUNDING
SCENARIO.
FIRST WE MEET OUR COMMITMENTS TO
OUR FEDERAL FEDERAL FUNDING
PARTNER.
IF WE WILL COMPLETE THE HUNDRED
NINETEEN MILE SEGMENT IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY. INCOMPLETE THE
ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEWS FOR A THE
ENTIRE PHASE ONE SYSTEM.
BETWEEN SAN FRANCISCO LOS
ANGELES IN ANAHEIM BY TWENTY
TWENTY TWO AS REQUIRED IN OUR
FEDERAL GRANT AGREEMENT.
SECOND WE EXTEND THE VALUE
VALLEY SERVICE FROM SAN
FRANCISCO TO BAKERSFIELD.
THE DRUG USINESS PLAN
RECOGNIZES THE HIGH RIDERSHIP
AND REVENUE POTENTIAL. OF
LEAKING THIS LEAK LINKING THE
SILICON VALLEY BUT THE CENTRAL
VALLEY BETWEEN SAN FRANCISCO.
ALL THE WAY TO BAKERSFIELD.
THE PROPOSAL WOULD DELIVER TO DO
TWENTY FOUR MILES OF HIGH SPEED
RAIL READY INFRASTRUCTURE FOR
USE BY TWENTY TWENTY SEVEN.
THE PLAN PROPOSES TO CONSTRUCT
HIGH SPEED RAIL. ALREADY
INFRASTRUCTURE IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY BETWEEN BAKERSFIELD AND
MADERA. IN THE SILICON VALLEY
BETWEEN GILROY AND SAN
FRANCISCO.
TO REDUCE TRAVEL TIMES FOR
EXISTING PASSENGER RAIL SYSTEMS.
EXPAND CLEAN ELECTRIFIED
SERVICE.
AND PREPARE THE CORRIDORS FOR
TESTING IN POTENTIAL EARLY HIGH
SPEED RAIL OPERATIONS.
FOURTH WE ISOLATE THE TUNNELING
IN THE POTATO PASSES THE FINAL
MISSING LINK TO COMPLETE THE
BALLOT ABOUT A SERVICE.
WE ENGAGE PUBLIC AND PRIVATE
SECTOR EXPERTISE TO EXAMINE AND
REFINED DESIGN OPTIONS.
OPTIMIZE OPERATIONAL EFFICIENCY
LIMIT COSTS AND DEVELOP
INNOVATIVE FUNDING INNOVATIVE
FUNDING OPTIONS FOR THAT SEGMENT
OF THE PROJECT.
AND FIVE WE CONTINUE THE BOOK
AND INVESTMENT IN SOUTHERN AND
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA.
THE DRAFT BUSINESS PLAN
CONTINUES TO PRIORITIZE
IMPROVING LOS ANGELES UNION
STATION.
THE BURBANK ANAHEIM CORRIDOR AND
THE ELECTED ELECTRIFICATION OF
CALTRAIN COURT OR IN THE BAY
AREA.
THE PLAN IN SOME REFLECTS THE
AUTHORITIES COMMITMENT TO APPLY
LESSONS LEARNED AND TO MAKE
ORGANIZATIONAL IMPROVEMENTS
NECESSARY. TO DELIVER THIS
PROJECT TO INITIATE HIGH SPEED
RAIL SERVICE.
BETWEEN SILICON VALLEY IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY SOON AS POSSIBLE
WHILE COMPLETING ENVIRONMENTAL
WORK.
AND MAKING IMPORTANT VESTMENTS
IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
ASSISTANT WITH ACTION TAKEN BY
THE LEGISLATURE TO INVEST WHAT
OCCULT BOOK AND FUNDS FROM PART
PROPOSITION ONE A.
WITH THE RELEASE IN THE TWENTY
EIGHTEEN DRAFT BUSINESS PLAN
WE'VE INITIATED A SIXTY DAY. A
PERIOD OF PUBLIC REVIEW AND
COMMENT IT CLOSES ON MAY SEVENTH
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN.
THE FINAL PLAN IS SCHEDULED TO
BE ADOPTED BY THE AUTHORITY
BOARD AT ITS HEARING DURING THE
THIRD WEEK OF MAY.
TO MY RIGHT OR TWO.
REPRESENTATIVES OF THAT OUR
EXECUTIVE TEAM.
ONE IS NEW TO THE AUTHORITY
THAT'S A JOE HEDGES WHO IS OUR
CHIEF OPERATING OFFICER WHO WE
BROUGHT DOWN FROM SEATTLE
WASHINGTON.
AND TO HIS RIGHT MY FAR RIGHT IS
RESPONDER CHIEF FINANCIAL
OFFICER FOR THE HIGH SPEED RAIL
FORTY.
WITH THAT SUMMARY MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS.
I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER YOUR
QUESTIONS TODAY.
SO IF YOU HAVE ANY OTHER OF
MEMBERS OF AT THEIR AT THE.
.
THE DIES DOWN FOOD LIKE TO
CONTINUE WILL GO AND ASK
QUESTIONS AT THE VERY END. YES
POSTING ANYTHING INCLUDE ANY
COMMENTS.
YOUR PLAN.
THOSE ARE MOSTLY HERE TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS WELL MOSTLY HERE TO
ANSWER QUESTIONS CANCER
CHAIRMAN.
SIR ANY QUESTIONS OF THE
COMMITTEE MISTER FUNG.
I THINK YOU OFFER FOR BEING
HERE.
HOW MUCH MONEY?
CURRENTLY EXIST THAT YOU HAVE
RIGHT NOW.
WHO A FEW CLUED?
HANDICAP TRADE COMMITMENT FROM.
THE SUCH A CAP AND TRADE LAST
YEAR.
WE DESCRIBED IN THE BUSINESS
PLAN IN RANGES.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FONG OF BECAUSE
THE CAP AND TRADE REVENUES BUT
VOLATILE SO LOYALISTS THAT
STIPULATE THAT HOW MUCH MONEY IF
YOU INCLUDE THAT.
WE ESTIMATE.
BETWEEN TWENTY.
ON THE LOW END IN ABOUT TWENTY
EIGHT BILLION ON THE HIGH END SO
YET TWENTY TO TWENTY EIGHT
BILLION CURRENTLY.
CORRECT ENHANCE.
AND YOU PROJECT IN THE BUSINESS
PLAN.
.
THAT THE POTENTIAL ESTIMATE IS
SEVENTY SEVEN TO NINETY EIGHT
BILLION.
THE BASELINE PROCESS MEANT FOR
THE ENTIRE PHASE ONE SYSTEM IS
IS THAT SEVENTY SEVEN BILLION
THAT'S RIGHT SO THERE'S A
THERE'S IT SO THERE'S A DELTA
OF.
FIFTY TWO AIR.
SEVENTY EIGHT BILLION DOLLARS
PLUS OR MINUS.
YEAH AS A RATIO OF.
A SORT OF IDENTIFIED FUNDING
FOR THE PROJECT AND OF FUNDING
WE HAVE IN HAND YEAH THAT'S IT
WE HAVE ABOUT A THIRD.
IS OPPOSED TO THE TWO THOUSAND
EIGHT WHEN THE. BOND MEASURE WAS
FIRST PASSED THE BOND PROVIDED
US ABOUT A FIFTH OF THE FUNDING
WE NEED FOR THE PROJECT.
OKAY.
AND AND I WANT TO FOCUS ON ON
PAGE FIFTEEN OF THE BUSINESS
PLAN THAT THE DRUG BUSINESS PLAN
YOU INDICATE THAT. THE POTATO
PASSED TUNNELS IS THE CRITICAL
LINK BETWEEN THE SILICON VALLEY
IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY. BUT.
RIGHT NOW YOU CANNOT AFFORD TO
CONSTRUCT A BECAUSE OF A QUOTE
FUNDING SHORTFALL.
.
WELL WHY DOES THE BUSINESSMEN
PROPOSED A BILL TO ORPHAN
SECTION TRACKS.
IF THERE'S NO WAY TO CONNECT
THEM.
OF MR FUNG THERE'S A COUPLE
REASONS FOR THAT ONE THE
AUTHORITY HAS HAD FOR SOMETIME A
PRINCIPLE OF. MAKING STRATEGIC
CONCURRENT INVESTMENTS
THROUGHOUT THE COURT OR THE CAN
BE LINKED TOGETHER OVER.
AND ALSO.
THAT AS A STRATEGY TO BRING A
MOBILITY BENEFITS FOR
CALIFORNIANS WITH TAXPAYER
MONEY.
IS SOON AS POSSIBLE SO WE
PROPOSE IN THIS PLAN IS TO MAKE
THE SAME KIND OF INVESTMENTS ON
THE SILICON VALLEY SIDE BY
EXTENDING THE ELECTRIFICATION
PROJECT ALL THE WAY TO GILROY.
SO WE'VE ELECTRIFIED TRAIN
SERVICE FROM GILROY TO SAN
FRANCISCO THAT BOTH CALTRAIN CAN
YOU CALTRAIN CAN USE IN THE
SHORT TERM.
AND REDUCE THEIR DIESEL.
TRAIN OPERATIONS BETWEEN KID A
GILROY IN SAN JOSE WOULD ALSO BE
A A A A A CORRIDOR THAT THAT WE
MAY BE ABLE TO USE. A WITH
EXPRESS TRAIN SOONER THAN TWENTY
TWENTY NINE PERHAPS ASSUMES
TWENTY TWENTY SIX OR TWENTY
TWENTY SEVEN. SIMILARLY IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY UNDER FEDERAL
GRANT AGREEMENT. AFTER WE MAKE
INVESTMENTS IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY WE ARE REQUIRED INTO THAT
AGREEMENT.
TO FIND OPERATIONAL INTERIM USE
FOR THE.
STRUCTURES THAT WE BUILD.
AND SO ON THAT SIDE WE ARE
PROPOSING TO EITHER A T. PUT
THOSE STRUCTURES TO USE THROUGH
EITHER EARLY ELECTRIFICATION.
COMBINING THAT WITH THE AMTRAK
SERVICE IS NOW AVAILABLE THE WAY
TO BAKERSFIELD FROM SACRAMENTO
WHERE THE BAY AREA. REDUCING
THAT TRAVEL TIME PROVIDING
ENOUGH.
USER BENEFIT IN THE INTERIM.
WHILE WE MOVE FOR THE BALLOT
VALLEY SECTION IN ESSENCE.
THE GAP OR FUNDING SHORTFALL WE
HAVE IS ABOUT THE PRICE OF THE
TOP.
AND SO WHAT WE.
PROPOSED TO DO HERE IS MAKE IN
ROME A USE AND INVESTMENTS ON
EACH SIDE OF THAT ISOLATE THE
TUNNEL IS THE ISSUE.
ENGAGE WITH THE.
INDUSTRY EXPERTS AND OTHERS ON
WHAT THE TUNNEL COULD IT SHOULD
LOOK LIKE IMPROVE PURSUE OPTIONS
FOR FUNDING OF THE TUNNEL. AND
THEN GET THE TIME A BILL SO WHAT
IS THE PRICE OF THE TITLE.
IT'S ESTIMATED A IT'S IT'S AN
EARLY A DESIGN RIGHT NOW IT'S
STILL THE ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW
PROCESS. SO IT'S SO KIND OF A
WIDE RANGE BECAUSE IT'S
ESTIMATED BETWEEN AND THE LOW
END OF FIVE ON THE HIGH END
ABOUT TWELVE BILLION.
AND. CURRENTLY YOU DON'T HAVE
YOU IDENTIFIED ANY.
FEDERAL STATE AND PRIVATE
FUNDING FOR THAT THAT GAP.
A NOT FOR THE GAP.
OKAY AND THEN. I IN TERMS OF.
.
OTHER THAN THE IN SORRY IT MAY
BE USEFUL TO SAY AGAIN BECAUSE.
WHAT WE HAVE IS THE CHAIRMAN
NOTED IN HIS OPENING REMARKS?
THERE'S A LOT OF UNCERTAINTY AND
RISK IN BOTH OUR COSTS AND OUR
FUNDING
AND ON THE FUNDING SIDE.
DEPENDING WHAT CAP AND TRADE
COMES IN THERE'S A SCENARIO
OUTLINED IN THE PLAN. WERE OF
CAP AND TRADE COMES IN THAT THE
HIGH END OUR COSTS WITH THE LOW
AND. WE HAVE NO GAP THAT'S
PROBABLY UNLIKELY SUI ESTIMATED
TO BE IN THE IN THE NEIGHBORHOOD
OF FIVE. TO TEN BILLION OF
WHITE.
WELL I THINK THE UNCERTAINTY IS.
RIGHT OKAY THAT'S THE IMMEDIATE
HIT THE NAIL ON THE HEAD THE
UNCERTAINTY AROUND THIS WHOLE
PROJECT IS EXPECTING WHAT GIVES
US AS MEMBERS PAUSE IN TERMS OF
OF OF. OF THIS WHOLE ENTIRE
PROJECT.
.
SO I AND ED I HEARD ON IN AN
ARTICLE THAT WAS MENTIONED THAT
IT. WOULD POTENTIAL YOU WOULD WE
WOULD YOU WOULD ASK OR I'D
RATHER IT WOULD ASK FOR.
A VOTE FOR FOR ADDITIONAL FUNDS
SO HOW MUCH IF THAT WERE TO
HAPPEN I PATHETICALLY HOW MUCH
MONEY WOULD YOU ASK.
IF THE DELTA IS.
FIFTY TO SEVENTY EIGHT BILLION
YEAH I'M NOT SURE.
WHAT?
A I THINK WAS A RECORD I THINK
THIS RICHER'S.
MENTION WHO AND RESPONSIBILITY
HARSH INFERNO OPENED UP THE
ANSWER THOUGH. YOU KNOW WE
ADDITIONAL FUND WE EVEN HAD A
DIALOGUE ABOUT THAT IN TERMS OF
WHETHER NOT THAT'S THE THE RIGHT
PURSUIT THE PURSUIT TO WE LAY
OUT IN THE PLAN IS UTILIZING THE
FUNDS THAT WE HAVE.
TO MAKE YOU KNOW INTERIM
INVESTMENTS NOW THAT PROVIDE
BENEFITS NOW ON EACH SIDE OF THE
TUNNEL AND ULTIMATELY YOU KNOW
COMPLETE THE ENVIRONMENTAL WORK
COMPLETE THE DESIGN WORK. AND
PURSUE FUNDING FOR THE TUNNEL
ELEMENT LATER AS WELL AS FOR
ELEMENTS IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
AFTER WE COMPLETE THAT
ENVIRONMENTAL WORK. SO YOU KNOW
BEYOND THAT I DON'T HAVE A PLAN
TO GO TO THE VOTERS FOR ANY
SPECIFIC AMOUNT OF MONEY FOR
THIS PROGRAM.
AND I ENTERED TO THE FEDERAL
FUNDS A MY UNDERSTANDING IS THAT
IF IF IT BOTHERS A TIME FRAME
THAT HAS TO BE COMPLETED FOR
THOSE FEDERAL FUNDS TO BE
UTILIZED OR THEY HAVE TO BE
REFUNDED BACK TO THE.
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IS THAT
CORRECT WE'VE RECEIVED THREE
POINT FOUR BILLION DOLLARS IN
FEDERAL FUNDS WE'VE ALREADY
SPENT TWO POINT FIVE BILLION OF
US.
THE REMAINING NINE HUNDRED
TWENTY EIGHT MILLION IS IN THE
FISCAL YEAR TEN APPROPRIATION
THAT WE HAVE NOT ACCESSED YET.
AND WILL USE AT A LATER TIME.
IF WE FAIL TO COMPLETE THE
CENTRAL VALLEY.
PART OR YOU KNOW THE WAY SHUT
DOWN THE PROJECT WE WOULD BE
SUBJECT OF REPAYMENT OF THE
FEDERAL FUNDS WE PARTY SPENT.
SO HOW MUCH OF THE FUNDS SO YOU
HAVE TO THE TWENTY FIVE TO
TWENTY BILLION YOU CURRENTLY
HAVE SO WHAT IS IT GOING TO BE
USED FOR RIGHT NOW.
BUT THE TWENTY TWENTY BILLION
DOLLAR YEAH WE WOULD UTILIZE
THOSE GUYS THAT SUGGESTED
EARLIER FOR. A COUPLE OF THINGS.
BUT ONE WE PROPOSE IN THIS PLAN
TO SPEND ABOUT FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS ON SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA WITH THE COLD BOOK
AND INVESTMENTS.
THE CHAIRMAN NOTED AGAIN GREAT
SEPARATION THAT AREA CALLED
ROSECRANS MARXUACH THAT IS.
AT ONETIME WAS THE MOST
DANGEROUS THAT RAILROAD THAT
TRAFFIC CROSSING IN THE STATE.
SO WE ARE FUNDING PARTNERS FOR
SEVENTY SIX MILLION ON THAT THE
REMAINING FOUR HUNDRED TWENTY
THREE MILLION WE WOULD USE FOR
REDEVELOPMENT AND AN EXPANSION
OF THE LA UNION STATION.
IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY WE WOULD
USE IT TO COMPLETE OUR WORK FOR
THE HUNDRED NINETEEN MILE
STRETCH THAT WE ARE NOW IN
CONSTRUCTION ON. WHO WOULD
EXPAND THATINDIVIDUAL SPILLED
MAKING THAT STRETCH
APPROXIMATELY A HUNDRED FORTY
MILES AND GET THAT TO BE A HIGH
SPEED RAIL ELECTRIFIED READY?
INFRASTRUCTURE AND WE WOULD
INVEST TO EXPAND OF THE
ELECTRIFICATION OF CALTRAIN ON
THE PENINSULA SIDE ALL THE WAY
TO GILROY. WHICH ULTIMATELY WE
ALSO WOULD WE NEED TO BE
ELECTRIFIED GET IN THE BAY AREA.
AND WE WOULD.
PURSUE.
FURTHER ALL ALL THE
ENVIRONMENTAL WORK ON A WHOLE
SEGMENT OF THE PROJECTS WOULD BE
PLEADED.
AND WE WOULD.
PURSUE.
FURTHER IMPROVEMENTS LEADING TO
THE TUNNEL SECTION ON BOTH THE
EAST AND WEST SIDE. OF THE.
OF THE VALUE VALLEY SERVICE OF
THE CRITICAL PASSED.
NOW IN TERMS OF YOU GIVEN.
A PRETTY WIDE RANGE IN TERMS OF
YOUR HIGH AND ANNUAL AT THE LOW
END AS.
SO YOU'VE SEVEN SEVEN BILLION TO
NINETY EIGHT BILLION HOW
RELIABLE ARE THOSE NUMBERS SINCE
WE'VE SEEN OVER TIME THOSE
NUMBERS HAVE CONTINUALLY
CHANGING.
YOU KNOW PRIOR TO MY ARRIVAL.
AT THE AUTHORITY.
THE THE BOARD HAD INITIATED
ACOSTA COMPLETE EXERCISE IN
EARLY TWENTY SEVENTEEN.
THE NUMBERS THAT ARE BEFORE YOU
WOULD WHICH WE CALL THE BASELINE
ESTIMATE.
IS THE RESULT OF THAT EXERCISE
THAT'S WHERE YOU GET THE TEN
POINT SIX BILLION IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY. THAT'S WE GET THE TWENTY
NINE POINT FIVE FOR THE BALLOT
ABOUT SERVICE AND THE SEVENTY
SEVEN BILLION FOR THE STATEWIDE.
A SERVICE SO THAT'S THE BASELINE
WHICH IS
I'VE DONE ON AN ESTIMATE OF
ALIGNMENTS WE WOULD USE.
CHEERIOS YOU NEED.
Ó SERIES OF OTHER IN THAT S.
INSIDE OF A TRIP THAT SEEMS TO
FULLY FUNDING AT THE GAP THAT IT
AT THE PERSON TIRE SYSTEM AT
SEVENTY SEVEN BE THE WHOLE.
ANAHEIM TO SAN FRANCISCO
SERVICE PHASE ONE.
.
SO THAT'S THE BASELINE.
WHAT WE ARE DOING DIFFERENTLY IN
THIS PLANS BEFORE IS NOT DONE IN
THE PAST?
IS A YOU KNOW I'M I'M
UNCOMFORTABLE COMING HERE.
.
FOR PROJECT OF THIS MAGNITUDE
AND WE DON'T HAVE.
ALL THE ENVIRONMENTAL WORK DONE
WE DON'T HAVE FOR THE DESIGN
WORK DONE TO JUST LEAVE IT AT A
SIMPLE DOLLAR ESTIMATE.
SO WHAT I'VE INCLUDED HERE IS A
UTILIZING AYE AYE WHAT I WOULD
CALL BEST INDUSTRY PRACTICE
TO PROVIDE A RANGE OF AROUND
THAT BASELINE.
IF WE MANAGE WELL.
GOING FORWARD WE CAN COME IN
BELOW THAT SEVENTY SEVEN WE HAVE
A LOW RANGE.
THREE WHICH IS CLOSE TO THE
ESTIMATE FROM THE TWENTY SIXTEEN
BUSINESS PLAN. AND A HIGH OF
NINETY EIGHT WHICH IS.
GENERALLY THE SWING UNDER
INDUSTRY PRACTICE AT THIS LEVEL
OF PROJECT DEVELOPMENT IS TWENTY
PERCENT BELOW THIRTY PERCENT
ABOVE. WHERE WE KNOW MORE LIKE
IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY THAT SWING
IS LOWER BECAUSE FIVE PERCENT
BELOW FIFTY PERCENT ABOVE? SO WE
USED THE BASELINE TO LAY OUT OUR
BEST ESTIMATE AND THEN REPLIED
INDUSTRY BEST PRACTICES ON WHAT
THOSE SWINGS COULD.
AND IF I'M CORRECT THIS ALREADY
HAS MORE THAN A BILLION DOLLARS
IN UNSPENT CAP AND TRADE
REVENUES
WHY HASN'T THE AUTHORITY SPENT.
OR WHAT IS WHAT IS IT PLAYING TO
DO WITH THAT BILLION DOLLARS IF
THEY HAVEN'T SPENT IT ALREADY.
.
WE HAVE SPENT SOME CAPITA RATE
DOLLARS A AND NOT A HUGE AMOUNT
BUT SOME IN THE AT CALTRAIN
CORRIDOR FOR THE ELECTRIFICATION
PROJECT. RUSSELL YEAH BICU
RUSS FUNKY FINANCIAL OFFICER WE
HAVE ABOUT A LITTLE OVER BILLION
DOLLARS IN CASH FOR PROP ONE A
AND ALSO LITTLE BILLION.
BUT OVER BILLION DOLLARS FOR CAP
AND TRADE OF THOSE ARE DEAF ON
TARGETED FOR THE CENTRAL VALLEY
SAYING THAT WERE CURRENTLY
UNDERWAY NOW.
SO THOSE A BEACON FOR THE
CENTRAL VALLEY SEGMENT ALSO TO
MAKE SURE WE MEET OUR OUR
AGREEMENT WHICH IS A
REQUIRES A FIFTY.
BUT LOOK THE LAST FEW QUESTIONS
AND YOU KNOW THAT MY COLLEAGUES
CONTINUE ON.
.
I THINK IN THE BUSINESS PLAN AS
I READ IT.
YOU PROPOSE FOR I GUESS FOR THE
FIRST TIME OR MAYBE THIS IS THE
FIRST I'VE HEARD OF PUBLICLY
INDICATED THAT YOU WOULD.
POTENTIALLY BORROW AGAINST THE
CAP AND TRADE REVENUES.
WOULDN'T AND THAT.
BE USING A LOT OF THE CAP AND
TRADE DOLLARS FOR DEBT SERVICE.
YELLOW ME UP START THIS AND
RUSSELL HAVE YOU HIT A JUMP IN.
THAT'S NOT A NEW IDEA IN THIS
BUSINESS PLAN IN THE TWENTY
SIXTEEN BUSINESS PLAN.
THE SCENARIO THAT WAS PRESENTED
THAT PLANNED ASSUME TO FINANCING
OF CAP AND TRADE AS WELL.
WHAT WE DID IN THIS PLAN WAS A
ARTICULATED WITH A LITTLE MORE
SPECIFICITY WHAT WOULD BE? WHAT
THE INDUSTRY IS RECOMMENDED THE
KIND OF THINGS YOU NEED TO MAKE
THE CAP AND TRADE DOLLARS
UNANSWERABLE? USED TO BE A
STABLE SOURCE OF FUNNY TO BE.
INVESTMENT GRADE SO WE'RE
LOOKING FOR A FLOOR OF A
COMMITMENT AN EXTENSION OF CAP
AND TRADE DOLLARS TO TWENTY
FIFTY.
AND.
ANON IMPAIRMENT OF LANGUAGES
IDEAL.
ALSO TO GET INVESTMENT GRADE
RATING SO THOSE ARE SORT OF
THREE THINGS THE INDUSTRY IS
RECOMMENDED THAT YOU NEED.
TO GET THE HIGHEST INVESTMENT
GRADE RATING FOR THE FINANCING
BUT THE IDEA FINANCING CAP AND
TRADE.
IS REALLY HAS TO DO WITH BEING
ABLE TO.
BRING DOLLARS FORWARD TO MEET
OUR CAPITAL CONSTRUCTION COSTS
AT THE TIME THE KAPPA
CONSTRUCTION USED TO BE BUILT.
THAT DOING A MAKE A PROJECT OF
THIS MAGNITUDE ON A PAGE YOU GO
BASIS WOULD HAVE US CONSTRUCTING
THIS THING ALL THE WAY OUT OF
TWENTY FIFTY YEAR BEYOND.
AND SO.
THE FINANCING ELEMENT IS SIMPLY
TO BRING DOLLARS FORD SEEING GET
THE WORK DONE SOONER.
I GUESS MY MY CONCERN IS THAT I
DON'T I DON'T KNOW OF ONE WORD
AND WHEN DID IN THE DEBATE OF
CAP AND TRADE THAT THERE WAS ANY
JUSTIFICATION USE CAP AND TRADE
TO PAY BOND DEBT AND SO IN. IN
TERMS OF INVESTING CAPITAL
DOLLARS I THINK A LOT OF FOLKS
WERE ANTICIPATING THAT YOU WOULD
FUND PROJECTS.
ACTUAL DELIVERABLE PROJECTS
SENSITIVE I USING IT TOOK THE
FUN BONDS.
AND SO THAT'S THAT'S THAT'S
CLEARLY A CONCERN THERE AND THEN
IN TERMS OF THE ASSUMPTIONS YOU
MAKE YOU'RE ASSUMING THOUGH THAT
THE LEGISLATURE EXTENSIVE AND
TRADE. POST
TO TWENTY FIFTY WHICH IS AN OPEN
QUESTION CURRENTLY RIGHT YEAH
IT'S AN OPEN QUESTION ALTHOUGH
AGAIN I WOULD SO SAFE FROM A
PLANNING PERSPECTIVE WE UTILIZE
THE. ASSUMPTION FROM TWENTY
SIXTEEN PLAN WHICH HAD CAP AND
TRADE GOING OUT THAT FAR WE KNOW
THAT IT WAS EXTENDED LAST YEAR
WE DON'T NEED THE. EXTENSION OR
THE.
THE FINANCING IMMEDIATELY DONE
SOMETHING WE NEED DIRECTLY IN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN WERE HOPING TO
BE ABLE TO FINANCE IN THE
TIMELINE OF ROUGHLY. TWENTY ONE
TO TWENTY THREE.
ROUGHLY THAT TIMELINE.
AND SO.
.
THAT'S WHY WE'VE WE'VE LAID OUT
IS AGAIN THIS WAS FIRST RAISED
IN THE TWENTY SIXTEEN BUSINESS
PLAN HERE WERE SAYING THESE ARE
THE KINDS OF THINGS YOU NEED TO
GET INVESTMENT GRADE. A RATING
YOU KNOW I THINK I'D SAY FURTHER
ABOUT FINANCING THE CAP AND
TRADE REP.
MONEY IS.
THE CAP AND TRADE PROGRAM TO
DEDICATE MONEY TO THIS MAKE A
PROJECT.
IT IS NOT UNUSUAL FOR MANY OF
THE SALES TAX COUNTY'S FROM
AROUND THE STATE THAT DEDICATE
SALES TAX MONEY TO
TRANSPORTATION PROJECTS TO BOND
AGAINST THOSE REVENUES.
IT'S AT A VERY COMMON FOR
PROJECTS OF THIS SIZE AND SCOPE.
SO THAT YOU CAN PULL THE CASH
FOR DAY AGAIN BE ABLE TO MEET
CAPITAL NEEDS OF THE PROJECT IN
A TIMELY WAY BUT. BUT ESTIMATE
AND THAT YOU WOULD BE USING SOME
OF THE CAPITAL DOLLARS TO PAY
DOWN DEBT AND INTEREST ON DEBT
CORRECT THAT THREAT.
SO.
YOU I THINK THE PUBLIC ANYBODY
TO KNOW THAT THAT MONEY IS BEING
DIVERTED FROM ONE PROJECT
PROTECT FOR WHAT ONE PROJECT TO
PAY FOR IT FOR FOR DEBT SERVICE
WHAT IT WOULD BE PAID A DEBT
SERVICE TO PAY FOR THE
CONSTRUCTION OF THE PROJECT.
THEN BUT I GUESS MY LAST
QUESTION IS IN TERMS OF READING
THAT. THE BUSINESS PLAN PROJECT
IS A PLAN I MEAN THERE ARE OUT
STILL A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF
UNFUNDED ASSETS.
IT'S PROJECT CORRECT.
I'M NOT SURE WHICH MEAN BY
UNFUNDED ASSETS I'M SORRY GO
THERE. IF ON PAGE FORTY ONE YOU
YOU DO
TERM TO TAKE A PASS AS UNFUNDED
ASSET AND THERE ARE A LOT OF
ASSUMPTIONS.
BEING PUT INTO THAT YOU'RE
ASSUMING A LOT OF REVENUE THAT
POTENTIALLY MAY NOT MATERIALIZE
SO THERE IS A LOT OF STILL.
GAPS IN THIS BUSINESS PLAN.
THERE IS NO QUICKLY BOOK. THIS
PROJECT FROM DAY ONE.
HAS NEVER HAD ALL THE FUNDING IT
NEEDS
TO BE COMPLETED.
AS I SAID AT THE OUTSET IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHT WHEN THE VOTERS
APPROVE THE BOND THAT PROVIDED
ONE FIFTH OF THE MONEY FOR THE
THE ENTIRE COMPLETED A PROJECT.
BUT NOW WE HAVE ABOUT ONE THIRD
OF WHAT WE NEED FOR THE ENTIRE
COMPLETION A PROJECT.
THEREFORE OUR STRATEGY HAS BEEN
TO INVEST THE DOLLARS THAT WE DO
HAVE.
TO PROVIDE THE BENEFITS TO THE
PUBLIC AS SOON AS WE CAN IN AN
INCREMENTAL WAY.
AND THAT'S WHAT WE CONTINUE TO
PURSUE IN THIS PLAN UNTIL.
WE'VE WE IDENTIFY ADDITIONAL
FUNDING FOR ELEMENTS OF THE
PROJECT
I WOULD NOTE THAT.
THAT'S NOT UNCOMMON PRACTICE TO
BUILD TRANSIT SYSTEMS.
AROUND STATE YOU BUILD WHICH
YOU HAVE WITH THE MONEY YOU HAVE
IN ULTIMATELY YOU EXPAND OVER
TIME WOULD MORE MONEY IS MADE
AVAILABLE FOR EXPANSION. BUT I
APPRECIATE THE CANDOR I JUST
THINK THAT CALIFORNIANS ARE NOW
SEEING THIS BILL COMING FORWARD
AND I DON'T THINK THAT THE.
I DON'T THINK THEY REALLY TRULY
UNDERSTAND THE TRUE GAP THAT
EXISTS BETWEEN THAT THE FUNDS
THAT WE CURRENTLY HAVE AS A
STATE AND THE LACK OF FUNDS THAT
PERSON AT NECESSARY TO BUILD
THIS PROJECT. GOING FORWARD
THANK YOU.
HERE MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE OF
QUESTIONS.
OF THE. PALACE MISTER GIBSON.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WAS CHAIRMAN
OF CERTAINLY APPRECIATE I'M THE
NEW KID ON THE BLOCK GOT THIS MY
SECOND MEETING. OF CHASTISED
COMMITTING THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER CHAIR FOR CONVENING THIS
SORT OF HAS BEEN ENLIGHTENING
EXPERIENCE MEET YOU BROUGHT
CLAYTON CERTAIN WELCOME YOUR
OFFICE REACHING OUT TO ME
PERSONALLY.
AND YOU KNOW LETTING ME KNOW
THE HISTORY THIS BEHIND THIS I
THINK THAT AGAIN THE VOTERS OF.
CALIFORNIANS VOTED TO MOVE THIS
PROJECT FOR.
SURLIS.
THE GOVERNOR'S WISHES TO.
MOVE THERE'S PROJECT FOR AND
KNOW THIS PROJECT HAS HAD SOME
SHORTFALLS BASE WHEN YOU JUST.
AS YOU DESCRIBED IN TERMS OF THE
FINANCIAL SHORTFALL THAT EXISTED
CERTAINLY YOU DON'T KNOW.
HOW THE? ENVIRONMENT IMPACT IS
GOING TO AFFECT THAT PARTICULAR
BUDGET APPRECIATE YOU STATING
THAT UP FRONT.
CERTAINLY I THINK THAT IT'S
GOING TO BE BENEFICIAL IF IN
FACT THIS PROJECT CAN GET OFF
THE GROUND. AND I THINK THAT IS
DEMONSTRATED BY YOUR LEADERSHIP.
BEING BROUGHT HERE TO THE
COMMITTEE.
AND ALSO YOUR NEW ROLE
RESPONSIBILITY.
LET ME ASK YOU JUST THIS THIS
QUESTION CAN WE GET IT DONE.
YEAH I BELIEVE SO I MEAN.
I HAD A PRETTY GOOD JOB.
BUT I TOOK THIS ONE BECAUSE I
YOU KNOW I BELIEVE. I BELIEVE IN
THIS PROJECT I THINK IT'S THE
MOST.
A TRANSFORMATIVE PROJECT I'VE
SEEN IN TWENTY FIVE YEARS OF
WORKING TRANSPORTATION POLICY IN
CALIFORNIA.
I THINK IT PROVIDES MOBILITY
ECONOMIC AND ENVIRONMENTAL
BENEFITS LIKE.
NO PROJECT I'VE SEEN BEFORE.
SO.
YOU LOOK WE GOT WORK TO DO.
WERE GONNA NEED TO PARTNER WITH
YOU WE'RE GONNA NEED A
CONTINUING PARTNERSHIP WITH
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO GET IT
DONE.
I THINK WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
PROPOSE IN THIS PLAN AND
RECOGNIZING THE CHALLENGES IN
THE CHAIRMAN DID A FINE JOB OF
ARTICULATING. ALL THE RISKS THAT
THIS PROJECT HAS BEEN OPERATING.
UNDER.
YOU KNOW I I I THINK YOU KNOW
OUR JOB IS TO IS TO.
YOU KNOW
PUSH TOWARD AS WE SAID MAKE THE
INVESTMENTS WE CAN MAKE TO
PROVIDE THE ME
BENEFITS THAT
PROVIDE AS WE GO.
AND ISOLATE THE ISSUES THAT
NEED FUNDING.
GOING FORWARD AND OF THAT'S
WHAT WE'VE LAID OUT IN THIS
PLAN.
THE PROJECT HAS AS I SAID
REPORT ECONOMIC BENEFITS AND
MOBILITY BENEFITS OF THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA.
AND.
ON YOU KNOW I THINK IT'S A VERY
IMPORTANT TO.
TO BRING THIS THING TO. TO
FRUITION.
THANK YOU.
STAR FOR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIR
OF.
I WANT A FALL OPEN ISSUE THAT I
BROUGHT UP A LAST YEAR AND.
IT KIND OF. MORE ELABORATE I
THINK WITH THE POINTS THAT.
.
AND MEMBER FONG THE SENATE
TRYING TO OUT BRING OUT THE VICE
CHAIR. AYE IN THAT'S ABOUT.
YOU KNOW I'M PESSIMISTIC ABOUT
THE PROJECT A BE BEING COMPLETED
BUT IN THE. WORST SITUATION I
SEE IS THAT IF SOMETHING GETS
PARTIALLY COMPLETED AND WHAT
DOES PARTIALLY GET COMPLETED IS
INTERVIEWS.
SO THAT'S WHY I ALWAYS WANT TO
MAKE SURE TO KEEP ALWAYS ASKING
ABOUT THE QUESTION OF
COMPATIBILITY.
WITH EXISTING AMTRAK STOCK WITH
NORTH AMERICAN STANDARD GAUGE
THAT FOR.
FOUR FOOT TO EIGHT AND A HALF
INCH.
STANDARD GAUGE SO THAT I IF I
YOU YOU BUILD UP A NICE PATH
RIGHT DOWN THE CENTRAL VALLEY.
THEN THAT CAN BE USED BECAUSE
THE CURRENT PROBLEM WITH AMTRAK
AYE IS THAT IT USES RIGHT OF WAY
THAT SIR. NOT LEAST FROM A
PRIVATE COMPANIES AND IT DOESN'T
HAVE THE.
THE PRECEDENCE OVER THEIR
FREIGHT STOCK IN THAT IT ENDS UP
BEING ONE OF THE BIGGEST UP
PROBLEMS WITH THEIR EXISTING
AMTRAK SYSTEM. AYE IS A HAVING
TO YIELD. AND SO.
YEAH QUESTION I'M TRYING TO GET
THE HARD AT IS ARE WE BUILDING
ON THAT STANDARD GAUGE SO
THERE'S THAT.
BACK COMPATIBILITY.
THAT IT CAN BE USED BY AMTRAK
OR STANDARD LA FREIGHT OR
PASSENGER.
IF OF WE AYE.
FISHER CUT BATES SITUATION.
OF WE ARE UTILIZING STANDARD
GAUGE OF FOR THE CONSTRUCTION OF
THE THE THE PROJECT I THINK.
.
THE ISSUE MAY BE FOR SOME
CRITICALLY FREIGHT AND I'LL I'LL
BE CANDID HERE.
THE BENEFIT OF THE PROJECT IN
MANY WAYS AND WHAT SETS IT APART
FROM OTHER PASSENGER RAIL. THAT
SYSTEMS IN CALIFORNIA IS THAT
FOR LARGE STRETCHES OF IT IT
DOESN'T CHAIR RAILROAD WITH
FRIGHT. IT DOESN'T SHIPS ARE
CHAIR RIGHT AWAY OR OR.
WHO WITH FREIGHT WHICH WHICH
MAKES IT A NO CAPABLE OF
TRAVELING AT HIGH SPEEDS AND?
DOES NOT HAVE TO WAIT FOR A
FREIGHT TRAFFIC TO MOVE SO
THAT'S AN IMPORTANT.
DISTINCTION.
FOR THIS PROJECT BUT AS A
GENERAL MATTER.
STANDARD GAUGE IS WHAT WE'RE
GOING FORWARD WITH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
CHAIR.
SIMILAR BAKER. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND.
THANK YOU MISTER KELLY AYE AYE.
PLEASED WITH THE EXPERTISE THAT
YOU BRING TO THE HIGH SPEED RAIL
AUTHORITY IN THE BACKGROUND I
MEAN IT'S IT'S A. IT IS GOOD TO
SEE GIVEN THE CHALLENGES FACING
THE PROJECT AYE AYE ASK A
SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT QUESTION AND
CANNOT BE DONE AND REALLY BE
FOCUSING ON SHOULD IT BE DONE.
BECAUSE EVERY PENNY THAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT THAT IS GOING INTO
THE PROJECT OR HAS IT GONE INTO
IT YET YOU'LL SAY WE NEED. CAN
BE SPENT ELSEWHERE COMES FROM
SOMEWHERE IT COULD BE INVESTED
ON THE BOOK AND PROJECTS THAT
CAN BE PUT IN SO MANY OTHER.
PROJECTS THAT NOT ONLY CREATE
JOBS IN GREAT ECONOMIC
OPPORTUNITY IN DIFFERENT PARTS
OF THE STATE BUT ACTUALLY
IMPROVE MOBILITY.
AND I I KNOW WE'RE GOING TO HEAR
FROM THE.
PEER REVIEW GROUP WHICH IS DONE
GREAT WORK.
ONE OF THE FOUR OPTIONS THEY LAY
OUT EARLY ON IN THEIR REPORT IS
TO AND IT.
AND THE PROJECT TAKE A LOOK AT
AND SAY YOU KNOW WHAT.
IT'S KIND LIKE THE CARTOON
WHERE THERE'S A TRAIN GOING IN
THEIR BUILDING THE TRACKS AS
THEY GO AND IT JUST KEEPS GOING
IN ONE DIRECTION OR THE OTHER
AND PRETTY SOON. YOU YOU WONDER
WHERE IT'S GONE.
THAT TO ME IS A LITTLE BIT HOW
THE PROJECT FEELS NOT ANY
REFLECTION ON THE EXPERTISE OF
THOSE HAS BEEN WORKING NOT JUST
HOW DEFAULT IN THE LAST TEN
YEARS.
SO THAT THAT SCENARIO THAT THEY
HAVE EVEN THE SECOND SCENARIO
WHICH IS TO COMPLETE SOME OF IT
THE CENTRAL VALLEY PROJECT.
YEAH I HAVE CONSTITUENTS IN THE
BAY AREA SAY I KNOW EXACTLY
WHERE THOSE.
DOLLARS CAN BE SPENT BETTER. AND
AND SO LET'S END IT AND MOVE IT
SOMEWHERE ELSE CAN YOU TALK TO
US ABOUT THE WHY SHOULDN'T WE
END IT.
INSTEAD OF CONTINUE ON AND
POSSIBLY LIKE THAT CARTOON
PUTTING THE RAIL IN FRONT OF US
AS WE AS WE MOVE ALONG.
WELL I'D SAY A COUPLE THINGS OF
ONE OF THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN AND
BUSINESS PLAN DOES NOT REFLECT
THE DEPARTURE IN THE STRATEGY. A
GOING FOR FROM TWENTY SIXTEEN IN
TERMS OF WHAT WE WOULD BILL
BUILT FIRST AND AND THE
DIRECTION WE WOULD GO. IS
CONSISTENT AND COULD CONTINUOUS
SO.
SO I I.
I AGREE A ONE ONE HOP AROUND AND
I DON'T THINK I DON'T THINK WE
DO.
THIS GETS BACK TO WHAT I SAID A
MINUTE AGO ABOUT THE PROJECT WHY
SHOULD WE CAN TO.
.
FOR ME THE GREATEST VALUE OF
THIS PROJECT.
AND A VALUE THAT I HAVE NOT
FOUND ANY OTHER TRANSPORTATION
PROJECT IN MY TIME HERE.
IS THE MOBILITY BENEFIT FROM
HIGH SPEED RAIL.
I THE IDEA THAT WE CAN BUILD
SOMETHING AND REDUCE TRAVEL
TIMES.
VERSES A CAR FOR EXAMPLE GOING
FROM STAMPS ES GO TO LA FROM
SEVEN OR EIGHT HOURS.
TO THREE OR LESS IS.
THE OUTSTANDING HAND AND THE
ABILITY TO MOVE PEOPLE FROM THE
BAY AREA THE CENTRAL VALLEY.
INSTEAD OF A SOMETIMES THREE OR
FOUR HOUR TRIP ON THE HIGHWAYS.
TO DO IT IN JUST OVER AN HOUR
IS A DIFFERENCE MAKER I THINK IT
WILL CHANGE THE WAY PEOPLE MOVE.
I THINK THAT'S BEEN THE
EXPERIENCE AROUND THE WORLD.
WERE HIGH SPEED RAIL HAS BEEN.
PUT INTO PLACE
AND SO IN TERMS OF THE SHOULD
FOR ME. IT'S THAT KIND OF
MOBILITY DIFFERENCE THAT I CAN'T
NAME ANY OTHER PROJECTS BEING
ABLE TO ACHIEVE.
THE SIMPLE REALITY WHICH MY
COLLEAGUES ARE TIRED OF HEARING
ME SAY. IS THAT NO MATTER HOW
MANY LANES YOU BUILD CARS ON THE
HIGHWAY. CAN'T GO TWO HUNDRED
MILES PER HOUR.
BUT HIGH SPEED TRAINS CAN'T.
AND THAT IS THE DIFFERENCE IN
CUTTING TRAVEL TIME.
AND SO. TO ME IT'S A VERY
IMPORTANT PROJECT TO REALLY GIVE
CALIFORNIANS.
AN OPTION TO MOVE AROUND THAT
THEY DON'T HAVE TODAY IN
SEVERELY CUT TRAVEL TIMES IN
WHAT IS OTHERWISE A VERY
CONGESTED.
THE SITUATION AROUND OUR STATE.
SO SO THAT'S THE THAT'S THE WHY
FOR ME AND AGAIN I WANT TO BE
CLEAR THAT THE STRATEGY WE LAY
OUT IN THE PLAN.
IS TO MAKE INVESTMENTS THAT ARE
NOT LOST INVESTMENTS AND WOULD
NOT BE STRANDED INVESTMENTS
EXTENDING. THE ELECTRIC
ELECTRIFICATION A CALTRAIN THE
BAY AREA TO GILROY. WILL HAVE
SOME INTERIM BENEFITS FOR
CALTRAIN SOME LONG TERM BENEFITS
FOR US. FLOTILLA SAME ABOUT THE
OF THE.
THE STRUCTURES WERE BUILDING
THE CENTRAL VALLEY ARE
REQUIREMENTS TO PUT THOSE IN THE
USE.
AND WE WOULD CONTINUE.
TO DO SO FINAL POINT IS THAT.
THE CAP AND TRADE A DOLLARS ALSO
HAVE TO.
HAVE TO RESULT IN SOME
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSION BENEFITS
NOT EVERY TRANSPORTATION PROJECT
CAN ACHIEVE THAT AT THE LEVEL
THAT THAT THIS ONE CANCER
THERE'S ALSO INAPPROPRIATENESS.
TO THOSE FUNDS BEING USED FOR
THIS PROJECT IN IN OUR
ESTIMATION.
THANK YOU IS IT'S IMPORTANT TO
ME THAT AND I THINK THE
COMMITTEE TO HERE YOUR YOUR HOW
HOW YOU LAY THAT OUT LIKE WHY
WHEN WE'RE CONFRONTED WITH THE
QUESTION SHOULD WE STOP.
WHAT DO ONE OF THE CENTRAL PART
OF YOUR ANSWER WAS THAT IT'S
GOING TO BE MORE THERE'S GONNA
BE IMPROVE MOBILITY?
THAT COMPARED TO A CAR.
HIGH SPEED RAIL WILL GO FASTER.
AND THERE HAVE BEEN CRITICISMS
AND ANOTHER WILL HEAR THEM ALL
OUT HERE ABOUT JUST HOW MUCH
HIGH SPEED RAIL WILL BE HIGH
SPEED WHETHER ITS SHARING RIGHTS
OF WAY WHETHER SHARON TO FOR
TRACK. AND STATE THE COMPARISON
FIRST OF FIRST OF ALL THAT IT
WILL BE TWO TO THREE HOURS.
AT LEAST IN THE PUBLIC THAT IS
REALLY GREATLY THAT THE
CREDIBILITY OF THAT HAS.
IT'S BEEN LOST.
AND THAT THE COMPARISON IS WITH
A VEHICLE WHEN WE HAVE
TECHNOLOGY THAT'S MOVING
FORWARDS AND SO MANY WAYS YOU
CAN COMMENT ON THAT AS WELL AS.
YOU KNOW BAY AREA MOBILITY OR
LOS ANGELES OR SAN DIEGO ABILITY
THAT THE AMOUNT OF MOBILITY
PERMITS WE CAN MAKE WITH THESE
DOLLARS MIGHT NOT BE FROM LA TO
SAN FRANCISCO BUT MIGHT BE ALL
AROUND THE GREATER BAY AREA ALL
AROUND THE CENTRAL VALLEY ALL
AROUND.
LOS ANGELES AND SAN DIEGO AND
OTHER PARTS OF THE STATE THEY
JUST WOULDN'T BE SPENT ON HIGH
SPEED RAIL SO TO ME. I ALSO LOOK
FOR THE GREATER MOBILITY FOR
CALIFORNIANS JUST I DON'T SEE IT
AS THE ONLY WAY TO HAVE IT IS.
THROUGH THIS PROJECT I THINK
IT'S MORE OF A STATEMENT THAN A
QUESTION ON THE FIRST ONE NOW I
CAN YOU ADDRESS THAT.
THE COMPARISON YOU'RE MAKING
THAT YOU'RE GONNA HAVE A TWO TO
THREE HOUR RIDE FROM LA TO SAN
FRANCISCO. WHEN SO MANY OTHER
PROMISES ABOUT THE PROJECT HAVE
FAILED TO BE KEPT.
WELL I WOULD SAY THAT YOU KNOW
OUR OPERATING GUIDELINE IN THE
FOLKS WHO.
DO THE OPERATION DESIGN WORK
FOR THIS PROJECT ARE GUIDED BY
THE REQUIREMENTS PROP ONE A. LOT
AND THAT IS A DESIGN REQUIREMENT
TO.
BE ABLE TO TO.
OPERATE THE SYSTEM THAT IT
TOURISM FORTY MINUTES BETWEEN
CHANCES GOING LOS ANGELES.
ISN'T DESIGNED MATTER WE WILL
DESIGN TO THAT WILL HAVE A
SYSTEM THAT WILL HAVE DIFFERENT
STATION STOPS.
SO.
IT WILL BE IT WILL BE DESIGNED
TO MEET THE CRITERIA PROP ONE IS
NOT RACIONAL MATTER IT MAY TAKE
A LITTLE LONGER WAS STATION
STOPS TO BE SAFE THREE HOURS. OF
TO GO FROM SEPSIS COULD A LOS
ANGELES BUT AGAIN VERSES YOUR
TRAVEL OPTIONS TODAY FAIRY THAN
A TRAIN OR CAR.
IT'S NOT EVEN CLOSE.
CONFERENCE ARE HOW MUCH
CONFIDENCE DO YOU HAVE THAT IT'S
GOING TO BE TWO HOURS AND FORTY
MINUTES TO THREE HOURS WHEN THIS
IS BUILT THIS CAN BE YOU
PERSONALLY I UP YOUR CONFIDENCE
IN.
WELL AGAIN THE DESIGN CRITERIA
IS THE TWO HOURS AND FORTY
MINUTES TO TRAVEL TIME WAS
STATION STOPS WOULD BE HIGHER
THAN THAT OKAY BUT I I'M
CONFIDENT.
CERTAINLY THAT WILL BE IN A TO
FORTY TO YOU KNOW THREE TWENTY
ARISE AND.
FROM SOME DEPENDING ON HOW TO
STOP TO MAKE YOU WHICH
STRAIGHTER ON EXPRESS SOURCES
NOT EXPRESS.
AM.
IT AND ONE OF THE REASONS WHY
THIS HAS THAT THERE'S BEEN SO
MUCH SKEPTICISM ABOUT THE SPEED
BECAUSE WE'RE COMPARING YEAH
DIFFERENT ERA IS THE SHARED YOUR
LINES YES. AND YOU HAVE EXAMPLES
OF HOW FAST YOU CAN GO ON A
SHARED LINE YES.
IN THE AREAS WERE IN URBAN
AREAS AND WE HAVE SHARED
CORRIDORS LIKE IN THE.
BURBANK TO ANAHEIM AREA AND IN
THE NORTHERN CALIFORNIA AND
CALTRAIN.
STRETCH.
YOU KNOW FOR STRETCHES OF THAT
THE IN THOSE RELATIVELY SMALL
STRETCHES OF OF MOVEMENT WILL
TRAVEL BETWEEN HUNDRED TEN.
UNDER TWENTY FIVE MILES PER HOUR
DEPENDING ON WHERE YOU ARE.
BUT THE BULK OF THE TRAVEL
THROUGH THE CENTRAL VALLEY WILL
BE IN EXCESS
OF TO MILES PER HOUR.
WELL IT AND A SLIGHTLY VARIOUS
CENTRIC YEAH THINKING OF THE THE
SAN JOSE AREA OF SAN JOSE AND
GILROY YOURS ALL ALONG THAT.
THAT LINE.
.
HOW FAST IS THAT GONNA GO THINK
ONE TEN IS OUR ESTIMATE TODAY?
AND WHEN YOU MENTION THAT STE
IT'S WHERE THEY WERE COMING
HEARING IS BECAUSE PROP ONE A
SAID IT HAS TO BE.
ABOUT THREE HOURS WE HAVE BE
ATTEMPTED DESIGNED THAT WAY IT'S
GOING TO BE.
THAT'S WHY I'M HERE IS BECAUSE
THAT'S WHAT PEOPLE WERE PROMISED
IN.
TWO THOUSAND EIGHT THAT'S WHAT
WE WILL HAVE YEAH THE DESIGN
CRITERIA THAT'S IN THE BOND BILL
IS FOR TWO HOURS AND FORTY
MINUTES AYE CRITERIA WE'RE
DESIGNING IT TO MEET THAT
REQUIREMENT.
AND.
I AYE. THERE WERE SO MANY THINGS
PROMISED AT THAT PARTICULAR
POINT IS WELL BE DIFFICULT TO
SEE HOW WERE HOW WE'RE GONNA BE
THERE PARTICULARLY WITH THE
SHARE TRACK AND THAT AND THE
CHALLENGES WE HAVE.
BUT I AM GRATEFUL THAT YOU'RE
THE PERSON IS TRYING TO TAKE A
LOOK AT IT. AND FIND SOME WAY TO
GET THERE THANK YOU THANK YOU.
MISTER DALY. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR.
.
AS YOU MENTIONED.
THE STRANDED COST ISSUE WERE.
AS TO BE DEALT WITH IN IT ON MY
LIKE. WHAT YOU'RE WHERE YOU'RE
FOCUSED ON?
IN THAT AREA.
AND ONE EXAMPLE IS THE BURBANK
TO ANAHEIM.
SEGMENT.
WHICH.
EVEN IF THE LINE NEVER.
GETS OVER THE TEHACHAPI HE'S.
WHICH IS MY REAL QUESTION IS.
HIS IS THAT CHALLENGE OF.
TUNNELING OR GOING OVER THE
TEHACHAPI MOUNTAINS FROM
PALMDALE TO BURBANK.
ON I LIKE THE IMPROVEMENTS FROM
BURBANK TO ANAHEIM. BUT IT'S
REALLY NOT A.
STATEWIDE SYSTEM.
AND DOESN'T MEDIAN TEN OF THE OF
THE VOTERS.
IF IT NEVER GETS.
FROM BAKERSFIELD TO LA. OR.
.
PAPPOINTS PALMDALE EXCUSE BUT.
TO
BURBANK.
HAS THERE BEEN ANY PROGRESS.
THE TECHNOLOGY.
OR WORTH THE COST BENEFIT
ANALYSIS.
FOR THAT LINK.
BECAUSE ALL THE READING I'VE
DONE.
IT SEEMS TO BE GETTING.
MORRELL MORE COMPLICATED MORE
AND MORE CHALLENGING.
MAY BE COST PROHIBITIVE.
AS SOON AS A.
.
ELECTED OFFICIAL INIS SOMEONE
WHO LOOKS TO HOW MUCH THINGS
COST.
TO GET FROM PALMDALE TO BURBANK
NOT TO MENTION THE NIMBY ASPECTS
IN OTHER OPPOSITION BUT JUST
THAT DOLLARS IN SO ANY PROGRESS
ON THAT.
YET WHAT WE CONTINUE TO MOVE
FORWARD ON ASSESSING DIFFERENT
ALIGNMENTS.
THERE WILL CERTAINLY BE A
TUNNELING.
THROUGH.
THE TO DETACH APPEASE.
I THINK WE HAVE ON THE ORDER OF.
A MORE THAN ONE TUNNEL I THINK
WITH A FIFTEEN MILE AN EIGHT
MILE.
TUNNEL.
YEAH IN THAT IN THAT STRETCH SO.
EIGHT AND LOOK IT WHILE IT'S A
LITTLE UNCOMMON AND PERHAPS IN
AMERICAN CERTAINLY CALIFORNIA.
FOR THAT LEVEL OF TUNNELING.
IT IS ACHIEVED THE AROUND THE
WORLD A THIRTY THREE MILE TUNNEL
JUST RECENTLY OPENED IN
SWITZERLAND.
THEY BUILD A TUNNELING THROUGH
MOUNT A SERIES FOR HIGH SPEED
RAIL ALL OVER THE GLOBE WHERE
THEY HAVE IT.
AND WE WILL BE UTILIZING OF
THAT KIND OF EXPERTISE WHEN WE
LOOK AT OUR OPTIONS.
A HERE SO WE HAVE THREE
DIFFERENT ALTERNATIVES FROM THE
PALMDALE TO BURBANK SCENARIO ALL
OF THEM. HAVE TOTALING ELEMENTS
IN THEM AND THEY ARE INCLUDED IN
THE COST ESTIMATES THAT ARE PER
PRESENTED IN THE IN THE BUSINESS
PLAN.
BUT IT'S TRUE THAT THIS IS WHY
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE MOVE
FORWARD ON THE ENVIRONMENTAL AND
WE FURTHER REFINE. THE DESIGN OF
THE SEGMENTS.
BECAUSE THE COST OF THE COST
LEVEL IT HAS A HIGH SWING.
IT COULD BE AS LOW AS TWELVE
HOURS HIGHS TWENTY FIVE TO GET
THROUGH THAT THAT SECTION AND
SO.
YOU DO THINGS LIKE.
FURTHER THE DESIGN REFINEMENT
OF OF THAT YOU BRING IN
EXPERTISE TO. A PROVIDE OPTIONS.
TO TO MOVE THROUGH THEIR.
AND YOU CAN'T YOU KNOW
CONSTRUCTING AWAY USING THE BEST
AVAILABLE TECHNOLOGY TO.
TO PROVIDE.
LOW COST MAXIMUM EFFICIENCY.
EFFORT AND THAT'S.
OUR DUTY GOING FORWARD IS WE WE
WORK ON THIS PROJECT BUT BUT
THOSE ARE THE. THREE ALTERNATES
DOWN THERE ALL INVOLVE
SIGNIFICANT.
THANK YOU.
CLEARLY QUESTIONS THE COMMITTEE
OF PEOPLE THE SPELL.
WRITER.
OF MISTER KACZYNSKI.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR OF HER
YOU KNOW MISTER HOW THE PRICING
STORY I'M A I'M THIS POLITICS OF
PRESENTATION WAS.
DON'T STEER TAKEN SOME BOTH IN
THE REVENUE AND TAX.
AND WHAT REAL QUICK QUESTION
AND THAT'S REALLY THE QUESTION
CLOSE TO THE DISTRICT I
REPRESENT.
IS WHEN CAN WE ACTUALLY SEE THE
I HAVE EVER SINGLE TWELVE WE'VE
WHEN CAN WE SEE THE FIRST TRAIN
ARRIVING IN DURING A STATION.
IS THERE ANY MASCULINE.
A COUPLE ANSWERS THAT THE FIRST
IS.
WE ARE WORKING CLOSELY WITH OUR
CALTRAIN PARTNER ON THE
ELECTRIFICATION OF THAT.
CORRIDOR.
WE PROPOSE IN THIS PLAN TO
ELECTRIFY FURTHER SOUTH ALL THE
WAY TO GILROY.
CURRENTLY THE ELECTRIFICATION
PROJECT TO SAN JOSE TO SAN
FRANCISCO.
WE'D LIKE TO COMPLETE THAT WORK
UNDER THIS PLAN AND.
DO SOME WORK WITH OUR EARLY
TRAIN OPERATOR TO SEE IF WE
CAN'T GET.
Ó ELECTRIFY TRAINS IN SERVICE
BY TWENTY TWENTY SEVEN. CAMINO
REAL ROY.
HE OUGHT YES HOLLYWOOD GILROY IN
CRIME.
AND THERE'S PRETTY MUCH
ANTICIPATING THAT THEIR HIGH
SPEED RAIL WILL BE.
COMING SHALL SHARE SHARING A YET
TO GILROY SAN JOSE TO SAN
FRANCISCO WE BE SHARING THAT
QUARTER AT THAT TIME.
WITH WITH WITH CALTRAIN PLUS
THE BLAND THAT SAYS YEAH WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT THAT'S CORRECT.
GREAT AUNT CANSECO QUESTION WAS
THROUGH THEM.
REGARDING TO THE MINIMUM
GUARANTEE.
YOU KNOW YOU THE WAY I KNOW THAT
TWENTY FIVE PERCENT OFF A CAP
AND TRADE MONEY.
IT WILL GO TO THIS HIGH SPEED
RAIL WE'RE TALKING ABOUT MINIMUM
GUARANTEES ARE YOU TALKING THEIR
FILE AND.
FIVE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR OF
WHICH IS TO LOW ESTIMATE. OR
SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS WHICH IS
THE HIGHEST YET TODAY.
.
WE HAVE A A PERCENTAGE SHARE
COULD CONTINUES THE APPROPRIATE
OUT A CAP AND TRADE A TWENTY
FIVE PERCENT RIGHT AND.
IF WE WERE TO.
REPLACE THAT WITH A DOLLAR
VALUE WE.
I THINK OUR ESTIMATE HERE WE WE
CAN WE DO A LOT OF THINGS IN
RANGES HERE WE HAD A LOW RANGE
USING THE FIVE HUNDRED. AND A
MEDIUM RANGE USING THE SEVEN
FIFTY HAVE PER YEAR. I THINK
BASED ON THE LAST THREE AUCTIONS
WE BROUGHT IN A SINCE AB THREE
NINETY EIGHT PASSED WE BROUGHT
IN. ABOUT FIVE HUNDRED FORTY
MILLION DOLLARS IN THE LAST
THREE AUCTIONS
WITH ONE MORE TO GO SINCE THAT
BILL PASSED SO.
WE HAVE INVESTMENT OF YOU KNOW
SEVEN FIFTY AS A REASONABLE
BASELINE A GOING FORWARD.
TWOSOME FIFTIES TO BASELINE THAT
A LITTLE WORSE YOU KNOW WHO CAN
NOW GET SOME HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS FROM THE CAP AND
TRADE. BILL WOULD HAVE TO A. YOU
MOVE SOME OF THE GENERAL FUND
WHOSE.
TO CONTINUE SUPPORTING THIS
PROGRAM.
WELL I I'M BARKING ONLY BECAUSE
THE AGAIN UNDER CURRENT LAW
WE'VE. LIVED TWENTY FIVE PERCENT
COMMITMENT AND HOW MUCH THAT
TURNS INTO ON A PERCENTAGE BASIS
DEPENDS ON HOW MUCH CAPITA IT
BRINGS IN.
IN TOTALITY.
SOVIET IF YOU KNOW THERE'S
THERE'S AN ESTIMATE OF THAT THE
COULD BE MUCH HIGHER IN THE OUT
YEARS SO WE BE HIGHER I GUESS.
WHAT WE WERE SAYING HERE FOR
GOING TO REPLACE IT WITH A
DOLLAR SIGN LEVEL SEVEN FIFTY?
WOULD BRING US ABOUT THE TWENTY
SEVEN TO TWENTY BILLION THAT
WE'VE REFERENCE IN THIS PLACE.
YOU KNOW MARK MARK. GETS ON.
.
I JUST FILLED OUT MORE
COMFORTABLE WITH A PERCENTAGE
LEVEL AND POSTED THAT THE CAP
ENTRY A MONEY. FLUCTUATING UP
AND DOWN KNOW YOU'RE GIVEN US
AND.
AND ARE ABSOLUTE.
DOLLAR AMOUNT SOME HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS. IN THEM MONEY
REQUIRED W. SOLVED THE GENERAL
FUND.
TO TO TO BACKFILL THE
DIFFERENCE.
THAT WOULD BE I SUPPOSE TRUE
ONLY IF A THAT WAS A. YOU KNOW A
FIRM FLOOR ALTHOUGH IT'S NOT A
SILLY THAT WOULD BECOME FROM THE
GENERAL FUND I MEAN I THINK.
BEGIN WE'VE SAID HERE IS NOT OR
IF THERE WAS A DOLLAR DOLLAR
SIGN BASELINE. NO SEVEN FIFTY
WOULD GET US THIS MUCH VERSES
ARE PERCENTAGE AMOUNT TODAY.
WHAT'S.
BUT I LIKE TO POINT OUT MY
CONCERT TICKET.
WE HAVE A QUESTION IS.
CLEAVED PAL.
SO.
MY SCHOOL YOU TALKED ABOUT
EARLIER IS LESSONS LEARNED AND I
KNOW YOU HAVE YOUR SKILL LOW
HERE.
AND.
.
SOME OF THE EXPENSE OF LESSONS
LEARNED.
IT WAS THE RIGHT OF WAY
ACQUISITION.
HOW WAS YOUR PURPOSEFULLY P.
ABLE TO MOVE FORWARD I MEAN WHAT
I'M A CONTRACTOR ALWAYS?
NEVER BUILT TO HOUSE THEM
PROPERTY NEVER OWNED.
AND SO WHEN YOU LOOK ABOUT THIS
SIERRA KIND HAS THE CONCEPT OF
BUILDING THE PLANE ON THE
RUNWAY.
PARA
SO WHAT ARE WE GONNA DO MOVING
FORWARD. BECAUSE ICE ALSO AS YOU
KNOW WE BOTH SERVED ON THE
PUBLIC WORKS BOARD TOGETHER. AND
WE SAW ONE EMINENT DOMAIN.
COMING TOWARDS US.
OF FROM THAT PROCESS AND A LOT
OF PEOPLE WERE.
NOW.
ABOUT HOW THEY WERE TREATED BUT
THEY WERE TOLD.
AND SO. WHAT ARE WE GONNA DO
MOVING FORWARD TO ACQUIRE THIS
AND AND OTHER APPROPRIATE
FASHION THAT ALSO? IS A VALUE
NOT ONLY TO THE PROJECT BUT THE
TAXPAYERS WERE PAYING FOR IT
GREAT LESSONS LEARNED.
FROM THIS PROJECT IT'S WORTH
NOTING THAT.
ABOUT SIXTY THREE PERCENT OF THE
COST INCREASES THAT WERE
IDENTIFIED IN THIS PLAN.
ARE TIED TO HAVING GONE INTO
CONSTRUCTION OR ISSUE
CONSTRUCTION CONTRACTS WITHOUT
ALL THAT THE RIGHT AWAY. A IN
HAND AND WHAT I MEAN BY THAT IS
THAT IS THEN. REQUIRED US TO BUY
ADDITIONAL RIGHT OF WAY TO STAY
AHEAD OF THE. A CONTRACT CA
CONTRACTOR.
AND HAD HIS PAY SOME DELAY
CLAIMS BECAUSE OF THAT.
ALSO IF YOU DON'T ALL RIGHT
AWAY YOU DON'T A LAWYER THIRD
PARTY AGREEMENTS AND YOU DON'T
KNOW. ALL UTILITY RELOCATIONS.
SO THE CONSTRUCTION CONTRACTS
WERE LET BEFORE ALL THAT RISK
WAS IDENTIFIED IN FULLY
MITIGATED.
THAT IS THE PRIME LESSON LEARNED
HERE THAT WE WOULD BE.
IMPLEMENTING GOING FORWARD IS
THAT WE WOULD NOT MAKE THAT
MISTAKE AGAIN WILL HAVE THAT
RISK MUCH BETTER IDENTIFY MUCH
MORE. IDENTIFIED MANAGING
MITIGATED BEFORE WE GO TO
CONSTRUCTION CONTRACTS.
ON RIGHT AWAY ITSELF WE HAVE
REALIGNED. THE RIGHT OF WAY AND
THIRD PARTY AGREEMENT.
THAT DUTY IN OUR ORGANIZATION.
TO.
A NEW MANAGER.
LAWYER THAT WE HAVE.
REASSIGNED STRICTLY TO THAT.
PURPOSE.
HEADED VACANCY IN OUR DIRECTOR
OF REAL PROPERTY THAT WE ARE NOW
FILLING.
AND.
WE'RE PUTTING IT.
ALL UNDER THE AN EXPEDITED
LEGAL PROCESS WITHIN. A WITHIN
OUR ORGANIZATION.
WERE ALSO A WORKING CLOSELY
WITH THE CONTRACTORS TO IDENTIFY
THE CRITICAL PATH PARCELS THAT
NEED TO BE. A PRIORITIZED.
AS WE GO FORWARD.
AND WE ARE OF THROWING OF
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES HIRING MORE
RESOURCES TO FOCUS ON THE RIGHT
AWAY.
THE RIGHT AWAY A ISSUE --
SO WHAT WE'RE DOING A LOT
OF THINGS TO MOVE FORWARD ON
THAT I WOULD ALSO SAY THAT
-- -- ARE RIGHT AWAY PROCESS
IS A LITTLE UNUSUAL FOR A
LINEAR TRANSPORTATION PROJECT
OF THE PROCESS THAT WE USE
IS MORE -- FAMILIAR FOR --
FACILITIES THAT ARE BEING BUILT
-- YOU SEE -- INVOLVING THE
DEPARTMENT GENERAL SERVICES
IN THE TRANSPORTATION SECTOR
I TYPICALLY DON'T GO TO THE
PUBLIC WORKS -- BOARD -- AND
YOU DON'T NECESSARILY USED AT
DTS SO WE WOULD BE SEEKING --
TO -- FIND -- WORK WITH YOU ON
THE RIGHT AWAY FOR YOU MIRRORS
MORE WHAT CALTRANS A DOES --
IN THEIR PROCESS WHERE THEY CAN
A SELF DO SEVERAL THINGS UNTIL
THEY -- -- SORT OF THE YEAH
WHAT'S THE TERM I'M LOOKING
FOR THEY CAN -- ON THEIR OWN
DO THINGS LIKE APPRAISALS
NEGOTIATIONS -- AND OTHER
THINGS WITHOUT GOING THROUGH
THE DDS A PROCESS THAT IS MORE
COMMON FOR TRANSPORTATION D.
W. ARE LINEAR TRANSPORTATION
PROJECTS I WILL BE WORKING
WITH OF LEGISLATORS ON AYE
THAT AUTHORITY HERE SO WE CAN
EXPEDITE OUR OUR PROCESS AS
WELL SO THOSE ARE A FEW THINGS
YOU MENTIONED SECURING
-- SEVEN FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS OF -- REALLY CAP
AND TRADE IF THAT WASN'T
BROUGHT FORWARD IN THAT PERIOD
OF TIME WITH THE GENERAL
FUND HAVE TO MAKE THE CAP
I MEAN IT'S NOT A YOU KNOW
IT IT'S A COUPLE THINGS IT'S
IT'S NOT A SO THE GENERAL
FUND FIRST OF ALL I MEAN WE
ARE WHAT WE'RE SAYING IN THIS
A BUSINESS PLAN IS TODAY WE
HAVE TWENTY FIVE PERCENT OF
A OF AN ANNUAL TOTAL THAT'S
CAP AND TRADE -- DEPENDING ON
WHAT THAT'S GOING TO BE GOING
FORWARD -- ACCORDING TO ALEJO
WITH THE LID LOW RANGES FIVE
HUNDRED THE HIGH RANGE IS ONE
POINT SEVEN BILLION -- WE'VE
FOR PLANNING PURPOSES PUT SEVEN
FIFTY IN THIS A PLAN -- AS A
AS A -- -- PLANNING -- MATTER
TRYING TO ESTIMATE WHAT WOULD
BE REASONABLE NUMBER WE TALK
TO THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
ABOUT IT -- AND OTHERS AND
THAT'S THAT'S A NUMBER THAT WE
PLUGGED IN HERE SO IF WE WERE
TO REPLACE THE PERCENTAGE WITH
A DOLLAR SIGN AND WE WANTED TO
MAKE IT FINANCES WILL WE WOULD
WANT TO TRY TO MAKE THAT A
FLOOR OF SOME KIND BUT WHETHER
THAT WAS -- WHETHER THE FLOOR
WAS -- SOME COMMITMENT WAS MADE
FROM OTHER CAP AND TRADE MONIES
OR SOMETHING ELSE REMAINS TO
BE SEEN IS UNNECESSARILY IT
IN GENERAL FUND COMMITMENT
SO THEN I DID AGAIN IF WE'RE
IDENTIFYING A NUMBER IS ONE
OF THOSE WHO'S GOING TO BE THE
BACKSTOPS A ONE OF THE OTHER
THINGS IS MY UNDERSTANDING
ABOUT CAP AND TRADE IS AT
SOME POINT IN TIME IT HAS A
DIMINISHING AMOUNT OF MONEY
THAT COMES IN BECAUSE YOU'RE
USING IT FOR MITIGATION AND AS
A RESULT -- ACQUIRE THAT YOU
DON'T NEED AS MUCH MONEY COMING
IN SO THIS WAS HAVE A DOWNSLOPE
OF INCOME AND NOW WE'RE SAYING
I MEAN MY UNDERSTANDING IS THAT
THE DRAFT PLAN EITHER ASSUMES
IT'S A STATIC OR AN INCREASING
AMOUNT OF REVENUE I DON'T
THINK THAT WAS IN A PURPOSES OF
A GOING OUT HIS A.
B. THIRTY TWO SO I THINK
WHAT WE'RE LOOKING AT IS HIS
REDEFINING CAP AND TRADE WITH
AN EXTENSION IS THAT WHAT I'M
HEARING FUND FOR THE TWENTY
FIFTEEN A PLAYER YEAH YOU
KNOW THE THE EXTENSION AND
MISTER CHAIRMAN IS IS JUST
THE CONSISTENCY WITH -- THE
ASSUMPTIONS IN THE TWENTY
SIXTEEN HAVE PLANNED THAT
CAP AND TRADE FOR PURPOSES
OF FUNDING HERE WOULD BE
AVAILABLE TILL TWENTY FIFTY
WE DID A TALK TO CARBON DOUBT
THAT THEY'VE GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSION REDUCTION REQUIREMENTS
-- GO GO AWAY TWENTY FIFTY --
THEY EXPECTED CAP AND TRADE
WOULD BE AN ELEMENT OF OUR --
CLIMATE CHANGE PROPOSALS GOING
FORWARD -- WHILE IT'S TRUE THAT
OVER TIME -- YOU WOULD HOPE
THERE'S A DIMINISHING -- AMOUNT
YOU ALSO SEE THE EXPENSIVE
-- EACH ALLOWANCE PROBABLY
GO UP -- AND SO -- -- WE MADE
-- AN ASSUMPTION OF -- WHAT
WE THOUGHT WAS A REASONABLE
ESTIMATE OF AB SEVEN FIFTY
BASED ON ESTIMATES WE'VE SEEN
WHAT THE CAP AND TRADE PROGRAM
COULD LOOK LIKE GOING FORWARD
SO
WE MADE A COMMITMENT TO
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE ON THIS
PROJECT WHOSE COMPANIES
EMPLOYERS LABOR DATA AND I WHEN
I WHEN I WALK THAT PROJECT IN
ACTUALLY HA THE ARTISTRY OF
THE WORKERS IS UNBELIEVABLE
IT'S IT'S FANTASTIC --
AND WE'RE GOING TO SAY WE'VE
MADE A COMMITMENT TO THESE
PEOPLE LIVE ACTUALLY RELOCATED
TO BE ABLE TO WORK ON THESE
AREAS -- IN FROM THE TRADES IN
AND AND AND VENDORS AND WHAT
NOT OF SO WE LOOK AT THE VIEW
OF THE BUSINESS PLAN AND I
DON'T SEE ANYTHING WHAT ABOUT
THE DEBT SERVICE THERE WOULD
HAVE TO CREATE THAT WOULD
HAVE TO BE PAID ON ANY MONEY
FAR SO WE LOOK AT IT WILL IT
SEVENTY SEVEN BILLION DOLLARS
WE DON'T GET FEDERAL FUNDING
AND WE DON'T GET -- PRIVATE
PARTNERSHIP AND SO NOW WE HAVE
A SEVENTY SEVEN BILLION DOLLAR
THAT WELL IN OVER THIRTY YEAR
PERIOD OF TIME IT WOULD COST
US ACT IT'S ALWAYS LIKE TO SEE
THE LOOK AT THE TOTAL BURDEN
OF THE PROJECT AND SO YOU KNOW
I THINK THAT'S AN OBLIGATION
WE HAVE AS LEGISLATORS TO
COMPLETELY UNDERSTAND THE WHOLE
PACKAGE IT TELLING US WHAT'S
AND COST REAL TIME DOLLARS BUT
NOT THIRTY YEARS THAT THE DEBT
THAT WERE OCCURRING FOR FUTURE
LEGISLATURE'S WOMEN PEOPLE
THAT O'NEILL GOING FORWARD
SO THAT I WOULD LIKE TO SEE
INCLUDED A AND THEN ALSO YOU
KNOW I HAD A DISCUSSION ABOUT
WHAT THE ENVIRONMENTAL I MEAN
PEOPLE NEED TO KNOW WHAT THE
ENVIRONMENTAL COSTS ON THIS
PROJECT WORDS ASTRONOMICAL OF
IT ALL AND THE CLEAR BENEFIT
THAT THIS PROJECT DOES BRING
FOR REDUCTIONS EVENTUALLY
HOW THAT THERE'S BEEN NO OF
CREDIT GIVEN UP IN IN THE
ENVIRONMENTAL ASPECT GOING
FORWARD YOU KNOW IT'S JUST
THOSE SOME OF THE THINGS THAT
THAT MAN UNITED YOU KNOW HOW
THE EARLY DISCUSSION ABOUT
THE EXORBITANT COST OF THE
ENVIRONMENT AND WE ACTUALLY
ARE TRYING TO ACHIEVE SOMETHING
THAT IS ENVIRONMENTALLY SOUND
YOU KNOW IT'S KIND OF A KIND
OF AN OXYMORON REALLY -- BUT
THAT NEARLY CLOSER SOME OF
THINGS BUT IN IN THE DRAFT IS
BUT I THINK WE NEED TO SEE REAL
TIME NUMBERS OKAY OF JUST ONE
COMMENT ON THAT MR CHAIRMAN
THERE IS A A CHART OF THE COSTS
SECTION IN THAT CHART IT NOTES
-- HOW MUCH CAP AND TRADE WOULD
HAVE FOR CAPITAL COSTS THE
ACTUAL AMOUNT WE WOULD BRING
IN IS IN EXCESS OF THAT BUT
AS YOU KNOW SOME OF IT WOULD
BE PAID FOR FINANCING BECAUSE
AGAIN WE WANT TO BRING THE
DOLLARS RIGHT FOR TO MEET OUR
CAPITAL EXPENSES SO IT WOULD
WE WOULD ACTUALLY GENERATE
MORE THAN THAT THE AMOUNT OF
THE CAPITAL COSTS BUT AGAIN
WE WOULD PROPOSE TO FINANCE WE
CAN GET THE WORK DONE SAID ONE
WE ALSO KNOW THAT PICKED AS IT
GETS MORE COSTLY AS TIME GOES
ON BECAUSE WE HAVE WHICH IS THE
GO UP IN COSTA MATERIALS AND
AND AND AND PURCHASED INFLATION
-- WE HAVE TO BE CONSCIOUS OF
THE FACT OF IS IT GOING TO BE
AFFORDABLE TO UTILIZE I MEAN
THERE'S NO PUBLIC SUBSIDIES
AROUND US IN THE BOND MEASURE
AND SO I MEAN I I THINK I
SAW SOMETHING WAS NINETY
ONE DOLLARS AND AND THERE'S
NOTHING MORE THAT I WANT TO
CENTRAL VALLEY HAVE THE FIELD
OF DREAMS OF THIS OPPORTUNITY
TO BE ABLE TO WORK IN SAN JOSE
OR LA ABSOLUTELY I THINK IS
PHENOMENAL BECAUSE I THINK THE
CENTRAL VALLEY BEEN OVERLOOKED
FOR MANY MANY YEARS OTHER THE
PROP ONE BEER THING WE DROPPED
A BILLION DOLLARS FOR NINETY
NINE -- SO -- BUT WE HAVE TO
LOOK AND SEE THERE IS THERE A
TIPPING POINT THAT YOU KNOW IS
THIS ACTUALLY A A REASONABLE
AMOUNT OF MONEY FOR SOME OF
OUR WORK A PATH THAT WAS YOU
KNOW ONE OF THE INTO PURPOSES
YEAH I THINK OUR -- RIDERSHIP
ASSUMPTIONS ABOUT FIFTY NINE
PERCENT OF THE TROOPS WOULD
BE LEISURE TRIPS OF THE FORTY
ONE I THINK BUSINESSES I THINK
THAT'S THE BREAKDOWN -- THE
NINETY THREE IS -- ESTIMATE OF
-- A TICKET PRICES THAT WE USE
FOR THE RIDERSHIP -- FIGURES
THE IDEA IS TO BE COMPETITIVE
WITH -- AIRLINE TRAVEL --
AN AIRLINE TICKET PRICES IN
YOU KNOW ULTIMATELY WITH THE
TICKET PRICES ARE WILL WILL
BE USING EARLY TRAIN OPERATOR
THAT WHICH IS BROUGHT ON
THIS YEAR -- TO HELP US WORK
THAT THROUGH IN THERE WOULD
PROBABLY BE DIFFERENT PRICES
FOR DIFFERENT USERS A DEPENDING
ON FREQUENCY OF HIMSELF OR
YOU'RE TRAVELING ALL THOSE
ONE LAST QUESTION SO SO WE'RE
ABSOLUTELY CLEAR PLEASE WHAT
THE COMMITTEE THROUGH EXACTLY
WHAT THE LEGISLATIVE ACTION
WILL NEED TO TAKE PLACE TO
IMPLEMENT THE FUNDING PLAN
YOU PROPOSE FOR JUST THE IOS
WHAT DO YOU EXPLODED YOUR
EXPECTATIONS OF THE LEGISLATURE
I WELCOME THE IF WE ARE TO
COMPLETE THE FINANCING ELEMENT
OF THE CAP AND TRADE -- --
ULTIMATELY WE WOULD NEED TO
STABILIZE THE KAPPA TRADE A
AMOUNTS GOING TO THE PROJECT
SO IT WOULD BE AN INVESTMENT
GRADE -- REVENUE STREAM --
AND IN THAT REGARD WE NOTED
IN THE PLAN THAT -- ULTIMATELY
AN EXTENSION OF THE PROGRAM
WOULD BE A HELPFUL AT TWENTY
FIFTY -- THAT THERE WOULD BE
A OF A DEDICATED AMOUNT OF
CAPITATE FOR THE PROJECT THAT
IS A RELIABLE OVER TIME OF A
FLOOR IF YOU WILL -- AND SOME
COMMITMENT THAT THOSE THAT
WOULD NOT BE A IN IMPAIR AMOUNT
OF MONEY SO THOSE ARE THE THREE
ELEMENTS TO MAKE SOMETHING
INVESTMENT GRADE YOU'RE GOING
TO FINANCE THE REVENUE STREAM
SO THOSE OF THOSE ELEMENTS THAT
WE WE NEED WE'RE NOT LOOKING
AT MOVING TO FINANCING UNTIL
AGAIN ROUGHLY THE TIMELINE OF
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TO TWENTY
TWENTY THREE ROUGHLY WILL ALSO
BE WORKING WITH THE LEGISLATURE
THIS YEAR WE HOPE AS I SAID
EARLIER ON SOME OF THE RIGHT
OF WAY PROCESS IMPROVEMENTS
THAT WE TALKED ABOUT EARLIER
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
MR MATHIS SIR
SO ONE ON MAY MAKE SURE
ABSOLUTELY CLEAR IS YOUR YOU'RE
SAYING YOU'RE YOU'RE BETTING
THIS ON FUTURE CAP AND TRADE
DOLLARS ARE CORRECT YEAH THAT'S
THE ONLY SOURCE OF ONGOING
REVENUE WE HAVE A GARAGE
HERE'S MY BIGGEST
QUESTION FOR HIM
WITHIN THE THAT THE CAP AND
TRADE YELLOW WE JUST NEGOTIATED
THERE'S A CA ONE WHICH THEN
GOES TO PROP SEVENTY SCARES
THE LEGISLATIVE BODY THE
ABILITY VOTE ON THE FUNDS AND
IF AT THAT POINT WE VOTE TAKE
THE FUNDING AWAY FROM YOU
QUITE FRANKLY I DON'T
UNDERSTAND HOW YOU CAN BUSINESS
MODEL PLAN FOR THE PROPOSITION
ON THE BALLOT HERE AND A COUPLE
OF MONTHS NOT KNOWING AND NOT
HAVE ANY GUARANTEE THAT THAT
VOTE WON'T CALM FOR THAT THAT
PROPOSITION WON'T PASS SO SO
YOU'RE BETTING ITS CHICKENS
THAT ARE HATCHED YET ON ON
MONEY THAT YOU DO NOT HAVE
AND YOU'RE TELLING US THIS
IS YOUR BUSINESS MODEL THIS
IS YOUR PLAN BUT YEAH COME
JUNE IF PROP SEVENTY PASSES
THEN COME TWENTY TWENTY FOUR
WHEN WE HAVE THE VOTE YOU MAY
BE DIE IN YOUR ARTICLE OFF A
FEDERAL FUNDING THEN YOU MAY
BE CUT OFF A STATE FUNDED SO
I DON'T QUITE UNDERSTAND WHERE
YOU INTEND TO GET THE FUNDING
IF THAT IS THE HALF AN OR HOW
YOU'RE ABLE TO PROJECT FUNNY
BEYOND THAT POINT AT THIS TIME
BECAUSE THERE'S NO CERTAINTY
INTEL AFTER BOTH POINTS OF
HAPPEN IF THE LEGISLATURE CUTS
OFF FUNDING A YEAH WE HAVE
A PROBLEM -- WHAT WHAT WHAT
THIS PLAN DOES IS TRY TO LAY
OUT A PLAN -- AND WHAT I WILL
DO AND THEN TWENTY NINETEEN
PROJECT UPDATE REPORT IN THE
TWENTY TWENTY BUSINESS PLAN IS
COME BACK TO YOU AND CONTINUE
TO REFINE AND LAY OUT THE
PROGRAM IN THE PLAN SO THAT
IF YOU HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY
TO VOTE IN TWENTY TWENTY FOUR
AND REDIRECTING CAP AND TRADE
DOLLARS THAT WE'VE LAID OUT A
PROPOSAL FOR YOU IN A PLAN FOR
YOU THAT YOU WOULD NOT WANT TO
DO THAT THE BUT IF SHOULD THE
LEGISLATURE DECIDE TO DO THAT
WILL HAVE A PROBLEM SAYS THE
CURRENTLY ONLY HAVE ONE PLAN
THERE'S NO PLAN B.
YEAR I OTHER CONTINGENCY
PLANS NO WE WE WERE WERE ALL
LOOK WE'RE REQUIRED UNDER THE
STATUTE TO ESTIMATE AND LAY
OUT FOR YOU WHAT WE DO WITH
THE AVAILABLE FUNDS DEDICATED
THE PROJECT AND THAT'S THAT'S
WHAT WE'VE DONE IN THIS PLAN
-- YEAH WE CERTAINLY WELCOME
OTHER FUNDS IDEA ADMIT BUT
THAT'S BUT THAT'S NOT WHAT
YOU'VE DONE IN THE PLAN BECAUSE
AS THE CHAIRMAN TO SAY YOU
HAVEN'T CALCULATED OUT THE
COST OF INFLATION FOR FROM
THE PROJECTS ACTUALLY AND WE
DON SO IT'S WE HAVE IN OUR
BECAUSE THIS IS A VALID COST
ESTIMATES OF WHAT THE SCENE
OF LIKE WITH THE INFLATION
AND WITH WITH NEW I MEAN THE
YEAH I I'M I'M I'M HONESTLY
EXPECTING TO HEAR SOMETHING
ABOUT THE TEARS GOING ON OF
THE STILL COST TO OVER HERE
BUT IT'S YOU HAVE NO GUARANTEE
ON YOUR FUNDING SIR AMEN I
AGREE WITH THAT WE HAVE NO
GUARANTEE ON OUR FUNDING WHAT
WE HAVE AND THAT'S WHY WE'RE
SAYING WE NEED THE CAP AND
TRADE DOLLARS TO BE SOLIDIFIED
AND THAT'S WHY WE LAID OUT IN
HERE WHAT THAT LOOKS LIKE I'D
I GOTTA SAY THAT I DON'T AGREE
THAT WE'VE GOT BEEN CUT OFF
PERMANENTLY WAS FROM FEDERAL
PARTNERS I BELIEVE THAT WE WILL
BE IN A POSITION TO -- WE HAVE
SUCH A DEDICATION THE STATE
REVENUE FOR THIS PROJECT THAT
I HOPE WILL CONTINUE TO HAVE
A RELATIONSHIP WITH FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT IN THE MATTER WHAT
LOOKS LIKE AND SOME SNAP IN AND
IT'S NOT SNAPSHOT IN TIME WHAT
WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE TO TRY
TO WORK THAT PARTNERSHIP GOING
FORWARD MISTER KELLY PLEASE GET
THE REST OF US THAT THE CRYSTAL
BALL THAT YOU SEE IN THE
FUTURE I CAN UNDERSTAND WHERE
YOU'RE COMING FROM THANK YOU
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
SCULLY THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS PLEASE
YEAH SO PLEASE MAKE US PROUD
SO MOVE FORWARD
WITH ITS NEXT PANEL
LA JOH NA PEER REVIEW GROUP
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE
SO MISTER KELLY IN YOUR GROUP
IF YOU WOULDN'T MIND JUST
HANG AROUND QUE SOME QUESTIONS
COME UP DURING THIS AFTER
THIS PANEL WOULD BE VERY
MUCH APPRECIATED THANK YOU
SO REALLY WHAT IT IS START
WITH THE -- LA O.
FIRST TOM WOULD YOU
PLEASE INTRODUCE
YOURSELF AND THEN PROCEED
GOOD AFTERNOON TIME HE WITHOUT
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
SERGEANTS DISTRIBUTED A
HANDOUT THAT ALL BE REFERRED
TO IT PARALLELS NETWORKS
THANKS AGAIN FOR HAVING
THIS YEAR'S PART OF THESE
PROCEEDINGS AS YOU KNOW
THE CALIFORNIA HIGH SPEED
RAIL AUTHORITY IS REQUIRED
TO PRODUCE A BUSINESS PLAN
EVERY EVEN YEAR THAT PROVIDE
CERTAIN KEY INFORMATION ABOUT
THE PLANT HIGH SPEED RAIL
SYSTEM GENERALLY ARE OFFICE
REVIEWS THAT PLANET OFFERS
ANALYSIS LEGISLATURE THIS
PRESENTATIONS GONNA PROVIDE
SOME BACKGROUND INFORMATION
ON PLANTS SYSTEM I THINK
IT'S USEFUL GIVEN THE NUMBER
ACRONYMS AND COMPONENT PARTS
THIS COMPLEX PROJECT TO JUST
SET THE STAGE BILL DESCRIBING
MAJOR CHANGES PROPOSED IN THE
DRAFT TWENTY EIGHTEEN BUSINESS
PLAN AND IDENTIFIES ISSUES
FOR LEGISLATIVE CONSIDERATIONS
ON PAGE TWO OF THE HANDOUT
THAT WE MAKE REFERENCE TO
PROPOSITION ONE EIGHTY EXCUSE
ME -- WHICH SPECIFIED CERTAIN
CRITERIA CONDITIONS THAT THAT'S
THE REAL SYSTEM ASSAULTING
EACH YEAR THAT'S REALLY
HELP PROJECT GOT STARTED FOR
EXAMPLE THE MEASURE REQUIRES
ELECTRIC TRAINS CAPABLE OF
OPERATING SPEEDS OF AT LEAST
TWO HUNDRED MILES PER HOUR
SPECIFIES MINIMUM TRAVEL
TIME TO ONE SPECIFIC ROUTES
THE OVERALL PROJECT VISION
IS DIVIDED INTO TWO PHASES
PHASE ONE OF THE SYSTEM WOULD
PROVIDE SERVICE FOR ABOUT FIVE
MILES FROM SAN FRANCISCO TO
ANAHEIM FACE TO EXTEND THE
SYSTEM NORTH TO SACRAMENTO
AND SOUTH TO SAN DIEGO IN
TWENTY SIXTEEN THE AUTHORITY
ESTIMATED PHASE ONE OF THE
SYSTEM WOULD BE COMPLETED IN
TWENTY TWENTY NINE AND COST
ABOUT SIXTY FOUR BILLION
DOLLARS THE AUTHORITY IS NOT
PROVIDED ESTIMATES OF THE
COST OR SCHEDULE FOR FEES TO
ON PAGE THREE ALL DISCUSS
THE PROJECT DELIVERY PLAN
FOR PHASE ONE DELIVERY PHASE
ONE IS DIVIDED INTO SEGMENTS
AT PHASE ONE OF -- THAT YOUR
PROJECTS TO WAITING TO TWO
SEGMENTS FOR FOR A PURPOSE
TODAY CRINKLY FORTY THE FIRST
OPERATION OF HIGH SPEED RAIL
IN THE STATE WILL BE AFTER
CONSTRUCTION OF THE INITIAL
OPERATING SECOND AT THE IOWA
US THAT WE'VE BEEN REFERRING TO
THIS AFTERNOON THAT'S GOING TO
CONNECT THE SILICON VALLEY TO
THE CENTRAL VALLEY IS COMMONLY
REFERRED TO AS THE VALLEY TO
VALLEY ONE IN TWENTY SIXTEEN
THE AUTHORITY ESTIMATED THAT
THE IOWA US WOULD COST ABOUT
TWENTY ONE BILLION DOLLARS
INITIALLY OPERATE BETWEEN SAN
JOSE AND A TERMINUS NORTH OF
BAKERSFIELD STARTING TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE CONSTRUCTION
OF THE INITIAL OPERATING
SEGMENT BEGAN WITH THE INITIAL
CONSTRUCTION SEGMENT IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY IN TWENTY
FIFTEEN THE ICE YES EXTENDS
FOR HUNDRED NINETEEN MILES
THROUGH THE CENTRAL VALLEY
FROM THAT EUROPE ABOUT TWENTY
FIVE MILES NORTH OF FRESNO TO
SHOW AFTER ABOUT TWENTY MILES
NORTH OF BAKERSFIELD IN TWENTY
SIXTEEN THE AUTHORITY ESTIMATED
COMPLETING CONSTRUCTION OF
THE I CS AT A COST OF SEVEN
POINT THREE BILLION DOLLARS
TO DATE ON PAGE FOUR OF THE
PROJECT HAS RECEIVED CAPITAL
FUNDING PRIMARILY FROM THREE
SOURCES THE FIRST OF THOSE
OF COURSE ARE PROPOSITION ONE
A BONDS THIS AUTHORIZES THE
TO SELL TEN BILLION DOLLARS
IN GENERAL OBLIGATION FUND
TO SUPPORT THE DEVELOPMENT
OF HIGH SPEED RAIL SYSTEM
AT THIS TIME STEVE IS SOLD
OUT TWO POINT THREE BILLION
DOLLARS IN PROPOSITION
ONE EIGHT MONTHS AND AS OF
DECEMBER THE AUTHORITY IT'S
BETTER COMMITTED ABOUT ONE
POINT SEVEN BILLION DOLLARS
OF THAT TOTAL FEDERAL FUNDS
ARE THE SECOND MAJOR SOURCE OF
CAPITAL FUNDING YOU THIRTIES
RECEIVED A TOTAL OF THREE HALF
BILLION DOLLARS IN FEDERAL
FUNDS TWO POINT SIX BILLION
THAT IS FROM THE AMERICAN
RECOVERY AND REINVESTMENT
ACT THE AUTHORITY IS FULLY
EXPENDED THOSE PARTICULAR
FUNDS AS OF SEPTEMBER TWENTY
SEVENTEEN SECOND STATE
RECEIVING NINE HUNDRED TWENTY
NINE MILLION DOLLAR GRANT
COMMONLY REFERRED TO AS THE
FY TEN GRAND THAT IS NOT YET
ACCESSES CO KELLY INDICATED
FINALLY OF COURSE CAP
INTRODUCTION REVENUES ARE
THE THIRD AND MAJOR LEG
OF THE STOOL STEVE BEGAN
PROVIDING CAP INTRODUCTION
PROCEEDS YOU FORTY -- IN THE
MATTER TWENTY FIVE PERCENT
ANNUAL CONTINUES PREPARATIONS
BEGINNING IN TWENTY FIFTEEN
SIXTEEN AT THIS TIME A TOTAL
OF ROUGHLY ONE AND A HALF
BILLION DOLLARS AND CAPTURED
REVENUES HAVE BEEN PROVIDED TO
THE FORTY AND AS OF DECEMBER
TWENTY SEVENTEEN BEFORE IT
SPENT ALMOST SIX HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS THOSE ONCE
YOU FORTY ALREADY GIVE US
AN OVERVIEW OF THE MAJOR
FEATURES OF THE DRAFT TWENTY
EIGHTEEN BUSINESS PLAN SO
I WON'T DWELL ON THE SKIRT
FOR TOO LONG BUT BEGINNING
ON PAGE FIVE WILL NOTE THAT
WE'VE GOT A MAP INDICATING
A THIEF ONE THE INITIAL
OPERATIVE SEGMENT AND INITIAL
CONSTRUCTION SEGMENT THIS ARE
SUBSETS OF OF THE OTHERS AND
IT'S WORTH UNDERSCORING AGAIN
THAT THE DRAFT TWENTY EIGHTEEN
PLAN PROPOSES TO CHANGE THE
SCOPE OF THE IOS EXTENDING
IT TO SAN FRANCISCO IN TO
BAKERSFIELD THAT'S CONNECTED
TO A LARGER POPULATION CENTERS
IT ALSO ASSUMES A DELAY
IN THE OPERATION OF THAT I
WEST NOW IN TWENTY TWENTY
NINE FOUR YEARS LATER THAN
ASSUME IN THE SIXTEEN PLAN
MAJOR FEATURE OF THE TWENTY
EIGHTEEN PLAN -- YOU'RE
YOU'RE THE TOP PAGE SIX AND
HE PROPOSES EARLY INSURANCE
SERVICES I COMPLETED
CONSTRUCTION SEGMENTS
PREVIOUSLY UNDER THE SIXTEEN
PLAN NO REAL SERVICES WERE
EXPECTED TO BEGIN UNTIL FOR
COMPLETION OF THE IOWA US
AS YOU'RE KILLING NOTED A
THE AUTHORITY OF PROPOSES
TO WATCH REALLY INTERESTS
REVERSES ON THE SAN FRANCISCO
TO GILROY CORRIDOR AND ON
COMPLETED ICE YES THE PLAN
SUGGESTS THAT THOSE COMPLETED
SEGMENTS COULD HOST ENHANCE
CALTRAIN OR AMTRAK SERVICES
WERE POTENTIALLY ABBREVIATED
HIGH SPEED RAIL OPERATIONS
PRESIDENT STRUCTURE COSTS
HAVE BEEN REVISED UPWARD AND
BY ABOUT A TOTAL OF THIRTEEN
BILLION DOLLARS FOR THE WHOLE
FEES ONE MOVING TO SIXTY
FOUR TO SEVENTY SEVEN BILLION
DOLLARS IT'S ABLE TO BOTTOM
OF PAGE SIX SUMMARIZES THE
ROUTING NUMBER THROUGH VARIOUS
SEGMENTS OF THE PROJECT
OKAY SEVEN WE DISCUSS THE
PROJECT FUNDING PLAN THE DRAFT
PLAN IDENTIFY SCHOOL FUNDING
FOR THE ICS FROM VARIOUS FUN
SOURCES INCLUDING PROPOSITION
ONE A BONDS FEDERAL GRANTS
AND CABINETRY REVENUES
TO COMPLETE THE I WAS THE PLAN
ASSUMES FURTHER EXTENSION OF
CABINETRY AND SECURITIZATION
OF THOSE REVENUES
THIS PLAN IS THE CAPTURE
PROGRAM EXCUSE ME IS CURRENTLY
ONLY AUTHORIZED OF COURSE
THROUGH TWENTY THIRTY FINALLY
IT ASSUMES THAT ADDITIONAL
FUNDING BECOMES AVAILABLE FOR
THE REMAINDER OF FEES ONE THE
BALANCE OF CONSTRUCTION OF FEES
ONE THAT IS FROM BAKERSFIELD
SOUTH TO ANAHEIM BLS ANGELES
IS CURRENTLY ESTIMATED TO
COST FORTY SEVEN POINT EIGHT
BILLION DOLLARS WHILE THE PLAN
DOES NOT IDENTIFY SPECIFIC
FUNDING SOURCES IN AMOUNTS THE
FUND THAT CONSTRUCTION IT DOES
DISCUSS THE POTENTIAL SOURCES
INCLUDING A COMBINATION OF
FEDERAL SOURCES I'M BORROWING
AGAINST THE NET OPERATING
REVENUES AT THE IOWA US
ON PAGE EIGHT WE CAN'T
FOR ISSUES FOR LEGISLATIVE
CONSIDERATION THE FIRST IS
THE ACTUAL PROJECT COSTS COULD
BE EVEN HIGHER THE AUTHORITY
NOTED OF COURSE THEY'RE NOT
PRESENT COSTS IN RANGES NAY
DESERVE CREDIT FOR THAT I THINK
IT'S AN IMPROVEMENT BUT THAT
ALSO MEANS THAT THE COST THE
PROJECT COULD BE SUBSTANTIALLY
HIGHER IN THE HEADLINE NUMBER
SEVEN SEVEN BILLION DOLLARS
THAT YOU HEARD ABOUT UP TO AS
HIGH AS NINETY EIGHT BILLION
DOLLARS IN FACT SEVERAL FACTORS
NEED TO BE DECIDED THOSE
INCLUDE FINAL DESIGN DECISIONS
PROCUREMENTS AND THERE COULD
BE CONSTRUCTION DELAYS THAT ARE
HARD TO FORESEE AT THIS STAGE
IN THOSE COULD ALL POTENTIALLY
AFFECT THAT EVENTUAL ACTUAL
COST THERE SIGNIFICANT
UNCERTAINTIES REGARDING
FUNDING TO COMPLETE THE IOS
AS YOU NOTED A LARGE PORTION
OF THE FUNDING IDENTIFY FOR
THE AYE WEST WOULD COME FROM
BORROWING AGAINST FUTURE
CABINETRY AT AUCTION REVENUES
THROUGH TWENTY FIFTY THE US
WITHOUT LEGISLATIVE ACTION
TO EXTEND THE CAP AND TRADE
PROGRAM THE TOTAL CAP AND TRADE
FUNDS YOU FORTY PLANS TO USE
CLEARLY I LESS WOULD PROBABLY
NOT BE AVAILABLE TO THE EXTENT
THAT LEVEL OF ACTION REVENUES
ASSUMED IN THE DRAFT PLAN DOES
NOT MATERIALIZE WITH COSTS
ARE HIGHER THAN EXPECTED IN
THIS BASELINE ESTIMATES THE
STATE WOULD NEED TO IDENTIFY
OTHER FUNDS WERE SAID TO HELP
FINANCE THE I WAS THE GENERAL
FUND TO BE ONE OF THOSE SOURCES
THERE'S NO COMPLETE FUNDING
PLAN FOR THE REMAINDER OF
FEES POINT WELL THE DRAFT
PLAN DISCUSSES THE POSSIBILITY
OF SECURE TIES IN THE NET
OPERATING REVENUES AT THE I
WAS THERE SEVERAL POTENTIAL
CHALLENGE THIS APPROACH FIRST
IT'S UNCLEAR THE INITIAL
SYSTEM WILL ACTUALLY GENERATE
NOT SURPLUS SECOND YOU THREE
ANTICIPATES A SECURE TIES IN
THE NET CASH FLOW WOULD MAKE
ADDITIONAL FUNDING AVAILABLE
NEW SOONER THAN TWENTY THIRTY
TWO EVEN THOUGH FUNDS WOULD
LIKELY BE NEEDED EARLIER TO
COMPLETE PHASE ONE BY TWENTY
THIRTY THREE HAS ASSUMED
AND CLAMPED THIRD THE PLAN
ESTIMATES THAT THE AMOUNT OF
FUNDING THAT BE GENERATED WOULD
FALL SUBSTANTIALLY SHORT OF THE
LEVEL NEEDED TO COMPLETE PHASE
ONE THAT IS NOT SPECIFICALLY
IDENTIFY HOW THE SHORTFALL
WILL BE MET AS I MENTIONED
THAT BALANCE TO BE STRUCK XIN
YES IT FOR THAT IS THE FORTY
SEVEN POINT EIGHT BILLION
DOLLARS AND THE PLAN INDICATES
THAT SECURE TYPE THING AND
OPERATING REVENUES MIGHT BRING
IN TEN ELEVEN TWELVE BILLION
DOLLARS IN FINANCING PROCEEDS
FINALLY ON PAGE NINE JUST
UNDERSCORE BEFORE FUNDING PLANT
IS CRUCIAL FOR THE SUCCESS OF
THE HIGH SPEED RAIL PROJECT
AND AT THIS TIME TO COMPLETELY
VIABLE FUNNY PLAN TO COMPLETE
THE IRS AND THE MANGER FEES
ONE DOES NOT EXIST RUSS BROWN
IS OUR CABINETRY EXPERT IS
HERE WITH ME AS WELL BE HAPPY
TO ENTERTAIN ANY QUESTIONS
NO MISTER CHAIRMAN HAVE AN
ANSWER QUESTIONS IF YOU THINK
YOU IT'S TWO THOUSAND UP
MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK YOU VERY
MUCH OF FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO APPEAR HERE TODAY AND I
WANT ESPECIALLY TO THANK YOU
FOR THE KIND WORDS YOU SAID
ABOUT WHAT WE'VE TRIED TO DO
SO FAR OF WE FOUND IT A GREAT
PLEASURE TO WORK WITH YOU AND
WITH YOUR STAFF WE ARE ACUTELY
CONSCIOUS OF THE DIFFICULTY
IN THE COMPLEXITY OF THIS
DECISIONS THAT YOU'RE FACING
RIGHT NOW AND ANYTHING WE CAN
DO TO CONTRIBUTE TO THAT IS I
THINK WORTHWHILE WE VERY MUCH
ENJOYED IT I WON APPROVED OF
THE PRESENT -- MARTY BLACKS
AS APOLOGIES A LAST MINUTE
SCHEDULE PROBLEM -- I TOOK
HIM OUT OF THIS -- I'M THE
CHAIRMAN OF THE PEER REVIEW OF
COMMITTEE AS A GROUP THAT HAS
-- NOTED AND WE REPORT TO THE
LEGISLATURE A DIVIDEND SOME
FIFTEEN REPORTS TODAY THAT THE
LEGISLATURE ON THE STATUS OF
THE HIGH SPEED RAIL PROJECT
WE SENT A LETTER TO THE --
CHAIRMAN AND THEN CHAIRMAN
ON THE SENATE SIDE AS WELL
COMMENTING ON THE DRAFT TWENTY
EIGHTEEN BUSINESS PLAN LAST
FRIDAY I WANT TO SUMMARIZE
THOSE COMMENTS -- TODAY THEY
FALL INTO CATEGORIES OF ONE IS
THE POLICY ISSUES THAT YOU'RE
GOING TO BE FACING AND THE
OTHER IS SOME COMMENTS ON DE
YET OF THE CONTENT WITH THE
PLAN ITSELF AND I REALLY WANT
TO FOCUS FIRST ON THE POLICY
ISSUES BECAUSE I THINK THEY ARE
MUCH MORE IMPORTANT WE BELIEVE
THAT THE HIGH SPEED PROJECT HAS
NOW REACHED A CRITICAL POINT
WHERE DIFFICULT DECISIONS NEED
TO BE MADE ABOUT THE PROJECT
FUTURE SCOPE AND FUNDING QUITE
SIMPLY AS A RESULT OF COST
INCREASES IN CHANGES IN THE
FUNDING SOURCES THE AUTHORITY
CAN NO LONGER COMPLETE THE LINK
FROM CENTRAL VALLEY EITHER TO
THE LA BASIN ORDER SAN JOSE
IN THE FINANCIAL THE US AS IT
STANDS TODAY THERE IS LITTLE
PROSPECT FOR A SYSTEM THAT
WOULD GENERATE ENOUGH CASH
FLOW TO CONTRIBUTE TO FUTURE
INVESTMENT THIS DILEMMA DOES
NOT COME AS A SURPRISE IT
HAPPENS NEARLY EVERY TIME WE
TRY TO TRANSLATE A MEGA PROJECT
FROM THE GRAND VISION INTO A
WORKING SYSTEM AND IT IS NOT
NECESSARILY A REFLECTION ON
THE CONFIDENCE OR HONESTY OF
THE PEOPLE AT THE AUTHORITY
WHO HAVE BEEN TRYING TO BUILD
A SYSTEM THE CRITICAL QUESTION
THOUGH IS WHERE DO WE GO FROM
HERE THE DRAFT PLAN DOESN'T
REALLY LAY OUT THE CHOICES THE
HUH IN ADDRESSING THIS QUESTION
THE GROUP PLAYED OUT FOR BROAD
OPTIONS BUT THESE WERE MEANT
BASIC OF YOU PROVOKE A DEBATE
THERE COULD BE OTHER OPTIONS
THAT ANYONE COULD ENTER INTO
THIS FIRST OPTION IS WE COULD
JUST STOP STOP WHERE WE ARE
PAY ALL OF WHAT WE HAVE TO PAY
OFF AND AND CUT OUR LOSSES THE
SECOND OPTION IS THAT WE COULD
COMPLETE WHAT WE'RE DOING IN
THE CENTRAL VALLEY BASICALLY
AND CREATE WHATEVER VALUE WE
COULD CREATE THEIR AND AND THE
WORK THAT'S COMMITTED ON THE
ENDS AND STOP THERE THE THIRD
OPTION -- WE COULD DO WHAT
AFFECT AND EFFECT THE BUSINESS
PLAN IS SUGGESTING WHICH IS
COMPLETE THE CENTRAL VALLEY
HAD THE CONNECTIONS TO GILROY
AND BAKERSFIELD AND IMPROVE
LA UNION STATION WHILE WAITING
TO FIND OUT WHAT DRACO PASSED
TUNNELS ARE GOING TO COST AND
HOW WE MIGHT GO ABOUT FINANCING
THAT OR FOURTH WE COULD REALLY
COMMIT TO THE FULL PHASE ONE
WITH THE UNDERSTANDING THAT
SUCH A DECISION WOULD HAVE TO
BE BASED ON THE ADOPTION OF
A CREDIBLE LONG TERM PLAN TO
FINANCE THE SYSTEM INCLUDING
THE POSSIBILITY THAT SYSTEM
COST MIKE WILL COME IN AT
THE HIGH END OF THE RANGE WE
DON'T VIEW THE FIRST OPTION
SIMPLY STOPPING AS CREDIBLE
IT WOULD LEAVE US WITH NOTHING
USEFUL AND WE WERE PROBABLY
STILL HAVE TO PAY BACK THE
FEDERAL ERA MONEY THE SECOND
OPTION STOPPING WITH THE
CENTRAL VALLEY PLUS A BOOK AND
IMPROVEMENTS WOULD WORK BUT
IT WOULD LIMIT THE VALUE OF
THE RESULT THE THIRD OPTION
AS IN THE DRAFT PLAN PROBABLY
MAKES THE BEST USE OF THE
EXISTING SITUATION ESPECIALLY
IN BRINGING NEAR TERM BENEFITS
TO THE MILLIONS OF CURRENT
PASSENGERS ON THE BOOKENDS BUT
IT LEAVES THE STATE SHORT OF
THE SYSTEM THAT WOULD BE ABLE
TO CONTRIBUTE TO FINANCING OF
THE REMAINDER OF THIS BEFORE
FOURTH OPTION WHICH WOULD
BE COMPLETING PHASE A AS
ORIGINALLY PLANNED DOES MEET
THE REQUIREMENTS OF PROP ONE
NAY BUT IT CANNOT BE DONE WITH
CURRENT FUNDING PROVISIONS
ARE SOURCES SIMPLY PUT WE DO
NOT BELIEVE THAT IT IS FAIR
A CREDIBLE ANY LONGER TO ASK
MANAGEMENT TO DELIVER A LONG
TERM PROJECT OF THIS SIZE AND
COMPLEXITY WITH SOURCES OF
FUNDING BETTER INADEQUATE IN
TOTAL AND UNRELIABLE AND ANY
GIVEN YEAR IF THE PROJECT IS
TO GO AHEAD BEYOND ESSENTIALLY
THE SECOND OPTION THE STATE
WILL NEED TO DEVELOP A SOURCE
OF FUNDING THAT IS UP TO
THE TASK THIS IS NOT A NEW
ISSUE THERE HAS ALWAYS BEEN
A FUNDING GAP OF SOME SIZE
DEPENDING ON THE ASSUMPTIONS
ABOUT COST IN INCOME IT WAS
CLEAR IN THE TWENTY SIXTEEN
BUSINESS CLASS PLAN THAT THERE
WAS A FUNDING GAP OF AROUND
FOURTEEN BILLION DOLLARS FOR
THE MEDIUM ASKED MONTH AND
THERE WAS AN ADDITIONAL TEN
BILLION THAT WAS NEEDED TO
GET TO THE POINT WHERE OF
REVENUES COULD BE GENERATED
FROM SELLING THE SERVICE
ITSELF IN OTHER WORDS IT WAS
SOMEWHERE AROUND TWENTY BILLION
THAT WOULD BE NEEDED TO GET
TO THE POINT WHERE INVESTMENT
MONEY FROM THE PRIVATE SECTOR
COULD BE GENERATED WHAT IS
NEW IS THE INCREASING SIZE OF
THE GAP ALONG WITH A CLEARER
UNDERSTANDING OF THE NEED
TO MAKE THE HIGH SPEED RAIL
AUTHORITIES FUNDING STABLE AND
PREDICTABLE THERE ARE OBVIOUS
WAYS TO DEAL WITH THIS YOU
COULD INCREASE TO SHARE OF CAP
AND TRADE RECEIPTS GOING TO
THE PROJECT YOU CAN GUARANTEE
THEIR INCOME OR PERMIT THEM TO
ISSUE SOME KIND OF GUARANTEE
BLINDS AGAINST THE STATE
AGAINST PREDICTED REVENUES
THAT COULD BE A TAX ON FUELS
LARA SALES TAX WAS PROPOSED
IN THE TWO THOUSAND BUSINESS
PLAN THERE ARE OTHER SOURCES
THAT MIGHT EMERGE LIKE FUTURE
FEDERAL GRANT PROGRAMS FEDERAL
LANDS IT CETERA BUT THEN AGAIN
THEY MIGHT NOT THE PROBLEM
WILL NEED TO BE ADDRESSED IN
ONE WHERE NO THERE IF EVEN
THE THIRD OPTION OR BEYOND IS
TO BE COMPLETED IN PARALLEL
WITH DEALING WITH THE NEED FOR
IMPROVED APPROACH THE FUNDING
ESPECIALLY BECAUSE THE STATE'S
ROLE IS LIKELY TO GO UP GROW WE
RECOMMEND THAT THE LEGISLATURE
RE VALIDATE THE PRIORITY OF THE
HIGH SPEED RAIL IN THE LIGHT OF
THE COMPETING NEEDS ELSEWHERE
IN THIS TRANSPORTATION TEN
OVER WHAT ALL AND THAT STATE'S
BUDGET THIS IS THE TASK OF
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE AND
THE TREASURY DEPARTMENT OR
TRANSPORTATION ALONG WITH THE
COMMUNITIES AFFECTED WOULD
BE WELL SUITED TO CARRY OUT
FOR THE LEGISLATURE I KNOW OF
MISTER CHAIRMAN YOUR QUESTION
AND ANOTHER QUESTION ABOUT
YOU KNOW BENEFITS OTHER THAN
REVENUES AND COST THIS WAS
ACTUALLY ADDRESSED AN EARLIER
BUSINESS PLANS WITH THE DID
ATTEMPT AN ECONOMIC A SOCIAL
BENEFIT COST ANALYSIS OF THE
STUDY AND HOW MUCH THAT WAS
WORTH IT WOULDN'T BE THAT
DIFFICULT TO RE COMMISSION THAT
KIND OF WORK AND YOU MIGHT WANT
TO CONSIDER WE DO HAVE SOME
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR SPECIFIC
CHANGES IN THE FINAL PLAN ONE
WE BELIEVE THEY WOULD BENEFIT
FROM INCLUDING AND REPORTING
ON THE END OF IT INPUTS FROM
THE EARLY OPERATORS SOON AS
POSSIBLE WE HAVE LONG ARGUED
FOR THE INCLUSION OF THE
ADVICE OF AN EARLY OPERATOR
NOW THEY'VE ACQUIRED THE EARLY
OPERATOR WE SHOULD BEGIN TO
SEE THE INPUTS FROM THAT EARLY
OPERATORS SOON AS POSSIBLE
WE NEED A BETTER EXPLANATION
OF THE BUSINESS MODEL THIS
MAY SOUND STRANGE BUT THIS IS
NOT A CONSTRUCTION WHAT WE'RE
ACTUALLY DOING IS BUILDING A
BUSINESS TO SERVE THE PEOPLE
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND
YET THE BUSINESS PLAN DOESN'T
PROVIDE THE KIND OF STRUCTURE
DESCRIPTION WE THINK SHOULD BE
PROVIDED UP WHAT IS IT GOING
TO LOOK LIKE WHEN IT ACTUALLY
ARRIVES WHO'S GONNA DO WHAT TO
WHOM ARE WE NEED TO PUT MORE
EMPHASIS ON DEVELOPING DETAILED
AGREEMENTS WITH THE BOOK AND
OPERATORS IN THE FREIGHT REYES
DESCEND SIMPLE IT IS ANYTHING
BUT WHEN TWO OR THREE OPERATORS
HAVE TO LIVE TOGETHER ON THE
SAME PIECE OF TRACK ESPECIALLY
FREIGHT AND COMMUTERS AND THEY
HAVE TO DECIDE WHO GETS WHAT
PRIORITY WHO PAYS WHAT TO WHOM
IT IS VERY CALM AND THESE OF
THE DECISION SHOULD NOT BE LEFT
TO LAST MINUTE THEY NEED TO
DEVELOP WE NEED TO DEVELOP AND
I PUT THE EMPHASIS ON WE A LONG
RANGE PROGRAM FOR ADDRESSING
GREAT CROSS ESPECIALLY BECAUSE
MORE SERVICES NOW GOING TO BE
PROVIDED JOINTLY BETWEEN SAN
JOSE AND GILROY AND AND THE
OF BURBANK TO ANAHEIM AREA
OF MORE AND MORE ENCOUNTERS
ARE GONNA BE THERE BETWEEN
AUTOMOBILES OR TRUCKS OR GAS
TRUCKS AND HIGH SPEED TRAINS
NOW THIS CAN'T BE SOLVED
IMMEDIATELY AND THERE THERE'S
NOT A PROBLEM JUST FOR THE HIGH
SPEED RAIL AUTHORITY IT'S A
PROBLEM FOR THEM PLUS COMMUTER
RAILWAY SPLIT FREIGHT RAILWAYS
PLUS THE HIGHWAY AUTHORITIES
PLUS EVERYBODY INVOLVED BUT
IT SHOULD START NOW AND CAL
CALTRANS WOULD BE A GOOD PLACE
TO ASK THAT IT BEGAN WE NEED TO
CLARIFY THE PERFORMANCE OF THE
SYSTEM IS SHOWN IN TRIP TIME
CALCULATIONS AND SCHEDULES OF I
AM INFORMED THAT THEY ARE STILL
TECHNICALLY CAPABLE OF MEETING
THE TWO HOUR FORTY MINUTE TRIP
TIME BUT I THINK CONTINUING
OF MY ATTENTION TO THAT WOULD
BE WORTHWHILE WE WOULD LIKE
TO CONTINUE THE EMPHASIS ON
SHOWING PROJECTIONS AS RANGERS
RATHER THAN POINT ESTIMATES
IT'S ABSOLUTELY IMPORTANT AND
TRACK BUT I THINK IT WOULD
BE USEFUL TO EXPAND THAT TO
INCLUDE THE CAPITAL ESTIMATES
AS WELL SO WE CAN BEGIN TO
GET A GOOD SENSE OF WHAT'S
THE PROBABILITY OF VARIOUS
KINDS OF OUTCOMES NOT ONLY
THE EXPECTED OUTCOME BUT WHAT
HAPPENS IF IT ALL GOES WRONG
-- WE DON'T HAVE THAT YET BUT
WE COULD HAVE THAT IF THIS WORK
IS EXTENDED TO GIVE US THAT
INFORMATION FINALLY WE THINK
THEY NEED TO PROVIDE BETTER
BACK UP PROCLAIM SURE BENEFITS
URBAN AND REGIONAL DEVELOPMENT
THAT THE BENEFITS ARE CLEAR BUT
THE BACKUP FOR WHAT HOW MUCH
BUT IS IT WORTH WHAT WILL IT
DO WELL WE HOPE THESE CAN BE
ADDRESSED THESE MORE TECHNICAL
POINTS CAN BE ADDRESSED IN
THE FINAL PLAN WE BELIEVE THE
LEGISLATURE'S IMMEDIATE FOCUS
SHOULD BE ON THE FUNDING AND
POLICY THANK YOU ENOUGH AND
THESE ARE BIG QUESTIONS BUT IF
I CAN HELP YOU ANSWERING THEM
I WOULD CERTAINLY LIKE TO TRY
THANK YOU MISTER THOMPSON
HER ANY QUESTIONS OF
THE COMMITTEE PANEL
THE CRAFT SO MEMBERS BAKER
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR A
VERY CLEAR -- OVERVIEW OF
WHAT YOU'RE LOOKING AT THE
WORK THAT YOU'VE PUT INTO IT
AND I WANT TO GO BACK TO HAVE
ONE OF THE LAST TWO POINT
YOU'RE MAKING ABOUT TRIP
TIMES YOU SAID I AM INFORMED
THAT IT'S STILL TECHNICALLY
POSSIBLE FOR THIS TO BE TWO
HOURS AND FORTY MINUTES AND
THEN I THINK CLEARLY I THINK
YOUR SUMMARY SAID ABOUT
THREE HOURS INTENTIONALLY --
HOW MUCH SCRUTINY LIKE REAL
SCRUTINY RIGOROUS SCRUTINY
HAS THAT HAVE THE TRIP TIMES
RECEIVED INDEPENDENT FROM ON
HIGH SPEED RAIL AUTHORITY IS
SAYING WILL HAPPEN WELL I'VE
DISCUSSED THIS ISSUE WITH
THEM THERE IS SOMETHING AND
RAILWAY PARLANCE CALLED IT OUT
TRAIN PERFORMANCE CALCULATORS
COMPUTER PROGRAM THAT TAKES
ALL OF THE VARIOUS ASSUMPTIONS
INTO ACCOUNT AND PREDICTS A
TRIP TIME FOR THE TRAIN VAT
OF I BELIEVE IS STILL SHOWING
THE LESS THAN TWO OR AND THEN
FORTY MINUTES FOR A TRAIN THAT
STARTS IN SAN FRANCISCO AND
DOESN'T STOP UNTIL IT GETS OF
LOS ANGELES ARE THEY WILL NEVER
SCHEDULE THAT TRAINS NOR WILL
THE OPERATING SCHEDULE EVER
SHOW THAT KIND OF TRIP TIME IT
WILL BE MORE LIKE THREE HOURS
THREE HOURS AND TEN MINUTES
WHICH THEIR BUSINESS PLANS
HAVE SHOWN FOR SCHEDULED TRAINS
WITH THREE STOPS THAT'S NOT
UNREASONABLE ARE IN THE DEMAND
FORECASTING THAT THEY'VE DONE
THIS CONSISTENT WITH THAT OUR
POINT HAS BEEN ESPECIALLY THAT
THE DEMAND FORECASTING SHOULD
BE CONSISTENT WITH THE ACTUAL
SCHEDULE NOW WITH THE OPTIMUM
POSSIBLE RUNTIME BUT OF THERE
THERE IS AN ISSUE OF WHAT IS A
LEGISLATION ACTUALLY REQUIRING
IT APPEARS TECHNICALLY THAT
IT REQUIRES THAT THE SYSTEM BE
DESIGNED TO YIELD ON A TRAIN
PERFORMANCE CALCULATOR TIME
OF LESS THAN TWO HOURS AND
FORTY MINUTES AND TECHNICALLY
THEY CAN DO THAT AND WITH THE
AIR MARKS THAT YOU'RE MAKING
WITHOUT ME THAT IN THE BACK I
WHAT I'M HEARING IS THAT IT'S
IT WOULD HAVE TO TECHNICALLY
BE DESIGNED TO DO THAT ALTHOUGH
IT MAY NEVER DO THAT WHEN THAT
IF THEY DIDN'T MAKE IT WILL
NEVER KNOW YOU TWO HOURS AND
FORTY MINUTES NOT AS IT STANDS
NOW OBVIOUSLY OVER TIME OTHER
THINGS COULD BE DONE IF YOU
WANTED TO BUILD UP A BRAND
NEW TRACK OF FROM FROM SAN
FRANCISCO TO SAN JOSE OVERT
OR TO GIVE AWAY AND SEPARATED
COMPLETELY AND SEVEN AT YEAH
DOT COM COULD BE DONE OKAY
WELL THEY TECHNICALLY COULD
BE DONE IT HAS BEEN IS ARE
NOT I WOULDN'T ARGUE THAT THEY
NECESSARILY SHOULD I THINK THE
THE THAT WHAT WE ARE CIRCLING
IN ON MIGHT WELL BE THAT THE
BEST ANSWER TO THE PROBLEM
AND THE TRIP TIME POINTS AT
I THINK YOU HAVE THIS IN YOUR
REPORT AND I WOULD CERTAINLY
HEAR THIS FROM OUR CONSTITUENTS
IT'S ONE OF THE CRITICISMS
ABOUT CALLING AT HIGH SPEED
RAIL IS YOU KNOW FOLKS FEEL
LIKE FOR THE AMOUNT OF MONEY
THAT YOU CAN PAY ME TO FLY
ON ANY GIVEN VERY CONVENIENT
AIRLINE I WON'T PITCH ONE IN
PARTICULAR HERE -- I GET FROM
LA OR BURBANK TWO OAKLAND SAN
JOSE SAN FRANCISCO FOR ABOUT
THE SAME AMOUNT OF MONEY IF
NOT LAST FOR THE REST OF MY
LIFE AND THAT TRAVEL ONLY GET
MORE EFFICIENT AND CONVENIENT
ESPECIALLY WITH ALL THE OTHER
ADVANCES THAT WE MAKE ON HOW
YOU GET TO AN AIRPORT OTHER
PARTS OF TRAVEL -- AND HAS THE
HIGH SPEED RAIL AUTHORITY EVER
IN ANY OF ITS REPORTS AND I
THINK IT DOES IN THIS BUSINESS
PLAN TRY TO ACKNOWLEDGE WHAT
ARE THE OPPORTUNITY COSTS FOR
WHERE ELSE WE CAN PUT THOSE
DOLLARS TO GET MOBILITY FASTER
LIKE THAT ARE THE HELP OR
THE AIRLINE OPTION OR OTHER
OPTIONS THEY HAVE IN A NUMBER
OF PLANTS MAKE CALCULATIONS
OF HOW MANY LANES OF HIGHWAY
CAN BE AVOIDED BY BUILDING
HIGH SPEED RAIL HELP YOU KNOW
-- BUT OTHER INVESTMENTS CAN
BE AVOIDED BY INVESTING IN
THIS WAY OF I DON'T THINK --
EXCEPT IN THE BROADER SENSE
OF ECONOMIC BENEFITS ACOSTA
I'M NOT SURE I'VE EVER SEEN A
STUDY THAT SAYS WHAT THIS WOULD
WOULD DO IN THE HEALTH AREA IF
WE DIDN'T DO IT IN THE HOUSE
IT REALLY WELL AND I THINK
LEGISLATION LAST YEAR ACTUALLY
PROHIBITS THE ABILITY OF US
TO ADD MORE LANES YOU KNOW
WHEN YOU PLACES IN ORDER TO
RELIEVE CONGESTION SO I DON'T
KNOW THAT THROUGH EUROPE THAT
WE'RE ABLE TO COMPARE SOMETHING
FAIRLY IT WILL HAVE VERY HIGH
SPEED RAIL THE SOMETHING THAT
WE'VE NOW DECIDED IS A STATE
THAT WERE NOT REALLY GONNA BE
ABLE TO DO I'M NOT SURE THAT
NOT IF THEY'RE COMPARISON IT
IT SEEMED IMPOSSIBLE ANSWER
THESE QUESTIONS PRECISELY MY
BROTHER WHAT I'VE SAID IS THAT
I DON'T THINK WE CAN BUILD
MORE THE PAST AND CALL IT THE
FUTURE WE JUST CAN'T DO THAT --
WE'VE WAS THERE IT WON'T WORK
I THINK A HUNDRED YEARS FROM
NOW I PERSONALLY BELIEVE PEOPLE
WILL THANK US FOR DOING IT
BUT IT'S GOING TO BE DIFFICULT
AND YES THERE ARE HARD TRADE
OFFS THAT HAVE TO BE MADE AND
THAT'S HIM AGAIN GIVEN WHAT'S
HAPPENING NOW AND YOU MAY WELL
WANT TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO ASK US QUESTIONS
WELL ABSOLUTELY AND AND THAT'S
GOING TO MY NEXT ONE WHICH IS
THERE'S OTHER THERE'S OTHER
OPTIONS YOU LAY OUT IN AND
SUMMARY OF WHAT IS IDENTIFIES
POTENTIALLY DIFFERENT OPTIONS
ONE IS STOPPING JUST STOPPING
WHICH WHICH MANY CALIFORNIANS
SAY PLEASE DON'T SPEND ANOTHER
PENNY ON THIS BECAUSE I'D
RATHER SEE THOSE DOLLARS GO
INTO WHAT WE BELIEVE WILL HAVE
A HIGHER INCREASE OF QUALITY
OF LIFE IN MOBILITY IN ANOTHER
GOOD IMPACTS AND YOU MENTIONED
YOU DID NOT THINK THAT WAS
APPROPRIATE SWEEP VOICES
QUICKLY WE WOULD WE'LL BE STE
LEFT WITH AN ASSET THAT CAN'T
BE USED FOR ANYTHING THE THREAT
THAT OKAY THIS SECOND OPTION
YOU MENTION YOU THOUGHT WHICH
IS THE PLEASE SOME OF THE LINE
-- THAT WHAT WHAT WOULD BE
REALLY BE LEFT WITH THEIR THAT
IS OF VALUE YOU WOULD BE LEFT
WITH BETTER SERVICE ON THE SAN
JOAQUIN'S TO SOMEWHERE NEAR
BAKERSFIELD YOU WOULD BE LEFT
WITH MUCH BETTER SERVICE IN
THE CALTRAIN AREA YOU WOULD BE
LEFT WITH MUCH BETTER SERVICE
OR SIGNIFICANT IMPROVEMENTS IN
ON THE SOUTH END -- INCLUDING
THAT THE RESTAURANT MOST COURT
MORE COURT I HAD SAME PROBLEM
WITH THAT IS THAT WORK AND
THREE CROSSINGS -- AND -- ME
YOU WOULD HAVE YOU WOULD HAVE
BETTER SERVICE AND WHEN IT
LOOKS GOOD WITH IT WOULD WOULD
YOU HAVE DONE IT TO DO JUST
THAT NO YOU'RE PROBABLY GONNA
AND THAT'S OUR DECISION IS
THAT WE WE YOUR POINT EARLIER
ABOUT THE FUTURE AND USING
THE PAST AND THE FUTURE OF IN
THE REALITIES THIS IS WHERE
WE ARE GOING TO SPEND THESE
DOLLARS THAT I AM THINKING
HUNDRED YEARS IF WE STOP
THIS PROJECT BUT WE'VE DONE
KUWAIT CONNECTIONS BETWEEN
MEGA REGIONS WE'VE INVESTED IN
FUTURE TECHNOLOGIES WE MIGHT
HAVE A GENERATION THANKING
US FOR SPENDING THE DOLLARS
THAT WAY AND NOT HAVING THE
OPERATING COSTS THAT TAKE AWAY
FROM TRANSPORTATION A END TO
THIS WE DON'T KNOW WHAT'S THE
DECISION WE WE HAVE TO MAKE
-- FINALLY YOU MENTION YOU MAY
WANT TO LOOK AT OTHER OPTIONS
THAT THERE'S FOR THAT ARE
KIND OF SUMMARIZED A LITTLE
BIT BUT WHAT OTHER OPTIONS
DO YOU THINK WE SHOULD BE
LOOKING AT BEYOND THE FOR THAT
OR OR SAID ABOUT THEIR WORK
OR WHAT POSSIBILITIES WOULD
YOU SAY WE WANT TO BE SURE TO
CONSIDER I KNOW THAT'S A GOOD
QUESTION AYE I SUPPOSE ONE
OPTION WOULD BE PUTTING MORE
MONEY IN CONVENTIONAL RAIL
PASSENGER SERVICE AND MAYBE
LASSEN HIGH SPEED FOR EXAMPLE
A MUCH BETTER CONNECTION FROM
SACRAMENTO OF BETTER SERVICE
-- ANDI ES STRAINS WELL BETTER
SERVICE SO WE HAVE A BETTER
CONNECTION ON NAY FROM -- LA
TO SAN DIEGO THINGS THAT WOULD
NOT INVOLVE TWO HUNDRED TWENTY
MILES AN HOUR BUT WOULD INVOLVE
BETTER SERVICE ON EXISTING
CLIENTS WHERE THERE ARE A LOT
OF PASSENGERS ALREADY -- LIKE
IT IT IN AND WHAT I REALLY HOPE
WE CAN DO IS PROVOKE EXACTLY
THIS KIND OF DISCUSSION I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT AND THE LAST
IS THE PRIVATE FUNDING -- OFF
WE GET QUESTIONS ABOUT WHERE'S
THE PRIVATE FUNDING THAT THAT
AT LEAST FOLKS FEEL LIKE THEY
HEARD ABOUT TEN YEARS AGO
WHEN THIS WAS DEBATED AND I
UNDERSTAND THAT'S WELL OFF INTO
THE FUTURE WHAT DO YOU THINK
IS THE LIKELIHOOD OF THAT BEING
TRIGGERED AND COMING TO THE
RESCUE THE FACT I THINK IT'S
HIGHLY LIKELY AT SOME POINT
THAT THERE WILL BE SOME FORM
OF PRIVATE INVESTMENT IN THE
SYSTEM LET US NOT SUPPOSE YOU
GET TO A POINT WHERE YOU'RE
RUNNING TRAINS AND YOU SHOW
A LOT OF DEMAND AND A LOT OF
PROFITABILITY AND THEN YOU SAY
WHAT HOW MUCH MONEY WILL YOU
OFFER ME AROUND MY SYSTEM FOR
ME I THINK WE COULD WELL GET
TO THAT BUT THE THE POINT WE
WERE MAKING IS THAT GETTING TO
THAT POINT REQUIRES AN AWFUL
LOT OF INVESTMENT THAT WE RIGHT
NOW HAVE GOT THE FOLLOWING
THANK YOU THANK YOU CULTURE THE
QUESTION TIME SO GO TO WASTE
YOUR FOLLOWING THEM GO TO MR
MATHIS I JUST A COUPLE QUICK
QUESTIONS ATTILIO IN TERMS OF
THE ASSUMPTIONS BEING MADE IN
THE IN THE BUSINESS PLAN UP BUT
YOU WOULD DO YOU DO YOU S.
ASSESSOR AT IN YOUR ANALYSIS
DO YOU BELIEVE THAT THOSE
ASSUMPTIONS ARE REALISTIC
COULD BE MORE SPECIFIC ABOUT
WHICH ASSUMPTIONS HERE FOR
INTO -- THEY THAT THE THE
MODERNIZATION OF THE CAP
AND TRADE THAT DEBT SERVICE
ASSUMPTION THAT KEVIN TRAITS
AND BIG SAID THE TWENTY FIFTY
WE DON'T MEAN THERE'S A LOT
OF ASSUMPTIONS THAT TO SOMEHOW
MAKE THIS PROJECT WORK BUT
THEY DO YOU BELIEVE THERE
IS A THOSE ARE REALISTIC
I THINK I'M IN TERMS OF THE
ASSUMPTIONS FOR CAPTURED
REVENUE ELECT ROSS SPEAK TO
SPEAK TO THAT -- IN IN GENERAL
THE AUTHORITIES PROPOSING A SET
OF ACTIONS THAT WOULD MAKE THAT
REVENUE STREAM FINANCE BOWL --
AND THOSE SECURITY REASONABLE
TO TO OUR HOUSES -- IT WE DON'T
THINK THERE'S A SILLY MUCH MORE
OR MUCH LESS THAT THEY WOULD
NEED TO DO TO SATISFIED HE
DOESN'T COMMUNITY THAT MONEY
WOULD BE SUFFICIENT PLATE
INVESTMENT CREED IS AS THEY SAY
I -- MINUTES FOR IS THE
ASSUMPTION ON CAP AND TRADE
INS ARE THE STEPS WOULD NEED
TO BE TAKEN TO MAKE THAT SECURE
I MEAN THOSE OUR ASSUMPTIONS
ABOUT ACTIONS TAKEN BY A FUTURE
LEGISLATURE AND SO THOSE ARE
I MEAN YOU KNOW IT'S DIFFICULT
FOR US TO SAY SORT OF KNOW WHAT
TYPES OF OPTIONS LEGISLATURE
WILL TAKE BUT YOU KNOW THOSE
YACHTS HOPEFUL TO KIND HOW
THOSE OUTLINED IN KIND KNOW
WHAT TYPES OF STEPS MIGHT NEED
TO BE TAKEN IN ORDER TO COME
TO MAKE THAT FUNDING -- MORE
SECURE THAT CONTINUUM AND OF
THE WAY THAT YOU SAID IN A WAY
THAT YOU CAN SECURITIZED UNDER
-- FINANCE THINGS -- AS FAR AS
THE CAP AND TRADE REVENUE AND
WHAT TO EXPECT IN THE OUT YEARS
AS WAS MENTIONED THE PROGRAM
IS ONLY CURRENTLY AUTHORIZED TO
TWENTY THIRTY SO ONE OF THOSE
KEY ACTIONS WOULD BE -- EXTANT
IN THE PROGRAM OUT TO TWENTY
FIFTY -- BUT EVEN THE REVENUE
OUT TO TWENTY THIRTY -- THE
AUTHORITY I REFERENCE SOME OF
OUR NUMBERS THAT WE PUT OUT IN
A RECENT REPORTS WHICH PROVIDE
SORT OF A LOS REVENUE SCENARIO
IN HIGH REVENUE SCENARIO OUT
TO TWENTY THIRTY -- I THINK
NO COUPLE IMPORTANT POINTS
ONE THOSE ARE ABSOLUTE BALANCE
ON REVENUE I MEAN IT IS EVEN
POSSIBLE IN CERTAIN YEARS THAT
REVENUE WOULD DROP NO BELOW
A COUPLE BILLION DOLLARS IN
A PARTICULAR YEAR OR IT COULD
BE QUITE A BIT HIGHER THAN NO
SIX SEVEN EIGHT BILLION THAT
WE -- -- OUTLINED THIS SORT OF
OUR HIGH REVENUE SCENARIO ON
SUCH IMPORTANT TO KEEP IN MIND
-- AND SO -- I CAN GET INTO
AS MUCH DETAIL AS YOU WOULD
LIKE ON -- ALL THE VARIOUS
FACTORS THAT AFFECT CAP AND
TRADE REVENUE UNCERTAINTY
BUT AT A HIGH LEVEL NEW ARE
A HIGH LEVEL YEAH YOU REVENUE
DEPENDS ON ALLOWS CRISIS IN
THE NUMBER OF ALLOWANCES SOLD
AND THOSE FACTORS DEPEND ON
THINGS LIKE ECONOMIC CONDITIONS
TECHNOLOGICAL ADVANCEMENTS AS
WELL AS A VARIETY OF REGULATORY
DECISIONS -- THAT -- THE
CALIFORNIA AIR RESOURCES BOARD
HAS YET TO MAKE ON THINGS LIKE
-- YOU KNOW THE PRICE CEILINGS
SURE -- NUMBER ALLOWANCES ARE
GONNA BE ISSUED HOW MANY ARE
GIVEN AWAY FOR FREE THOSE TYPES
OF THINGS SO JUST TO GIVE YOU
A SENSE BUT LET ME CRYSTALLIZE
I GUESS MY CONCERN MY QUESTION
AND I I KNOW AS AS THE CHAIR
INDICATED NO CAP AND TRADE AS
THE PROGRAM AND FULLS OF THE
REVENUES WILL REDUCE OVERTIME
I GUESS AS AS HE HAS AS A
CHAIR STIPULATED SO HOW I SEE
IT IS WE HAVE AN UNCERTAIN
FUNDING PLAN WHICH AND PAGE
EIGHT YOU USE UNCERTAINTY A
LOT AGAIN IN YOUR ANALYSIS
AND THAT WE HAVE A VOLATILE
SOURCE OF FUNDING TO YOU PLUG
A LOT OF GAPS IN THIS TRAP PLAN
IS THAT A CORRECT ASSESSMENT
I THINK THAT'S A FAIR
CHARACTERIZATION AND MY LAST
QUESTION IN TERMS OF THE IF
THE MOST EFFECTIVE USE OF CAP
AND TRADE DOLLARS IS I THINK
THERE'S A LOT OF DEBATE IN THIS
BUILDING ABOUT THAT IS THERE
AN ANALYSIS DONE IN TERMS OF
THE COST BENEFIT ANALYSIS OF
SHOULD WE USE CAP AND TRADE
DOLLARS FOR THIS VERSUS OTHER
WAYS OF REDUCING WHATEVER SO
IF WE HAVE A A DELTA OF FIFTY
TO SEVENTY BILLION DOLLARS
-- FOR THIS PROJECT COULD
WE USE THAT MONEY FOR OTHER
PURPOSES MORE EFFECTIVELY
IS THAT HOUSE IS BEING
DONE OR CAN'T LA I DO THAT
I THINK IT LARGELY DEPENDS ON
THE LEGISLATURE'S PRIORITIES
MENACES AND YOU KNOW -- MONEY
THAT THE LEGISLATURE COULD
MAKE A VARIETY OF DIFFERENT
DECISIONS ON HOW TO SPEND
IT AND IT DEPENDS -- YES OR
YOUR MEASURE OF EFFECTIVENESS
DEPENDS ON EXACTLY WHAT YOU'RE
TRYING TO ACHIEVE HOW THE
ADMINISTRATION DOES PRODUCE
A REPORT ANNUALLY WHERE THEY
TRY TO ESTIMATE GREENHOUSE
GAS REDUCTIONS AND SO THERE'S
SOME INFORMATION IN THERE
AND THERE'S A WIDE RANGE OF
PROGRAMS AN ESTIMATED COST
PER TON OF EMISSION REDUCTIONS
OF THAT TYPE OF INFORMATION
IS AVAILABLE WE HAVE NO
SOME ISSUES WITH SOME OF THE
ESTIMATES BUT THERE'S A LITTLE
BIT OF INFORMATION THERE
BUT -- I THINK WE THINK THE
LEGISLATURE WE'VE ENCOURAGED
THE LEGISLATURE TO THINK A
LITTLE BIT MORE BROADLY EVEN
THEN GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSION
REDUCTIONS OF THE REGULATION
ITSELF CAP AND TRADE IS
INTENDED TO HELP THE STATE MEET
ITS GREENHOUSE GAS TARGETS AND
SO WE THINK THE LEGISLATURE
TO THINK BROADLY ABOUT HOW
WE COULD USE THIS MONEY ON A
VARIETY OF THINGS WHETHER IT
BE GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTIONS
LOCAL AIR POLLUTANT REDUCTIONS
OR THINGS EVEN OUTSIDE OF THAT
SCOPE THAT THE LEGISLATURE
CONSIDERED A HIGH PRIORITY SO
THINK ABOUT THAT WIDE RANGE OF
OPPORTUNITY COSTS IS IMPORTANT
ARGUE WHAT IF THE AND GET THE
LEO COULD GET A SYSTEM THAT I
REALLY APPRECIATE THAT COURSE
MATHIS
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR --
NAY ARREST WHERE THIS I MEAN
THE THE REVIEW THIS SUMMER YOU
GUYS GIVES US GREAT -- WOULD
IT WITH THE FACT THAT THERE ARE
A LOT OF ASSUMPTIONS -- YOU GO
THROUGH A LOT OF OPTIONS OF YOU
KNOW IF WE HAVE THE MONEY WE
CAN DO THIS OR IF WE HAVE THIS
WE CAN DO THAT S.
BUT I I'VE REALLY GOTTA ASK
IN THIS IS THE QUESTION QUITE
FRANKLY THAT I GAS AT HOME
ALL THE TIME WHEN IT WHEN IT
COMES TO HIGH SPEED RAIL AND
PRIVATE FUNDING IS WHY AREN'T
WE LOOKING TO PAY A HIGH
TO PRIVATIZE THIS IN AND DO
SOMETHING I MEAN WE WE HEAR ALL
THE TIME AND ON FACEBOOK FEES
AND EVERYTHING ELSE ABOUT HOW
THE AWESOME THINGS GUYS LIKE
IAN MUSKER DOING AND I SCREWED
UP GET ASKED ASSEMBLYMAN MATHIS
HOW COME WE ARE TALKING YA
MUST TO PRIVATIZE THIS IN HERE
PRIVATE DOLLARS TO DO THIS
ON SOMETHING THAT WE KNOW THE
TECHNOLOGIES MUCH FASTER AND
IT STILL GIVES ARE ALL OF OUR
GUYS THE JOBS IN THE BUILDING
AND EVERYTHING ELSE IS STILL
GIVES ALL OF THAT SOURCE
LOOKING TO BUILD ON THE WORK
FORCE WE'RE GONNA HAVE THE THE
JOB DEVELOPMENT GRAVEL THAT
EVERYTHING WE'RE GETTING FROM
I SCRAWLED ON ON THE JOB FRONT
BUT WE'RE ACTUALLY GETTING A
PRIVATE DOLLARS IN IN SOMEBODY
WITH BETTER TECHNOLOGY QUITE
FRANKLY I MEAN IT IT HE'S OF
THE QUESTIONS I GET ASKED ON
A DAILY BASIS WHEN I'M HOME SO
ON I'M ASKING YOU GUYS BUT WHAT
WHAT IS YOUR ANSWER TO THAT AND
HOW COME IF IF WE'RE LOOKING
AT ALL OPTIONS ARE ON THE TABLE
GETS HER WHY ISN'T THAT ONE
SOMETHING THAT'S BEING EXPLORED
IT THE ANSWER THAT I THINK IS
THAT IF THEY WERE ONLY PRIVATE
BENEFITS AND PRIVATE COSTS
THEN WE COULD LET THE LINE TAKE
CARE OF IT BUT THAT'S NOT THE
CASE THERE ARE MANIFEST PUBLIC
BENEFITS ASSOCIATED WITH THIS
LIKE POLLUTION LIKE CONGESTION
LIKE SAFETY LIKE OF NOISE LIKE
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACTS THAT THE
PRIVATE SECTOR WILL NOT PAY
FOR AND WE CAN'T ASK THEM TO
THERE ARE ALSO PUBLIC COSTS
-- THAT LIGHT EL OPPORTUNITY
BECAUSE WHERE ELSE I HATE TO
SOUND LIKE AN ECONOMIST I SWORE
NEVER WOULD PUT BUT I'VE GOTTEN
INTO THIS FROM TIME TO TIME
THERE PUBLIC COSTS THAT ALSO NO
PRIVATE ENTITY WILL TAKE INTO
ACCOUNT ONE WHERE THE OTHER
THE QUESTION OF THESE KIND OF
PROJECTS AND THIS IS EXACTLY
WHAT HAPPENS IN EUROPE IS IS
THE SOME OF THE PUBLIC AND
PRIVATE BENEFITS EQUAL TO THE
SUM OF THE PUBLIC AND PRIVATE
COSTS IN THE ONLY WAY TO TURN
MEANT TO DETERMINE THAT ONE
IS TO TRY TO PUT A NUMBER OR
SOME VALUE ON WHAT THE PUBLIC
BENEFITS ARE HOW MUCH IS IT
WORTH US TO US TO ELIMINATE
TWENTY GRADE CROSSING DEATHS
A YEAR BETWEEN SAN FRANCISCO
AND SAN JOSE HOW MUCH IS IT
WORTH IT TO US TO M.
TO REDUCE CONGESTION OF
BETWEEN -- SAN JOSE AND SAN
FRANCISCO DILLON MUST CAN'T
GENERATE THE MONEY TO PAY FOR
THAT ONLY THE PUBLIC SECTOR
CAN DO THAT AND THE QUESTION
IS IS THE COMBINATION OF
PUBLIC MONEY AND PRIVATE MONEY
EQUAL TO THE BENEFITS THAT
WE BOTH TO RUNNING SENSORS
ARE YOU SAYING YOU DON'T SEE
THE POSSIBILITY OF A PUBLIC
PRIVATE PARTNERSHIP THAT'S
EXACTLY WHAT THEY'RE TALKING
ABOUT BUT ONLY AT THE SECOND
PHASE OF THIS ONCE YOU'VE GONE
PAST THE POINT OF GETTING IN
AND OUR OPERATION THEN YOU
CAN SELL THE PRIVATE BENEFITS
TO THE PRIVATE SECTOR BUT THE
PUBLIC BENEFITS REMAIN IN ON
THE PUBLIC SIDE AS THEY SHOULD
LA AREAS HAVE ANYTHING READ
RELATED OF I HEARD THEY HAVE
YET EVEN LOOKED AT ANYTHING
LIKE THAT THAT'S OUTSIDE
THE SCOPE OF THE ANALYSIS
THAT WE'VE CONDUCTED ON THE
STRAP BUSINESS PLAN I DON'T
HAVE A WHOLE LOT MORE TO ADD
TO IT LOU SAID BUT I JUST
UNDERSCORES THAT THE DRAFT
PLAN DOESN'T VISION ONCE THE
IOWA'S OPERATIONAL SECURITIZED
THOSE REVENUES AND THAT
WOULD INVOLVE PRIVATE SECTOR
INVOLVEMENT IN A FINANCING
THE REST OF OF PHASE ONE
A OF BRING THEM BACK TO MY
CONSTITUENTS THINKS THANK
YOU THE OTHER QUESTIONS
OF THE COMMITTEE VOEPEL
I WILL JUST ADD MR MATHIS THE
QUESTION MUST WOULD HAVE TO
ALSO ACQUIRE ALL RIGHT AWAY A
PUBLIC PRIVATE YEAH STILL GOT
ACCORDING TO WRITE I WHICH IS
AN ONEROUS TASK AS WE CAN SEE
-- THIS IS A QUESTION FOR THE
JUDGE OF THIS TO THE ONLY TWO
FOR THE ACTIONS ITEMS REQUESTED
BY THE AUTHORITY OF THE OF
THE LEGISLATURE A TO FINANCE
CAP AND TRADE DOABLE AND WOULD
REQUIRE A VOTE OF THE PEOPLE
I THINK WE NEED TO DISCUSS
WITH COUNSEL IN MORE DETAIL
-- TO GET A SPECIFIC ANSWER ON
WHICH ITEMS WOULD REQUIRE GOOD
PEOPLE BUT IT'S CONCEIVABLE
THAT SOME OF THEM MIGHT A
GENERALLY SPEAKING THE ACTIONS
THAT YOU FORTY IS REQUESTING
THAT SEEM TO BE WILL BE
NECESSARY TO NAY CAP AND TRADE
REVENUES INVESTMENT GRADE
GOOD QUESTION WOULD BE --
DOES THEY'LL THEY'LL HAVE ANY
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR ADDITIONAL
OVERSIGHT MEASURES THAT
WOULD DIE OF BE TAKEN BY THE
LEGISLATURE OR THE MINISTRATION
I'LL JUST USE SP ONE AS AN
EXAMPLE CALTRANS NOW HAS AN
INSPECTOR GENERAL THAT IS PART
OF THAT PROCESS WATCHING FOR
THAT AGENCY -- WITH A SIX YEAR
TERM DID YOU GUYS CONSIDER OF
OTHER OVERSIGHT MEASURES THAT
THE LEGISLATURE COULD BE --
PART OF WE CAN CONSIDER THAT
QUESTION BUT WE COULD WORK
WITH YOUR STAFF TO CONSIDER
AT ANSWERING THAT PERHAPS
IN IN MORE DETAIL -- IT'S
WORTH NOTING OF COURSE THAT
-- JOINT AUDIT COMMITTEE IS
ALSO WANTS NOT OF OF THE HAS
YOUR AUTHORITY IN THE PROJECT
AND THAT'S A POSITIVE STEP
MY UNDERSTANDING IS THAT --
THAT ARTICLE BEGUN IN THE
LATTER PART OF MAY I THINK
IT'S A SEVERAL MONTH PROCESS
BUT I NEED TO DOUBLE CHECK
THAT TO GIVE YOU CORRECT
-- LOU THANK HIM AGAIN --
MISTRUST THANK YOU SO MUCH I
WISH EVERY PROJECT HAD THIS
ABILITY FOR THE DEDICATION
YOUR COMMITTEE HAS GIVEN AND
THE PROFESSIONALISM THAT IS
ROUGHT AND THE AWARENESS.
TO LEGISLATURE HAS BEEN
ABSOLUTELY.
PHENOMENAL SUPPORT YOU'VE GIVEN
US AND I CAN'T THANK YOU ENOUGH
WORKING MY STAFF AND SO SOME OF
THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS GOING
FORWARD.
OF.
THE DRAFT PLAN CONTAINS
RECOMMENDATIONS OF NEEDED
ACTIONS FOR LEGISLATION TO TAKE.
TO ENABLE THE AUTHORITY TO FIND
HIS CAP AND TRADE FUNDS.
WITH THESE ACTIONS BE SUFFICIENT
TO BUILD THE SYSTEM. IN IS THIS
THE BEST OPTION FOR FUNDING THE
IOS.
WELL FIRST OF SHIP THANK YOU FOR
SAYING NICE THINGS HAD BEEN NOT
SO MUCH FOR THAT QUESTION TO ME.
COULD STILL PUT YOU ON THE SPOT
THEM.
I AND. I THINK.
THE ANSWER IS NO IT WON'T BE
SUFFICIENT TO FINISH THIS
THERE IS MORE THAT WILL HAVE TO
BE DONE ESPECIALLY IF YOU REALLY
WANT TO REDEDICATE TO DOING FACE
ONE AND FINISHING.
THAT ONLY IF YOU WERE TO SAY.
ALL OF THE CAP AND TRADE MONEY
GOES TO HIGH SPEED RAIL AND.
ONLY IF THE HIGHER END
ESTIMATES WERE TO COME ABOUT.
WHERE THAT WOULD THAT BE ENOUGH
TO SUFFICE?
OTHERWISE IT'S OTHER SOURCES ARE
GOING TO HAVE TO BE FOUND NOT
WRITTEN NOT NECESSARILY AFTER
IT'S AN OPERATION BUT TO GET IT
TO THE POINT WHERE IT CAN
OPERATE.
WELL BASED ON THE DOES THE CURVE
YOU GROUP BELIEVE THE FINANCING
PLAN THAT WAS IS VIABLE.
MARTIN DARLING I THINK MORE WILL
NEED TO BE DONE OVER A PERIOD OF
TIME TO GET US THERE. ESPECIALLY
IF AS WE SAID YOU HAVE TO PLAN
FOR THE HIGH END OF THE
ESTIMATES TO COME TRUE RATHER
THAN THE THE MIDDLE OR THE OR
THE MORE FAVORABLE NUMBERS.
IT WILL BE THERE WILL BE MORE
THAT WILL NEED TO BE DONE AND
AND AND I I THINK. AGAIN IF
YOU'RE GOING TO GO FORWARD WITH
PHASE ONE TYPE AMBITION.
WE REALLY NEED THE PLAN FOR THE
UPPER END OF THE RANGE NOT NOT
THE MID PART OF THAT I'D LOVE TO
HAVE IT TURN OUT BETTER BUT BUT
I WOULD.
ABSENT SAID I'M AN OPTIMIST AND
MY HOPES BUT I'M A REALIST IN MY
PLANTS AND IN THIS CASE I THINK
REALISM WOULD SAY.
PLAN FOR.
COMPLETING IT IN UNDER ADVERSE
OUTCOME.
KRISTIN.
SO DO YOU THINK THAT THE EARLY
SERVICE ON THE CENTRAL VALLEY
LINE OR THE SAN FRANCISCO TO
GILROY LINE MIGHT VIOLATE
PROPOSITION ONE A.
THERE IS NO SUBSIDY MANDATE.
WELL I THINK THAT THAT THAT'S A
GOOD QUESTION IT ISN'T CLEAR TO
ME WHAT THE EARLY SERVICE OF
HIGH SPEED RAIL FROM SAN JOSE TO
SAN FRANCISCO OR GILROY MIGHT
ENTAIL I DON'T EVEN KNOW THAT
THEY REALLY WOULD DO THAT.
AND I CERTAINLY THINK THE
CONTRIBUTION OF THIS MONEY TO A
CALTRANS PERFORMANCE WILL BE
POSITIVE AND WE DON'T NEED TO
WORRY ABOUT THAT.
WHAT WOULD THIS HURT THE SERVICE
WOULD LOOK LIKE BETWEEN A AND
THE CENTRAL VALLEY AGAIN OTHER
THAN TESTING I DON'T KNOW THAT
HIGH SPEED RAIL?
I DON'T KNOW EXACTLY WHAT THEY
WOULD DO.
.
I THINK THE INITIAL SERVICE
WOULD BE TO ALLOW. AMTRAK TO USE
HIGH SPEED RAIL TRACKS.
HOWARD ST SAN JOAQUIN SWITCH
RUBY A GOOD THING AND THAT WITH
CONTRIBUTED PERFORMANCE THIS AND
WORKING.
WHETHER YOU WOULD HAVE HIGH
SPEED RAIL TRAINS IN EFFECT
COMPETING WITH THE SAN
JOAQUIN'S.
AT THE OUTSET I REALLY DON'T
KNOW AND I DON'T THINK THAT'S
BEEN WELL ENOUGH. DEFINED.
SO.
LA THOUGH IN AND MISTER THOMPSON
WOULD YOU EVER HAVE YOU EVER
THOUGHT ABOUT IF THERE WAS.
THE POSSIBILITY OF A REVENUE
GENERATING COMPONENT OF HIGH
SPEED FREIGHT.
THAT WOULD ACTUALLY BE ABLE TO
TO.
ALL WHO MET.
THE SYSTEM IN SOME KIND OF
FUTURISTIC KIND OF CONCEPT.
WERE OF SOME OF THE FOREIGN.
COMPANIES THAT PERFORM.
I SPEED RAIL
I HAVE THAT THAT DYNAMIC.
AN YOU WHEN YOU LOOK ABOUT THE
ADVANTAGE OF GLASS TRUCK MILES
TRAVELED.
BICU MOBILITY THROUGHPUT
BASED ON THIS.
WOULD IT BE.
ANOTHER OPTION IN YOUR VIEW
POINT AS A VIABLE.
SOURCE OF INCOME THAT MIGHT BE
INTEGRATED NO.
AND I REALLY DON'T THINK SO I
THINK THE EXPERIENCE WITH HIGH
SPEED.
PASSENGER TRAINS OR A VERY
SPECIAL BEAST.
AND THEY HAVE A DIFFERENT MARKET
AND A DIFFERENT SET OF CUSTOMERS
IN A DIFFERENT SET OF TECHNICAL
REQUIREMENTS.
EVERY TIME PASSENGER RAILROADS
HAVE TRIED TO OPERATE FREIGHT
SERVICES THEY'VE HAD TROUBLE.
NOW HIGH PRIORITY PACKAGE
SERVICE FEDERAL EXPRESS KIND OF
STUFF YES BUT THAT THAT'S A
POSSIBILITY.
BUT ANY ANYTHING BEYOND THAT I
WOULD BE SUSPICIOUS OF THE.
MOUSSA BUT I APPRECIATE THE
GANDER.
SO LAST QUESTION FOR ME OF.
WISCONSIN.
CAN YOU WALK US THROUGH WHAT
WOULD HAPPEN IF THIS PROJECT
STOPPED.
WELL THAT WOULD DEPEND ON HOW
WHAT STOPPED IF YOU STOPPED IT
JUST STOPPED NOW YOU WE HAVE
NOTHING OF VALUE LEFT IN THE
VALLEY NOTHING REALLY TO USE.
AND YOU'D HAVE TO PAY BACK
FEDERAL MONEY BATS.
APPARENTLY WHAT WOULD HAPPEN.
IF INSTEAD YOU SAID COMPLETE
WHERE YOU'RE DOING AND THE
CENTRAL VALLEY AND COMPLETE WHAT
YOU'RE DOING ALL CALTRAIN
ELECTRIFICATION PLUS THE WORK ON
THE SOUTH END.
IT YOU WOULD NOT END UP WITH
HIGH SPEED SERVICE IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY REALLY OF OF MANY
GREAT VALUE.
ALL YOU WOULD HAVE MUCH ENHANCE
CALTRAIN SERVICE.
AND YOU WOULD HAVE AND DANCE
SERVICE ON AND.
ON THE GRADE CROSSING IN THE
SOUTH.
IN IN THAT YOU WOULDN'T HAVE TO
PAY BACK THE FEDERAL MONEY
BECAUSE YOU WOULD AT LEAST
COMPLETE COMPLETE SOMETHING
OPERATIVE IN THIS
WE'RE BATTLING AND THEN. THAT
WOULD BE IT AS I UNDERSTAND.
AND NOT ONLY THAT VALUE LOST BUT
ALSO ALL OF THE JOBS THAT HAVE
BEEN COMMITTED.
PEOPLE HAVE COMMITTED RESOURCES
IT WOULD BE.
IN THAT REGION. JUST AN
ABSOLUTE.
ECONOMIC DEVASTATION THAT
WOULDN'T. HIM.
AND THE IMPACT ON. THE ECONOMY.
WOULD BE.
THAT PART THAT'S DEPENDENT ON
FINISHING THIS CONSTRUCTION
OPERATIONS WOULD BE WOULD BE
HARMED YES.
THE OTHER QUESTIONS OF THE
COMMITTEE.
MET SOME EVER BAKER.
I THINK YOU AND I.
ON THAT FEDERAL MONEY.
IF IT JUST STOPPED.
IT DIDN'T MAKE MAYBE PUT THE
OTHER RESOURCES INTO OTHER
CONSTRUCTION IN MOBILITY
PROJECTS IS.
OR I SUPPOSE ONCE NOT SPENT IT
ALL BUT THAT FEDERAL MONEY IT IS
THERE ANYTHING THAT WOULD
PROHIBIT THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
FROM FOR GIVING THAT.
LEGALLY THAT YOU KNOW.
I DON'T KNOW. THE ANSWER IS I
DON'T AND IF WE DON'T COMPLETE
CERTAIN EVERY EVERY CERTAIN
MILESTONES BY. EARLY THE NEXT
DECADE TWENTY TWENTY TWO DON'T
HAVE TO IS THERE A TRIGGER THAT
WE HAVE TO GET BACK FEDERAL
MONEY ANYWAY HER AM I. NOT RIGHT
ABOUT THAT. I THE ONLY
TRIGGERING NEW OF WAS THAT THE
MONEY HAD TO BE SPENT BEFORE
SEPTEMBER THE THIRTIETH TWENTY
SEVENTEEN.
OTHERWISE IT DIED.
BUT I DON'T KNOW. EXPATRIATE IN
THAT BED DATES CONTINGENT ON
COMPLETING A USEFUL SECOND THAT
BY TWENTY FOUR LITTLE SHIPMENT
NO.
I DON'T KNOW WHEN WHETHER
THERE'S A DEADLINE AFTER
COMPLETING MY I HAVE BEEN IN MY
HEAD THAT'S WHY TO ME TOO. I
THOUGHT IT WAS THAT THEY HAD
SIGNIFICANT HAVE TO COMPLETE ALL
DELIVER HAS REAL PEOPLE.
LIKE.
AND I THINK YOU.
WELL THE COMPLETES HIS FELLOW
PANELISTS THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR. ATTENTION TO DETAIL AND.
WILL CALL OUR NEXT PANEL OF.
SO WILL CORPORATE SUN IT RADHA
AND JUNE.
ARE NOT. PLEASE.
PLACE OF TOTAL.
PUT HIM.
SO SO LET'S GO AHEAD AND START
FIRST. STATE YOUR NAME AND WHO
YOU REPRESENT PLEASE.
AND.
PLEASE PROCEED.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN GOOD
AFTERNOON COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR HAVING
ME HERE.
MY NAME'S HAS SONIC DRIVE.
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF SOFT IN
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
GOVERNMENTS SKY.
WHICH IS A PRESENT.
EXACTLY FOURTEEN NINE POINT SIX
PERCENT OF THE STATE POPULATION.
AND I DO APPRECIATE THAT
DISCUSSION TODAY I APPRECIATE.
.
THE CEO OF HIGH SPEED RAIL
MISTER KELLY.
COMING IN AND BEING
STRAIGHTFORWARD ABOUT.
HOW MUCH IT'S GONNA COSTS WHAT'S
GONNA TAKE?
JUST TO REMIND YOU ON NINETEEN
AND TWENTY OF COMMITTEE BEFORE.
THAT IN TWO THOUSAND TWELVE WE
SIGNED A MEMORANDUM OF
UNDERSTANDING WITH HIGH SPEED
DATA STORAGE.
TO INVEST THAT BILLION DOLLAR.
AN IMPROVING.
THE THIRD RAIL CROSSINGS.
AND.
OLD THE PROJECT THAT WOULD MAKE
HIGH SPEED THEY'LL COME SMALLER
REGION.
AND THAT BILLION DOLLARS IN
TWENTY TWELVE WAS NOT EXPECTED.
THE TO BE WAITING UNTIL TWENTY
EIGHTEEN.
I'M HAPPY TO REPORT OF THAT
SEVENTY SIX.
MILLION OUT OF THE BILLION HAS
BEEN ALLOCATED PLUS CON.
NO CROSSING.
I AM VERY PLEASED AND GRATEFUL
TO THE HIGH SPEED THEIR US WHAT
IF YOU FOR PUTTING IN THEIR
DRAFT BUSINESS PLAN. FOUR
HUNDRED TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS
TO COME TO UNION STATION WHICH
WILL BE. A WELCOME OF TODAY.
.
IN NEWS FOR US.
SO THAT BRINGS THE FIVE HUNDRED
BILLION FROM ONE EIGHT. DOLLARS.
THERE IS ANY MEANING COVER
BILLION DOLLARS THAT WE WOULD
LIKE TO WORK WITH HIGH SPEED
RAIL AUTHORITY.
TO IDENTIFY FROM OTHER SOURCES.
TO INVEST IN THE CATO.
I'M NOT HERE TO JUDGE.
THE PROJECT I THINK YOU HERE'S
ENOUGH ABOVE THE PROJECT ALL I
CAN TELL YOU IS.
NOT ONLY THAT THE INVESTMENT IN
THE BOOK ENDS.
THEY JUST SIGNED THE MORE YOU
IT IS VERY CRITICAL FOR THE
EXISTING. RAIL SERVICES IN THE
FUTURE.
WHEN I SPEED DETAIL.
COMPLEMENT TO OUR REGION.
SO I I COMMIT TO YOU TODAY THAT
WE GET TO WORK WITH WITH YOU AND
WITH HIGH SPEED RAIL AUTHORITY
TO IDENTIFY THAT AS TO THE
MONEY.
AND DID HE IF THE HIGH SPEED
HEALTH ON TELEVISION.
REMINDING YOU THAT WHEN WE
STARTED THIS DISCUSSION.
LE FARE SEGMENT WAS SUPPOSED TO
BE AND SOMETHING CALIFORNIA ONE
OF THE MAJOR POPULATION CENTERS.
THAT MOVES NOTICED AND AND WE
UNDERSTOOD THAT HE'S ON WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH HIGH SPEED
RAIL ON.
WE'LL CONTINUE TO WORK WITH YOUR
PERMIT CAN PROVIDE INFORMATION
BUT MAKE NO MISTAKE ABOUT IT.
THE FORTY NINE POINT EIGHT
PERCENT.
THAT SETS A PRESENT OR SOMETHING
CALIFORNIA EXPECT.
AND INVESTMENT IN THE EXISTING
SYSTEM IN ANTICIPATION OF HIGH
SPEED BILL.
BUT BEING THERE AND WITH THAT
MISTER CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE MEMBER
I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE.
PAGE WAS TURNING.
.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
IT'S A A PLEASURE TO BE HERE AND
I THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY.
MY NAME IS JIM HART THAT I'M THE
EXECUTIVE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALTRAIN COMMUTER RAIL SYSTEM.
CALTRAIN APPLAUDS THE CALIFORNIA
HIGH SPEED RAIL AUTHORITY ON THE
RELEASE OF THEIR CRAFT TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN BUSINESS PLAN.
THANKS IN PART TO COMMITTED
PARTNERSHIP AND SIGNIFICANT
INVESTMENT FROM THE AUTHORITY
CALTRAIN HAS BEEN ABLE TO
PROCEED WITH EFFORTS TO
ELECTRIFY THE CALTRAIN QUARTER
BETWEEN SAN FRANCISCO AND SAN
JOSE. AND HAS SECURITY
INVESTMENT NEEDED TO REPLACE
SEVENTY FIVE PERCENT OF THE
SYSTEMS DIESEL FLEET. WITH HIGH
PERFORMANCE ELECTRIC TRAINS.
A PLEASED TO REPORT THE WE ARE
PROJECT GROUNDBREAKING IN JULY
TWENTY SEVENTEEN.
DESTRUCTION HAS BEEN ONGOING FOR
MONTHS AND THE FIRST POLLS HAVE
BEEN SCRAWLED ALONG THE QUARTER.
WE'RE ALSO PLEASED WITH THE
PROGRESS OF THE HIGH PERFORMANCE
ELECTRIC TRAINS OF WILL BE
MANUFACTURED IN SALT LAKE CITY.
AND SERVING WRITERS ARE QUARTER
BY TWENTY TWENTY TWO.
THE DRAFT TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
BUSINESS PLAN PROPOSES NEW
STRATEGIES THAT WOULD EXPAND
ELECTRIFICATION OF THE CALTRAIN
QUARTER SOUTH OF SAN JOSE TO
GILROY.
ENSURING THAT ALL COMMUNITIES
CURRENTLY SERVED BY CALTRAIN
WILL BENEFIT FROM THE ADVANTAGES
OFFERED BY ELECTRIC TRAINS.
INCLUDING INCREASE SERVICE
FREQUENCY REDUCE TRAVEL TIMES.
ENHANCED RELIABILITY AND
IMPROVED AIR QUALITY.
THIS NEW APPROACH WHICH IS PART
OF THE PHASED IMPLEMENTATION OF
THE SILICON VALLEY TO CENTRAL
VALLEY LINE.
IS A CONTINUATION AND
ENHANCEMENT OF THE AUTHORITY OF
LONG STANDING COMMITMENT TO
EVENTUALLY CONNECT THE STATE
WITH HIGH SPEED RAIL SERVICE. IN
A WAY THAT ALSO OFFERS IMMEDIATE
IMPROVEMENTS TO EXISTING
REGIONAL RAIL SERVICES.
ACCORDING CALTRAIN.
THE APPROACH ALSO FOCUSES ON THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF EARLY IN A
ROOM HIGH SPEED RAIL SERVICE
BETWEEN SAN FRANCISCO AND
GILROY.
AS EARLY AS TWENTY TWENTY SEVEN.
THE ADDITION OF HIGH SPEED RAIL
SERVICE TO THE CALTRAIN QUARTER
HAS GREAT POTENTIAL FOR
MAXIMIZING THE BENEFITS OF COURT
OR ELECTRIFICATION.
AND PROVIDING COMMUNITIES ALONG
THE QUARTER WITH NEW MOBILITY
OPTIONS THAT WILL BE A VALUABLE
PART OF OUR EFFORTS AS A REGION
TO ADDRESS GROWING TRAFFIC
CONGESTION. AND MAINTAIN OUR
ECONOMIC COMPETITIVENESS.
CALTRAIN IS CURRENTLY LEADING
EFFORTS TO DEVELOP THE CALTRAIN
BUSINESS PLAN WHICH INCLUDES AN
IN DEPTH TECHNICAL ANALYSIS OF
THE ISSUES INCLUDES
CONSIDERATIONS RELATED TO THE
EXPANSION OF SERVICES. WITHIN
THE CORRIDOR INCLUDING THE
ADDITION OF HIGH SPEED RAIL.
CALTRAIN LOOKS FORWARD TO
CONTINUED INVOLVEMENT FROM THE
AUTHORITY ON OUR LOCAL AND
REGIONAL STAKEHOLDERS TO
COMPLETE THE BUSINESS PLANET TO
BETTER DEFINE STRATEGIES.
FOR ENHANCE CONNECTION BETWEEN
COMMUNITIES ON THE COURT OR IN
FOR THE EVENTUAL CONNECTION OVER
REGION TO THE REST OF THE STATE.
CALTRAIN ALSO LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE AUTHORITY IN
OUR PARTNERS IN SAN FRANCISCO TO
ENSURE THAT CALTRAIN AND HIGH
SPEED RAIL SERVICES ARE EXTENDED
TO DOWNTOWN SAN FRANCISCO'S
TRANSBAY TRANSIT CENTER.
AS SOON AS POSSIBLE
THE EXTENSION OF HIGH QUALITY
RAIL SERVICE THE TRANSBAY
TRANSIT CENTER HOLDS DRAMATIC
POTENTIAL FOR THE EXPANSION OF
CALTRAIN SERVICE. TO NEW MARKETS
WILL HELP FACILITATE CONGESTION
RELIEF AND ENHANCE MOBILITY
THROUGHOUT THE ENTIRE QUARTER.
SIMILARLY WE ARE EXCITED TO BE
WORKING IN A PARTNERSHIP WITH
THE AUTHORITY THE CITY OF SAN
JOSE AND THE SANTA CLARA VALLEY
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY. TO
ENVISION A NEW DIRT ON STATION
AYE IN SAN JOSE A PROJECT THAT
WILL CREATE THE NEW REGIONAL
STATE WHY CONNECTIVITY. AND
TRANSFORM THE SOUTHERN TERMINAL
OF OUR RAILROAD.
AGAIN I APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE HERE TODAY AND
BE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS.
Q. ANY QUESTIONS OF THE
COMMITTEE OF OUR PALS.
WE GET TO GOOD.
SO I HAVE A COUPLE.
HASSAN WHAT ARE SOME OF THE
OTHER THE OTHER PRIOR PRIORITY
PROJECTS IN THE SACK SKEG REGION
QUICKLY FUND BY THE REMAINING
FIVE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
PROMISED IN THE MOU.
YOU MIGHT CONSIDER.
OKAY. MISTER CHAIRMAN THERE WERE
SEVERAL PROJECTS WE ACTUALLY
SUBMITTED A LIST.
FOR OVER FIFTY IF YOU PROJECTS.
FROM A GRADE THE CROSSINGS TO
EXPANDING THE THE RAILS IN SOME
PLACES. SAFETY PROJECTS.
.
THAT AND WE WILL BE MORE THAN
HAPPY TO WORK WITH THAT SHORTAGE
HERE ABOUT THE DETAILS OF US
CRIED. GRANTED SOME OF THESE
PROJECTS.
I'M NOT REALLY FOR
CONSTRUCTIONS.
BUT NOW THE FACT THAT WE'RE
USING THE FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
OF OTHER THAN PROP A. WE COULD
WORK WITH US ON THE TEAM MUCH
BETTER MUCH FASTER TO GET THIS
PROJECT. WOULDN'T OUT OF IT GOT
TO GROW.
SO IS IT YOUR UNDERSTANDING THAT
THE COMMEMORATIONS THAT YOU WILL
RECEIVE THE REMAINING FIVE
HUNDRED. MIL THAT AWFUL. OKAY.
AND THEN.
MR HARTNETT.
HAS THE AUTHORITY TO IDENTIFY
THE IMPROVEMENTS NEED TO BRING
HIGH SPEED RAIL SERVICE.
TO FOR THINKING SAN FRANCISCO
ONE ROLE CALTRAIN PLAY IN THE
DEPLOYMENT PLANS.
AND AGAIN ON TO THE TRANSMITTER
YES I ACTUALLY.
THERE'S A OF WE HAVE.
LAID OUT A PROCESS FOR WORKING
WITH THE AUTHORITY CITY OF SAN
FRANCISCO THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
ON OF PLANNING THE SERVICE.
FROM.
OUR EXISTING FOR THINKING
STATION TO
THE TRANSBAY TERMINAL.
WITH.
LOOKING AT THE ENVIRONMENTAL
ALTERNATIVES
AND THEY'RE TRYING TO COME
TOGETHER ON A PLAN TO.
BOTH CHOOSE THE RIGHT
ALTERNATIVE AND HAVE THE
APPROPRIATE STATION CAPACITY.
TO.
SUIT BOTH HIGH SPEED RAIL ON
CALTRAIN NOT JUST FOR NOWBUT
FOR THE FUTURE SO WE HAVE WE ARE
WORKING VERY WELL TOGETHER AND
THAT.
CAN YOU.
DETERMINE WHAT CAPACITY IT HER
ADDITIONAL CAPACITY THIS WILL
FORWARD.
CALTRAIN ON RIDERSHIP.
THIS BEING THE EXCEPTION TO
DOWNTOWN.
.
IT IT YEAH I.
YOU DID IT SUBSTANTIAL INCREASES
THE MARKET FOR US BECAUSE OF THE
NUMBER OF WRITERS WHO WOULD LIKE
TO GO TO DOWN. TOWN EXTENSION AS
AS COMPARED TO STOP UNIT FOR
THINKING.
THERE IS A THERE'S A RANGE OF
FIGURES. BUT.
AYE RIGHT NOW WE SERVE ABOUT
NINETEEN MILLION WRITERS YEAR.
AND.
I WOULD EXPECT.
BY A THAT AS A SIGNIFICANT
INCREASE OF THAT MERELY BECAUSE
OF THE EXTENSION BUT WE HAVE
PLANS TO ENHANCE THE CAPACITY
FOR OTHER REASONS AS WELL SO WE
WE EXPECT VERY.
OF ROBUST.
SYSTEM WORKING TOGETHER WITH
HIGH SPEED ROLLER BLADED
SERVICE.
APPRECIATED. SEGWAYS INTO.
CAN YOU ELABORATE ON THE CURRENT
CALTRAIN SERVICE TO GILROY. HOW
WOULD THE PROPOSED EXTENSION OF
ELECTRIFICATION GILROY AFFECT
CALTRAIN?
I THE PROPOSED AND THAT THE
PROPOSED.
.
ELECTRIFICATION I THINK WOULD
PROVIDE TREMENDOUS OPPORTUNITIES
FOR CAPACITY INCREASE RIGHT NOW.
THE THE RAIL SERVICE.
USES SOLELY THE UP RIGHT AWAY.
UNDER ATTRACTED YOU AGREEMENT
THAT THEY ARE INVOLVED SANTA
CLARA COUNTY THAT HAS.
BE CAPPED LIMITED NUMBER OF
TRAINS THAT CAN.
RUN UP AND DOWN THE THE TRACKS.
IT IS NOT SUFFICIENT TO MEET THE
DEMANDS OF THE OF THE FUTURE.
AND UNDER OUR CURRENT THAT
ELECTRIFICATION PROJECT THE
THERE IS NO FUNDING FOR
ELECTRIFYING THAT THAT THE
RAILWAY.
SO.
THE OPPORTUNITY TO WORK
TOGETHER WITH HIGH SPEED RAIL IN
THIS IS IS OF TREMENDOUS BENEFIT
TO TO THE ENTIRE COURT OR.
WELL I THINK IT HAS TO BE
CAPTURED ALSO THERE WAS. BOOK IN
MONEY FROM ONE EIGHT BUT THERE
WAS ALSO SIX HUNDRED AND FORTY
SEVEN MILLION DOLLAR.
COMMITMENT FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT FOR THIS PROJECT ALSO
YES THE.
ACTUALLY THAT THE TOTAL BUDGET
FOR ELECTRIFICATION PROJECT
INCLUDING OF BOTH OR ALL THE THE
CIVIL SIDE OF IT IN THE PURCHASE
AT THE ELECTRIC CARS IS JUST
SHORT OF TWO BILLION DOLLARS.
SO THE.
THE FUNDING FROM THE AUTHORITY.
INCLUDES A SIX HUNDRED A
BILLION DOLLARS IN BONDS AND
ANOTHER HUNDRED THIRTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS HAVE OTHER SOURCES.
AND WE HAVE.
WITH THE GREAT SUPPORT OF THE
STATE AND AND OTHERS OBTAINED AT
SIX HUNDRED FORTY SEVEN MILLION.
DOLLAR FEDERAL GRANT IN THE
BALANCE OF THE MONEY IS FROM OF
LOCAL CONTRIBUTIONS REGIONAL ONE
AND ANOTHER ABOUT COMMITMENTS.
SO IT'S.
DE DA HIKED THE AUTHORITY
INVESTMENT IS IS SIGNIFICANTLY
LEVERAGED.
IN IN THE SELECT CATION
PROPERTY WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
THE ECONOMIC. VALUE OF THIS
INVESTMENT WITH.
TACK COMING INTO THE REGION HOW
CONGESTED THE.
THE THE.
.
REGION IS RIGHT NOW FOR FOR ANY
KIND OF MOBILITY GET TO WORK.
AND.
AND ANY KIND OF FREE DYNAMIC IS
ACTUALLY STALLED IN THE WORLD
ONE AND SO DID THIS INVESTMENT
ACTUALLY BRINGS ANOTHER.
VALUE.
INTO THE AREA THROUGH THAT.
WOULD LIVE ONE OF KIRK IT IT'S
ABSOLUTELY.
CRITICAL TO THE QUALITY OF LIFE
IN THE IN THE REGION AS WELL AS
THE ECONOMIC VITALITY.
THE THAT ENHANCE THE CAPACITY
BETTER OPERATING CLEANER
OPERATING.
.
SYSTEM IS JUST KEY TO THE
REGION.
OF.
ABRAHAM LINCOLN WAS PROUD OF OUR
SYSTEM WHEN IT FIRST STARTED
OVER A HUNDRED AND FIFTY YEARS
AGO AND I THINK I PROBABLY
DIDN'T FORESEE BOB
ELECTRIFICATION OF IT BUT.
BUT HE PROBABLY THOUGHT IT WOULD
HAVE IMPROVED A LITTLE BIT MORE
A LITTLE QUICKER.
AND THAT WE REALLY NEED TO MAKE
THIS MAKE THIS CHANGE TO TO
BRING US UP TO THE.
IT YOU KNOW BUT THAT THE
QUALITY THAT REALLY.
.
IS NECESSARY TO MEET THE
CAPACITY NEEDS OF TODAY AND
TOMORROW.
WELL.
MR AT OUR.
.
AND FOR ONLY A TO KNOW THAT AND
INVESTMENT.
IN THE BOOK ENDS.
IS NOT POLITICALLY TAKE ALONG
AND FROM SHIFTED WILL BUT IF YOU
SAY IT'S AN ECONOMIC ISSUE IT
WILL BRING BENEFITS RIGHT AWAY.
SO WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH HIGH SPEED RAIL AUTHORITY.
JET JUST REMINDING YOU THAT WE
HAVE THE.
THE LOSS AND CANADA.
LOS ANGELES IN THE ABSENT FROM
SAN DIEGO TO SAN LUIS OBISPO.
THAT'S THE SECOND BUSIEST
GUIDED OR AFTER THE NORTHEAST.
AND THEN IN THIS MONTH THERE
WOULD DO A GREAT DEAL
IMMEDIATELY.
TO THE PEOPLE SUFFERING CAN BE
FOR THE TO HALF OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA SO. THEY ECONOMIC
BENEFIT THESE DOCUMENTS IT WILL
BE GREAT.
TO INVEST IN THE SYSTEMS AS WELL
AS MY COLLEAGUE TO JIM TALK
ABOUT THE INVESTMENT IN THE.
ONE I THINK WE HAVE TO ALSO LOOK
AT THE.
IMPENDING A.
I'M NOT AFRAID FISCAL BECOMING
INTO THAT REGION. WITH A NEW
SUPER FREIGHTERS AND WHAT NOT
NEARLY FROM THE EIGHT THOUSAND
TWO YOU DO YOU USE TO TWENTY
FOUR THOUSAND TO USE.
AND THE ABILITY TO GET THAT.
FREIGHT. PRODUCT MOVING.
HOW WITH THESE GREAT SUBSTANCE
SOME OF THE MOBILITY ISSUES THAT
YOU YOU RUN ACROSS?
IT'S IT'S A FOR PLANNING KIND OF
INVESTMENT TO TRY TO CONTINUE.
TO ENCOURAGE THAT THIRD OF OUR
ECONOMY TO FLOURISH
SO I GET EXECUTIVE I MISTER
CHAIRMAN ONE THING.
DETAILS. OF THE FAIRY TALE.
AND THE PASSENGER RAIL USE THE
SAME TAX RATE.
AND THE KIND OF PROJECT THAT WE.
WE PUT TOGETHER FOR THE BOOK
AND INVESTMENT INCLUDE THOSE
AGAIN CROSSINGS IN MANY AREAS
WERE ABOLISHED THE FREIGHT. AND
THE PASSENGER RAIL USES.
AND AND LAKE YOU MENTIONED
MISTER CHAIRMAN ONCE HERE THOUGH
THE STATE'S JOBS THAT ACCURATE
IN THAT IT COULD HAVE BEEN LOS.
MOVING FREIGHTS MOVING GOODS
AROUND.
THANK YOU SO VERY MUCH.
MISTER BERMAN I THINK YOUR
QUESTION. YET TO SCOOP WATCHING
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
A LOT OF TIME AND ATTENTION AND
RESOURCES HAVE BEEN
SPENT ON.
GRADE SEPARATIONS AND.
INK FOR ATTACK GRAY CROSSINGS
IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AND IN
GYM.
THAT YOU KNOW HOW IMPORTANT THAT
IS TO TO MY DISTRICT INTO THE
PENINSULA WHERE CALTRAIN
CURRENTLY RUNS YOU KNOW FIFTY
TWO HUNDRED FEET FROM SINGLE
FAMILY HOMES AND SCHOOLS THAT I
WANT TO.
AND BUSINESSES AND.
THERE ALSO.
YOU HAVE BEEN A LOT OF PERSONAL
SAFETY ISSUES AROUND THE
CALTRAIN CORRIDOR.
IN THE PENINSULA CAN YOU TELL
US A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE
CONVERSATIONS WITH HIGH SPEED
RAIL WHAT KIND OF.
GOT COMMITMENTS THEY'RE MAKING
TO ADDRESS.
SOME OF THE.
IMPACTS THAT HIGH IF ICE HERO
ORDER RUN.
UP TO SAN FRANCISCO WOULD HAVE
ON THEIR
COMMUNITIES BUT THERE ARE A
SPECIFIC COMMITMENTS AT THIS
TIME THE THEIR. HIGH SPEED RAIL
IS IS STILL GOING THROUGH THE
ENVIRONMENTAL PROCESS FOR THE.
ENVIRONMENTAL CLEARANCE AT SAN
FRANCISCO TO SAN JOSE. AND.
I'M SURE THE GRADE SEPARATIONS
ARE GOING TO BE.
MENTION AND LOOKED AT AS PART
OF THAT.
.
YOU TO BE REALLY HONEST WE
SUFFERED IN IN CALTRAIN FROM A
LACK OF. THE ABILITY TO
INVESTMENT GRADE SEPARATIONS
SYSTEM CALTRAIN IS NOT.
THEIR ORGANIZATION THAT
RECEIVES A DEDICATED SOURCE OF
TAX FUNDS WE ARE.
FUNDED OVER SEVENTY PERCENT FOR
OPERATIONS AND MAINTENANCE
SIMPLY BAR FOR A BOX OF REVENUE.
IN UNDER THE BALANCE COMES FROM
OUR OR THREE COUNTY PARTNERS.
AND WE HAVE NEVER HISTORICALLY
HAD A GREAT SEPARATION PROGRAM.
END SO WE RECOGNIZE IT IS IT'S
NOT JUST A HIGH SPEED RAIL ISSUE
IT'S A CALTRAIN ISSUE IT'S AN
ISSUE FOR THE COMMUNITIES.
SAM UNTIL COUNTY.
ITSELF FROM LOCAL FUND'S
LEVERAGING OF OTHER FUNDS HAS.
FUNDED A NUMBER OF GREAT
SEPARATIONS
WE HAVE ONE GOING ON NOW THAT'S
LIKE JOINTLY FUNDED WITH HIGH
SPEED RAIL IN THE SAN MATEO
AREA.
WOULD NOT HAVE HAPPENED WITHOUT
THE HIGH SPEED RAIL FUNDS.
AND SANTA CLARA COUNTY WHEN IT
PASSED ITS THAT MEASURE BE.
IN TWO THOUSAND SIXTEENA
SUBSTANTIAL AMOUNT OF MONEY.
AVAILABLE TOWARDS GRADE
SEPARATIONS.
SO I THINK WHAT WE NEED TO DO IS
JUST WE NEED TO STEP BACK AND
LOOK TOGETHER HOW BEST WE CAN
ADDRESS THE GREAT SEPARATION
ISSUE.
IT IS NOT ANYONE ENTITIES.
FULL RESPONSIBILITY TO TOTALLY
AGREE APPRECIATE THAT AND IN
LIEU WOULD MENTION THAT EARLIER
HOW IT'S GOING TO HAVE TO BE.
STATE.
REGIONAL LOCAL EFFORT I KNOW A
LOT OF CITY GOVERNMENTS THAT ON
THE PENINSULA ARE TALKING THAT.
PUTTING RESOURCES TOWARDS IT AS
WELL THE SCOPE OF IT IS SO BIG
THAT IT'S GOING TO TAKE
EVERYBODY.
YOU KNOW COMING TO THE TABLE
WITH SERIOUS RESOURCES.
AND AND I I HOPE AND TRUST THAT
A HIGH SPEED RAIL WILL MAKE THAT
COMMITMENT WHEN THE TIME COMES.
THANKS ASSEMBLY MEMBER JUST SO
THAT THEY'RE. JUST SEEN ON OUR
REGION.
WE HAVE.
FIVE COUNTIES OUT TO THE SIX.
AND SIX OUT OF THE SEVERAL
SOFTENED CALIFORNIA THAT HAVE A
DEDICATED SALES TAX OF
TRANSPORTATION.
SO I WANT PARTNERSHIP WITH HIGH
SPEED RAIL OF THIS MONEY BECOMES
AVAILABLE MEANS WE'RE GONNA
MATCH THIS MONEY.
AND HAVE A MULTIPLE BILLION
THERE ARE LITTLE INVESTMENTS
ENOUGH POLITICALLYEXHIBITION
POP I THINK CAPACITY TO THE TAX.
OF BEING GREEDY FOR HIGH SPEED
DELIVERY.
GOING THERE I THINK YOU FOR IT
YOU'VE IDENTIFIED. THAT.
.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE SELF HELP
COUNTIES IN IN IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WILLING TO.
BE PART OF THE PROCESS WE LOOK
AT SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA'S
COMMITMENT TO LEVERAGE THE
THESE FUNDS ON. ISSUES AS A
PARTNER GOES A LONG WAYS I MEAN.
WITH THERE WASN'T THIS
COMMITMENT BY YOUR ORGANIZATION.
AND THE SUFFOLK COUNTIES.
PROBABLY NOT GONNA GET OUT OF
OUT OF THE BOX JUST APPRECIATE
YOUR WILLINGNESS AND AND ALL OF
YOUR MEMBERS TO BE PART OF THIS.
A SOLUTION BECAUSE AGAIN IT WAS
HIGHLY CONSTRAINED PROJECT.
EVERY LITTLE BIT HELPS SO THAT
THE FOUR HUNDRED TWENTY MILLION
THOSE COMING TO UNION STATION
THAT'S THE HIGH SPEED RAIL. ONE
A FUNDS GONNA BE MATCHED BY MUCH
MORE LOCAL AND WE'RE WILLING TO
DO THE SAME. WITH THE REST OF
THE MONEY WENT.
I APPRECIATE THE COMMITMENT.
ASSEMBLY BIGGER GIVEN THE
QUESTIONS YOU. THINK YOU AYE.
SO WHEN I UNDERSTAND A BIT
BETTER.
FROM EIGHT EAST BAY AREA SO
JUST THROUGH THE BENEFITS TO THE
GREATER BAY AREA FROM THE WORK
THAT YOU'RE REFERRING PARA
CALTRAIN
CORD BUT.
WHICH OF THOSE.
ITEMS THAT YOU'VE LISTED FOR US
HEAD HEIGHT HAD IF THE FUNDING
COULD HAVE COME FROM SOMEWHERE
ELSE IF HIGH SPEED RAIL WEREN'T.
BUILT
BUT FUNDING CAME THROUGH
SOMEWHERE ELSE WOULD SAVE A
SIMILAR AMOUNT OF INVESTMENT
THAT YOU NEED JUST CAME AT THE
STATE LEVEL A STATE
TRANSPORTATION BY WHAT NAME YOUR
FUNDING SOURCE THAT MAY HAVE
COME FROM IT BUT.
THERE'S NOTHING IN HIGH SPEED
RAIL BEING BUILT ITSELF IT'S
MAKING THESE BEGIN PROJECTS
POSSIBLE IT'S JUST THAT IS A
SOURCE OF FUNDING NOW THAT.
THE LEGISLATURE MADE THAT THE
CASE EARTH THEIR PROJECT THAT.
IF WE DON'T BUILD HIGH SPEED
RAIL THE BOOKENDS WOULDN'T BE
POSSIBLE.
BUT FOR THE FUNDING.
WELL BOB I GUESS.
THE BEST WAY I COULD ANSWER THAT
IS TO SAY THAT.
.
IN THE CALTRAIN TO STRATEGIC
PLANS BEGINNING IN THE NINETEEN
NINETIES.
ELECTRIFICATION.
WAS A BIT PART OF THE STRATEGIC
VISION VISION OF CALTRAIN SO
THAT IT PREDATES.
HIGH SPEED RAIL.
AND SO THE OUT IN THE IN THE
FUNDING POWER OVER UP WITHOUT
THA THE FUNDING FROM HIGH SPEED
RAIL FROM THE AUTHORITY AND FROM
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AND AND
ALL OUR PARTNERS LOOKED AT.
TOGETHER WE COULD NOT HAVE.
.
UNDERTAKEN THE ELECTRIFICATION
PROJECT.
BUT SINCE THE PERCENT SAID SINCE
THE OUT.
ADVENT OF OF HIGH SPEED RAIL WE
WORK VERY CLOSELY TOGETHER AND
NOT JUST BETWEEN.
CALTRAIN AND HIGH SPEED RAIL
BUT WE'VE BEEN WORKING TOGETHER
WITH THE STATE.
AND IN TERMS OF HOW WE BEST FIT
IN.
FOR THE.
OVERALL STATE RAIL PLAN.
AND SO. ALL OF THIS POWER
PIECES%
OF THAT.
IN THE HIGH SPEED RAIL AS A
PIECE OF THAT AND CALTRAIN IS A
OF THAT.
TOGETHER UP WITH THE OTHER
PIECES.
REALLY COULD COMPRISE A WHOLE
STATE RAIL PLANTS AT THAT THOSE
ARE POLICY DECISIONS FOR. OTHERS
THAN ME BUT WE WE ARE PART OF A
LARGER POT PUZZLE THAT INCLUDES
HIGH SPEED RAIL. IN THE OTHER
WORLD SYSTEMS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE.
AND THE SAMPLING ASSEMBLY WOMAN
FOR SOMETHING CALIFORNIA THIS
PROJECT EXISTED.
.
WE THAT MEANS THEY WE WANT TO TO
IMPROVE IN THE STATION.
WE PRESCIENT THE PARTNERSHIP OF
HIGH SPEED YET BUT I I WOULD
SAY.
IF WE DIDN'T HAVE HIGH SPEED
THAT WE WOULD SO PROBABLY COME
TO THIS COMMITTEE AND SAY. HOW
BY THIS GOVERNMENT DID FUNDING
VOTER OR THAT I THE FUNDING
THE POINT IS THESE THESE
PROJECTS ARE NEEDED?
AND WHAT I WHAT PARTNERSHIP WAS
AYE SPEEDOS VERY MUCH
APPRECIATED TO MAKE THEM HAPPEN
WHICH.
THANK YOU.
SO WHAT I WANT TO THANK YOU BOTH
FOR BEING HERE AND. BEING PART
OF OUR PANEL SO.
IF YOU HAVE ANY LAST WORDS LIKE
SAY BEFORE YOU.
AT JUST AGAIN ONE I THINK HIGH
SPEED RAIL AND MYSTICAL
<U&gt;&LT;C.GREEN&GT;.&LT;/C&GT;
</U
&gt;
FOR BEING STRAIGHT FORWARD AND
AND THE BUSINESS COMES UP WE
LOOK FORWARD TO DOING THAT BIG
AND THE BOOK ENDS AND AND WE
WAITED.
CHEERS AND WE DON'T WANT TO WAIT
ANOTHER SIX ONE OF THE WOOD FROM
WHAT.
HOW WOULD YOU DO IT TOMORROW TO
ASK?
SO IT IS THANK YOU AGAIN FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY.
THANK YOU.
SO WERE GONNA GO AHEAD NOW AND
MOVE TO PUBLIC COMMENT.
WE NEED THAT MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WHO WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK
ON THE.
ON FOR OR AGAINST.
.
THE DRAFT BUSINESS PLAN PLEASE
WHAT I'LL ASK.
IS THAT YOU STATE YOUR NAME
REPRESENT.
AND SO WE'RE TRYING TO KEEP IT
AT A.
REASONABLE AMOUNT OF TIME PLEASE
AND.
SIR STAGE NAME UNCLEAR RIGHT
HERE MY NAME IS TED HEART. I'M
SPEAKING AS THE VOTER AND AS A
CALIFORNIA TAXPAYERS.
I HAVE BEEN INVOLVED WITH A HIGH
SPEED RAIL FOR TEN YEARS.
AND APPRECIATE.
WHAT THIS PANEL AND WHAT THIS
HEARING HAS DONE IT IS THE FIRST
TIME IN TEN YEARS?
THAT I'VE HEARD REALLY PERTINENT
QUESTIONS ASKED OF THE AUTHORITY
UP UNTIL NOW. THAT HAS NOT
EXISTED.
BECAUSE I'VE ATTENDED ALMOST
EVERYONE OF THE BOARD MEETINGS
AT SARAH BUT I'D LIKE TO CALL TO
YOUR ATTENTION IS WHAT HAS BEEN
MISSING TODAY FROM. ALL OF THIS.
AND THAT IS.
THE VOTER.
THE VOTER HAS BEEN LEFT OUT OF
THE US IN THE SENSE. THAT IN
PROP ONE A AND TWO THOUSAND
EIGHT THE VOTERS WERE TOLD.
THAT.
FOR TEN BILLION DOLLARS THEY
WERE GOING TO GET A FORTY FIVE
BILLION DOLLAR. HIGH SPEED RAIL.
WE'RE TEN YEARS DOWN THE LINE
YOU MENTIONED IT BEFORE. EXCEPT
THAT THE FUN THE ACTUAL NUMBER.
IF YOU TAKE THE NINETY EIGHT
BILLION. AND THEN EXTRAPOLATE
THAT MOVE IT FORWARD YOU'RE
LOOKING AT A HUNDRED AND FIFTY
BILLION.
SO THE FORTY FIVE BILLION HAS
GONE UP THREE HUNDRED PERCENT.
AND THE QUESTION THAT NEEDS TO
BE LOOKED AT AS IS. WHAT ABOUT
THE VOTERS IN SAN DIEGO?
RIVERSIDE AND SACRAMENTO IN THE
INLAND VALLEY AND ALL OF THESE
PLACES WHO ACTUALLY VOTED FOR
THIS.
AND THE DISCUSSION TODAY.
IT'S LIKE IT DOESN'T EXIST.
THESE VOTERS ARE BEING LEFT OUT
COMPLETELY.
THE LAST COMMENT I WOULD MAKE.
IS I JUST WANT TO THROW IT IN
THERE THE QUESTION WAS WHAT WHAT
HAPPENS IF WE STOP IT.
WELL AFTER SIXTY YEARS IN THE
COMMERCIAL CONSTRUCTION BUSINESS
WHEN YOU'VE GOT A BAD
INVESTMENT.
YOU STOP
YOU DON'T THROW.
GOOD MONEY AFTER BAD THANK YOU.
DID YOU NAME YOUR REPRESENTING
SIR
YES MY NAME IS ALICE GOT ON
WITH.
.
SINCE MY CALIFORNIA HIGH SPEED
RAIL ACCOUNTABILITY AND ALSO
SPEAKING AS A TAXPAYER AND OF
THE CITIZEN.
.
AS FAR AS THE PROJECT IS
CONCERNED I THANK YOU TODAY FOR
WHICH YOU DON.
ENLIGHTENING OF AND ABOUT A
HUNDRED FIFTY MEETINGS OVER THE
LAST EIGHT YEARS.
AND THIS IS THE ONE OF THE FIRST
ONES THAT REALLY HIT THE POINTS
THE MAIL ON THE HEAD.
WHAT I TOOK AWAY FROM THIS
MEETING AS LIKE A PAIR KNOW
SOMEONE'S HAND AMEND IF I COULD
FOR THE RECORD?
BUT I TOOK AWAY AS.
.
THERE'S NO PLAN.
WHAT I TOOK AWAY AS THERE'S NO
MONEY?
AND TO MISTER HART POINT.
.
ONE OF THE THINGS I WAS I
LEARNED WHEN I WENT IN THE
BUSINESS AFTER A TRIED FROM THE
NAVY VERY SIMPLY WAS THIS.
IF YOU'RE GOING TO WORK FOR MY
COMPANY YOU BETTER MAKE ME
MONEY.
AND YOUR NOT MAKE ANY MONEY
WE'RE GOING TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO
GET RID OF IT. AND TO ME THAT
DEEP AND HAS TO STOP.
SOME ONYX.
CUT TO THE CHASE.
.
AS THERE'S BEEN SAID ALREADY
MISSED GERMANS PROJECTS LIFELESS
CRITICAL LIFE THREATENING
CROSSROADS FURTHERMORE. YOUR
CONCERNS FOR THE RECORD I DIDN'T
WELL STATED AND TODAY I
APPRECIATE AGAIN WHAT YOU DON.
WITHOUT QUESTION THE TAXPAYERS
HAVE THAT THAT DIDN'T THE MOST
ALL HAVE THE MOST ONEROUS TAX
OBLIGATION UNITED STATES.
PROBABLY EVEN IN THE WORLD FOR
CALIFORNIA WE ARE TAXED TO. THE
NTH DEGREE.
ADDITIONAL I BELIEVE EVERYONE IN
THIS DIAZ BELIEVES AND KNOWS
THAT THIS PROJECT IS NO LONGER
VIABLE I DON'T THINK IT'S VIABLE
ANYMORE EVEN HARDLY HEARD OF
TODAY.
.
KEY POINT I WANT TO MAKE IS
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE AND
THE ENTIRE LEGISLATIVE AND
EXECUTIVE BRANCH.
OF THIS CAN OF THIS STATE ARE
STEWARDS OF OUR BANK.
PLEASE ACCEPT THE RESPONSIBILITY
OF ONE HUNDRED AND TEN PERCENT.
AND THAT IS WHAT THE TAXPAYERS
EXPECT OUT OF YOU THAT IS THE
BIGGEST ISSUE LIKE TO CLOSE WITH
THIS.
DOWN IN SOUTHERN.
DOWN IN CENTRAL CALIFORNIA.
.
IT'LL TOWN SOUTH OF HILL AYE
KINGS CAN'T.
SOUTHERN KINGS COUNTY.
THERE'S BEEN A PROBLEM WITH THE
PLAN TAKING IT SHOULD THE
SERIOUS COMPOUND THE HOUSE WAS
CLOSED UP.
SOME.
TWO AND A HALF YEARS AGO.
AND I DROVE BY THERE. ABOUT
THREE WEEKS AGO THE HOUSE IS NOW
OCCUPIED.
I CALLED.
SOMEBODY DOWN THERE THAT IF OF
KNOWLEDGE.
ESTAMOS GOING HE SAID WELL THEY
DON'T LONG THEY DON'T WANT TO BE
THE HOUSE.
PEOPLE LIVE IN THAT HOUSE THE
GENTLEMAN THAT BUILT THAT HOUSE.
HIS WIFE.
DESPITE.
HE BUILT THE HOUSE FOR HER WITH
HIS OWN HANDS.
THREE YEARS TO BUILD A HOUSE.
A COUPLE YEARS LATER THE HIGH
SPEED RAIL SAYS A COMMON THREAD.
I GOT PAST THEIR.
BUT THE LAST MONTH.
HOUSE IS WIDE OPEN.
BRENDA WINDOWS.
HOUSES BIT LIVING AND BEING
RENTED.
TUNISIA ONE.
BEING RENTED.
AND.
WHY?
MY QUESTION
THAT TO ME IS ONEROUS.
SURPLUS KRISTIN PRIMARY
REPRESENT I'M BILL TO CARRY
RESIDENT BAKERSFIELD MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
IN THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN AND
REPRESENTS PLAINTIFF FORTY
FINALLY ADMITTED IT IS NUMEROUS
MADE NUMEROUS COSTLIER IS THE
CENTRAL VALLEY.
HOWEVER LIKE PREVIOUS BUSINESS
PLANS THERE IS STILL A LOT OF
HYPE AND HOPE.
A HUGE IN MISSION IS THE FUNDING
GAP CONNECTING SILICON VALLEY IN
THE CENTRAL VALLEY SEGMENTS NEW
TEMPLATE TO FUNDING GAP. YOU
THIRTY AGAIN FEELS TOO FAILS OR
KNOWLEDGE OF THE PRIVATE SECTOR
WILL NOT INVEST IN THIS RISKY
PROJECT WITHOUT GUARANTEES.
NATIONALLY THERE STIFF
COMPETITION FOR LIMITED FEDERAL
MONEY FOR EXAMPLE AMTRAK IS
SEEKING NINE HUNDRED MILLION.
FOR SALTY'S CORRIDOR.
MODERNIZATION.
THE AUTHORITY HOPES TO MONETIZE
CAP AND TRADE REVENUE BY ISSUING
STATE OF CALIFORNIA REVENUE
BONDS. REQUIRING A CREDIT
ENHANCEMENT OR GUARANTEED BY THE
STATE BECOMES A BOND HOLDERS FOR
THE UNCERTAINTY OF CAP AND
TRADE.
OF RECEIPT
OBVIOUSLY SEGMENT SOUTH OF
BAKERSFIELD TO COMPLETE PHASE
ONE REMAIN UNFUNDED.
THE AUTHORITY CONTINUING ADMITS.
OUR TOUTS ITS TRANSPARENCY
YET AN EXHIBIT TWO POINT ONE IT
SHOWS TUNNELS BETWEEN YOUR IN
MADERA. BUT OMITS THE TUNNELS
BETWEEN BAKERSFIELD IN PALMDALE
AND THE TUNNELS BETWEEN PALMDALE
IN BURBANK.
TUNNELS VERY HUGE UNKNOWN COST.
IN THE PLAN RIDERSHIP ESTIMATES
ARE BASED ON TRAVEL BETWEEN
BAKERSFIELD AND SAN FRANCISCO.
IN REALITY TRAVEL WILL BE
BETWEEN CHAPTER OR POSSIBLY
BAKERSFIELD AND MADERA IN
BETWEEN GILROY IN FULL FORCE AND
KING STREETS IN SAN FRANCISCO.
LACK OF FUNDING WILL LIKELY MAKE
PEACE TWO SCENARIOS LONG
LASTING.
IN ORDER TO ESTIMATE THE AMOUNT
OF ANNUAL STATE SUBSIDY TO MAINE
TO. A SUSTAIN OPERATIONS
RIDERSHIP REVENUE FORECAST FOR
THESE TWO SEGMENTS IS ESSENTIAL.
IT IS CLAIMED CENTRAL VALLEY
STATEMENT COULD BE USED BY
AMTRAK.
BUT WITH CURRENT AMTRAK STATIONS
GONE FROM THE HIGH SPEED RAIL
ALIGNMENT.
IT WOULD BE A HARDSHIP FOR
CENTRAL VALLEY WRITERS.
LASTLY WHILE MORE REVEALING THAN
PRIOR PLAN I'M FLABBERGASTED ONE
ON PAGE NINETEEN OF THE TWENTY
EIGHTEEN PLAN. YOUR THORNY
INDICATE SERVICE DECISIONS WOMAN
SHORTFALL COMPLIANCE WITH
PROPOSITION ONE A.
THE CURRENT PROJECT IS FAR FROM
WHEN VOTERS NARROWLY APPROVED
TEN YEARS AGO. IN CONCLUSION I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THIS
COMMITTEE NOT SUPPORT THE
CONTINUATION OF THIS RISKY
PROJECT AND HALTED UNTIL
ENVIRONMENTAL WORK IS COMPLETED.
AND TUNNELING COSTS OF
DEVELOPING A RELIABLE FUNDING
SOURCES ARE IDENTIFIED THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU.
MA'AM WHICH SAY YOUR NAME WHO
REPRESENT PLEASE.
YES ON IT IS AND GENTLEMAN MY
NAME IS ME THERE RIGHT AND I'M
THE OWNER OF A REALLY COOL GROUP
INC. A SMALL WOMAN OWNED AND
DISADVANTAGED BUSINESS
ENTERPRISE FROM ROSEVILLE
CALIFORNIA.
MY COMPANY PROVIDES PROJECT
MANAGEMENT AND CIVIL ENGINEERING
SERVICES TO BOTH. PUBLIC AND
PRIVATE SECTOR CLIENTS.
WE HAVE BEEN INVOLVED WITH THE
HIGH SPEED RAIL PROJECTS SINCE
TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN.
BUT I HAVE BEEN A SUPPORTER OF
THIS PROJECT LONG BEFORE I HAD
AN OPPORTUNITY TO WORK ON IT.
BECAUSE AND I'M HERE TODAY
TIGHTLY TO EXPRESS MY SUPPORT
ONCE THEY GAIN FOR THIS PROJECT
WHICH I THINK IS VERY VERY
IMPORTANT FOR OUR STATE.
AND I'M DOING THAT BOTH OF THE
SMALL BUSINESS OWNER AND THEIR
RESIDENT FOR CALIFORNIA VOTE.
THE HIGH SPEED RAIL PROJECT IS
THE MOST IMPORTANT AYE I'M
VICIOUS UNDERTAKING IN OUR STATE
RIGHT NOW. AND IT REQUIRES THE
SUPPORT OF ALL OF OUR RESIDENTS
AS WELL AS ALL OF FOR
LEGISLATORS ALL LEVEL. TO BECOME
A SUCCESS.
THERE'S NO NEED TOREPEAT THEIR
OF THE BENEFITS OF THE HIGH
SPEED RAIL PROJECTS I'M SURE GO
HER DIED. ITSELF MODERNIZE THOSE
OR TRANSPORTATION SYSTEMS GOOD
FOR THE ENVIRONMENT IS CREATING
JOBS BUT I'M COMPELLED TO POINT
KNOW WHAT GOVERNOR BROWN SAID
THAT THIS PROJECT HAS CREATED
TAUZIN'S OF THOUSANDS OF. HIGH
PAYING JOBS FOR RESIDENTS OF
CALIFORNIA AS WELL AS THE RIVER
VETERANS WHICH I ALSO I'M VERY
MUCH ASSOCIATED WITH IT.
UP WE KNOW THAT MANY ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT THE COST OF THE
PROJECT DELAYS BUT I'VE BEEN IN
THIS BUSINESS A MONTHS I'M A
CIVIL ENGINEER. AND I HAVE BEEN
INVOLVED IN SEVERAL MEGA
PROJECTS I DON'T THINK THIS
PROJECT IS ANY DIFFERENT THAN
ANY OTHER MEGA PROJECTS. THAT
HAVE HAD TO OVERCOME A POSITIONS
FUNDING ISSUES. AND
SO.
YOU CONCLUSIONS.
I MUST BE OR LEGISLATORS WHO PUT
THEIR FULL SUPPORT BEHIND THIS
PROJECT BECAUSE I THINK WOULD
YOUR SUPPORT. THE PROJECT TEAM
WILL MAKE THIS PROJECT A SUCCESS
AND A REALITY FOR A STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THANK.
THANK YOU SIR PLEASE STATE YOUR
NAME AND WHO YOU REPRESENT.
GOOD AFTERNOON OR GOOD EVENING
MY NAME IS ROLAND LEBRON EARLY
BE ARE YOU AND I HAVE NO
AFFILIATION.
OUTROS FROM SAN JOSE THIS
MORNING TO GIVE YOU A FIFTH
OPTION.
WHICH IS HOW WE COULD CONNECT
SILICON VALLEY TO FRESNO.
WITHOUT HAVING TO AMEND THE
EXISTING TWENTY BILLION DOLLAR
FUNDING ENVELOPE NOT TWENTY
EIGHT.
THE BULLS ARE CLEAR.
THE MAJORITY OF VOTERS APPROVED
ALIGNMENT BETWEEN THE BANK AND
THE ANAHEIM IN THE SOUTH.
AND DEROY ES AND FRANCISCO INTO
NOT.
PROBLEMS ARE IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY.
PRIMARILY PRIMARILY BECAUSE THE
EXISTING ALIGNMENT.
IS IMPACTING EXISTING
INFRASTRUCTURE.
DUBBED APPROPRIATELY DESIGNED
HIGH SPEED LINE WILL
DELIBERATELY AVOID
THAT'S WAY TO COST NOT SWAYED
IMPACTS ARE COMING FROM.
SO BRIEFLY INCLUDE ENCLOSING.
WHAT IS THE SOLUTION?
FIRST WE NEED TO HIT THE POST
BUTTON AND THE CENTRAL VALLEY.
AND SECONDS WE NEED TO REVISIT
BUT NOTE SAY NOT PACHECO PASS.
IF YOU DO DAYS WE WE REDISCOVER
AND ALIGNMENT THAT NOT ONLY
SHE'S TEN MINUTES TRAVEL TIME.
BUT THEY'D ALSO ELIMINATES
APPROACH HIM ACTS APPROXIMATELY
TEN MILES OF TUNNELS.
AND IF YOU DO THIS.
BECAUSE OF THE EXISTING A
FREIGHT LINES ON BOTH SIDES OF
THE AISLE LYMAN.
IT WOULD BE POSSIBLE TO SHEA AND
A TON OF SWISS FREIGHT WITHOUT
IMPACTING THE HIGH SPEED RAIL
TRAFFIC
THANK YOU.
CHRIS TEACHER NAMED WHO
REPRESENT.
JIM LIKES ON BEHALF OF THE SAN
FRANCISCO BAY AREA RAPID TRANSIT
DISTRICT BART IS VERY ENCOURAGED
AND SUPPORTIVE OF THE NEW
UPDATED TWENTY EIGHTEEN BUSINESS
PLAN. WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH THE AUTHORITY OVER THE LONG
TERM TO IMPROVE CONNECTIVITY OF
THE HIGH SPEED RAIL SYSTEM OR
ESTABLISH CONNECTIVITY BETWEEN
HIGH SPEED RAIL.
IN NOT JUST PART BUT ALL OF THE
REGIONAL RAIL AND TRANSIT
AGENCIES AROUND THE STATE THANK
YOU.
FISHERMEN WHO REPRESENT PLEASE
AYE GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME'S
DAVE MERCER NAM WITH OPERATING
ENGINEERS LOCAL THREE AND FRESNO
ON THE DISTRICT REPRESENTATIVE.
AND.
I'M JUST HERE TODAY TO SHARE
WITH YOU A LITTLE BIT ABOUT WHAT
PROJECT MEANS TO OUR MEMBERS AND
IN FRESNO AND YOU'VE TOUCHED A
LITTLE BIT ON IT THIS AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIRMAN. AND.
THAT'S THE LABOR ISSUE.
.
THERE'S ONE MEMBERS GO AROUND
HOW MANY PEOPLE IT'S EMPLOYED.
OR WHAT IT MEANS TO FOLKS DOWN
CENTRAL VALLEY BUT THIS MORNING
BEFORE I LEFT FRESNO I PULLED
OFF NUMBERS FOR JUST US THIS IS
ONE CRAFT.
AND TODAY WE HAVE HAD SIXTY
CONTRACTORS.
PERFORMING WORK ON THE HIGH
SPEED RAIL.
THAT'S JUST LIKE THE.
LADY IN FRONT OF ME A FEW FEW
MOMENTS AGO SPOKE.
THESE ARE SMALL BUSINESS WOMEN
OWNED BUSINESSES DISADVANTAGED
BUSINESS A LOT OF THOSE TYPES OF
BUSINESSES.
TO DATE.
WE'VE HAD OVER FIVE HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY DISPATCHES EXACTLY FIVE
OR SEVENTY SIX DISPATCHES.
TWO LIES HERO THAT'S ONE CRAFT
OPERATING ENGINEERS REPRESENT
SURVEYORS NAY HEAVY EQUIPMENT.
OPERATORS THAT YOU SEE OUT
THERE OF THE CRANE OPERATORS.
SO THAT'S THE IMPACT THAT IT'S
HAVING ON.
FOLKS DOWN IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY.
.
WORKING ON THE HIGH SPEED RAIL
HAS OFFERED A ONLY THREE MEMBERS
A GOOD LIVING WAGE BENEFITS.
AND IT'S ALSO GIVEN US
OPPORTUNITY TO EMPLOYER TO TRAIN
APPRENTICES.
LEASE APPRENTICES A LOT OF THEM.
ARE COMING OUT OF THE SERVICE
THERE VETERANS.
WHERE WERE PUT IN THAT ARE
PRETTY SHIP PROGRAMMER TEACHING
THEM A TRADE A CRAFT THAT THEY
CAN CARRY ON LONG AFTER THE
HEIST HEROES COMPLETED?
AND THEN TO ONE OTHER POINT I'D
LIKE TO MAKE A.
WHICH BROUGHT UP WHEN WE'RE IN
I'M SIT HERE LISTEN TO YOUR YOUR
DIALOGUE WHICH I THINK IS VERY
IMPORTANT AND I APPRECIATE IT.
BUT IT'S THE LOCAL IMPACT THAT
IT'S HAVING ON THE ECONOMY IN
FRESNO.
I'M FIFTY YEARS OLD AS LONG AS
I CAN REMEMBER THEY DON'T TALK
ABOUT REVITALIZING DOWNTOWN
FRESNO.
AND IT'S NEVER HAPPENED THEY
TRIED LOTS OF DIFFERENT THINGS
AND AND NOTHING'S REALLY TAKEN
HOLD.
IF YOU GO DOWNTOWN FRESNO TODAY
IN THE LAST THREE FOUR YEARS IS
IS.
REVITALIZED
IT IT LOOKS MUCH DIFFERENT AND
IT FIVE YEARS AGO AND THAT'S A
DIRECT EFFECT
FROM MY SPEED RAIL AND THERE'S
NOTHING THAT THAT WE I MEAN WE
CAN ASSUME THAT'S GONNA HAPPEN
ALONG THE THE CORRIDORS AND
DIFFERENT COMMUNITIES SO ALONG
THE PATH OF HIGH SPEED RAIL.
AND I JUST WANTED TO BRING THAT
UP BECAUSE THAT IS A A LOT OF
THAT THAT DEVELOPMENT DONORS
PRIVATE MONEY RESTAURANTS THE
BUSINESSES THAT ARE MOVING TO
DOWNTOWN FRESNO AND IT'S.
IT'S JUST A GREAT THING TO SEE
SO I APPRECIATE YOUR GUYS IS
HARD WORKING YOUR DEDICATION
AND.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON.
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
MY NAME STEVE CASTER ON THE
RESULT DIRECTOR FOR THE PAINTERS
AND ALLIED TRADES HERE IN
SACRAMENTO. I MAY I NATIVE
CALIFORNIAN I'VE BEEN IN FAVOR
OF HIGH SPEED RAIL.
LONG BEFORE I BECAME A LABOR
REPRESENTATIVE.
WE CURRENTLY HAVE.
.
SOME MEMBERS WORKING ON THE
PROJECT AND ALSO SOME STATE
BASED.
EMPLOYERS AND FOR THESE REASONS
AND MANY OTHERS IRISH COMMITTEE
SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
STATE YOUR NAME HE REPRESENT
PLEASE.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M MY QUEST I
REPRESENT DISTRICT COUNCIL
SIXTEEN PAINTERS AND ALLIED
TRADES.
AND OF MY COLLEAGUES IN OTHER
LABOR REPRESENTATIVES.
FROM THE CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY
HAVE DONE A GREAT JOB OF
EXPLAINING THE BENEFITS TO OUR
MEMBERS. BUT I WANT TO.
TALK ABOUT RAIL SERVICE IN
CALIFORNIA AS A WHOLE AND SOME
OF OUR MEMBERS IN ORDER TO GET
TO WORK. ON THE JOB.
TIMELY EVERY MORNING HAVE TO
LEAVE THEIR HOMES AT ONE THIRTY
AND TWO O'CLOCK IN THE MORNING.
JUST TO AVOID HEAVY TRAFFIC AND
THEN THEY SLEEP ON THE JOB FOR
AN HOUR OR TWO IN THE MORNING SO
ANYTHING THAT WE CAN DO AS AN
OVERALL.
.
UPGRADE OF THE RAIL SERVICE IN
CALIFORNIA ON ALL ASPECTS LIKE
AGENDA MORE SAN ON THE PANEL IS
GONNA BENEFIT.
THE LIVES OF OUR MEMBERS AND
THEIR FAMILIES AND SPENDS MORE
QUALITY TIME RATHER THAN YOU
KNOW THEIR HEAD OF HOUSEHOLD
HAVING TO GO TO BED GINO SIX
THIRTY OR SEVEN O'CLOCK IN THE
EVENING THE SET QUALITY FAMILY
TIME.
IN ORDER TO. GET TO WORK IN THE
MORNING SO THANK YOU SO MUCH AND
I HOPE THAT'S PROJECT MOVES
FORWARD.
WHICH NAME HE RIPS SIMPLEST GOOD
EVENING TOM LEHMAN SAN DIEGO
BUILDING TRADES ALSO TAXPAYER.
I'M JUST HERE TO SAY SOMETHING
REAL SIMPLE ABOUT HOW
TRANSFORMATIVE A PROJECT OF THIS
SIZE IS AND AND LET YOU KNOW I'M
SUPPORT OF IT. I'M THAT GUY THAT
GOT OF THE MARINE CORPS IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY TWO AND WENT TO.
A PROJECT A BIG PROJECTS THE
NUCLEAR POWER PLANT SENATE NO
FOR A. THAT PROJECT CREATED ALL
THIRTY SIX YEAR CAREER FOR ME.
OBVIOUSLY NOT ALL AT THE SAME
PLACE THERE'S AN OPPORTUNITY
ONCE ONCE PEOPLE GET INTO THE
TRADES TO STAY IN THE TRADES AND
CONTINUE TO BILL CALIFORNIA
THANK YOU.
Q..
TRINITY REP SO PLEASE.
CAN WE COMMITTEE MONEY WAS
STEVEN BOOKER OF THE POLITICAL
DIRECTOR COMMUNITY AFFAIRS
LIAISON FOR THE INTERNATIONAL
BROTHERHOOD OF ELECTRICAL
WORKERS LOCAL SIX SEVENTEEN
ASSUME UNTIL COUNTING. ON MUSCLE
LOW NATIVE CALIFORNIA TAXPAYER
VOTER AND ON THE DESERT SHIELD
DESERT STORM VET.
I WAS SO MEMBER MATHIS WAS HERE
BECAUSE HE LEFT ABOUT A CRYSTAL
BALL EARLIER.
MY CRYSTAL BALL TELLS ME THAT
THE CHEAPEST. TIME TO BUILD THIS
PROJECT IS TODAY WHERE FULL
SUPPORT OF IT IF WE KEEP BARACK
SING ON THIS I KEEP ALL THIS RED
TAPE ONE THIS PROJECT IS JUST
GOING TO INCREASE THE COST.
THE CHEAPEST TIME TO BUILD THIS
IS RIGHT NOW THE VOTERS VOTED
FOR WE NEED TO BUILD HIGH SPEED
RAIL AS OTHER INDIVIDUALS OF
SANTA CREATES.
GREAT JOBS.
EVERYBODY LEADS MANY COMMUNITIES
AND WE'RE FULL SUPPORT OF THIS
THANK YOU.
S. MY NAME'S JEFF ROBERTS OF A
REGIONAL DIRECTOR WITH DISTRICT
COUNCIL SIXTEEN LOCAL UNION TO
NINETY FOUR PRESIDENT CALIFORNIA
PAINTERS AND ALLIED TRADES IN.
ALL THIS DITTO. ON MY RELIGIOUS
BOOK FORM ANTI.
MY NAME IS RANDY OR A HOSTILE
DISCOUNT SIXTEEN PARA DELI TRAYS
ON A BUSINESS REPRESENTATIVE
HERE IN SACRAMENTO.
SELECT DITTO WHAT MIKE WESTON
AND ALSO AS A FATHER OF TWO
TEENAGE SONS. I SEE THIS IN THE
BEST IN THEIR FUTURE THEIR
CHILDREN'S FUTURES AND THEIR
CHILDREN'S FUTURES AND I HEARD
HER SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WHICH NAMELY RIPS UP
PLEASE MISTER SHARE MEMBER SARAH
FLOCKS IN THE CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION.
WE'VE BEEN IF SINCE THE
BEGINNING IN SUPPORT OF HIGH
SPEED RAIL AS A SMART INVESTMENT
IN THE TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM OF
THE STATE AND ALSO AS AN
ECONOMIC. ECONOMIC DRIVER AND
IT'S VERY EXCITING TO SEE.
IN THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN BUSINESS
PLAN. THAT THIS IS REALLY COMING
TO FRUITION YOU SEE THAT THERE
IS THE PROJECT HAS ALREADY
YIELDED TWO POINT THREE BILLION
DOLLARS IN LABOR INCOME THE
NUMBER OF JOBS IT'S CREATED THE
STRUCTURES THAT HAVE GONE UP. ON
THE BENEFITS TO OUR EXISTING
RAIL SYSTEM THESE ARE ALL REAL
BENEFITS THE HIGH SPEED RAIL IS
DELIVERING TO OUR STATE.
BUT ALSO THIS BUSINESS PLAN
PRESENTS OF A VISION OF A VALLEY
TO VALLEY SYSTEM THAT CAN
REALLY.
NOT ONLY HELP WITH ECONOMIC
INVESTMENTS AND ECONOMIC GROWTH
IN THAT THE CENTRAL VALLEY. BUT
ALSO CAN HELP ALLEVIATE THE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING CRISIS WE
HAVE
AND IF THERE'S A WAY TO GET
PEOPLE FROM THE CENTRAL VALLEY
FROM INDIA FROM MERCED FROM ALL
OF THESE AREAS. TO JOBS IN
PLACES LIKE THE BAY AREA TO SOME
OF THE TAX CENTERS THEN WE CAN
REALLY START CONNECTING PEOPLE
AND ALLOWING THEM TO BE ABLE TO.
AFFORD A HOME TO RENT AN
APARTMENT AND STILL GET TO A
GOOD PAINT JOB AND SO FOR THAT
WE SUPPORT THIS PROJECT WE
SUPPORT THE BUSINESS PLAN. THANK
YOU TO YOU AND TO THE HIGH SPEED
RAIL.
FOR THEIR WORK ON THE STATE YOU.
PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME AND WE
WERE SO PLEASE TAIWANESE JOHN
HERNANDEZ.
I REPRESENT THE AYE ORDERS.
FROM FRESNO CALIFORNIA LOCAL
ONE FIVE FIVE.
WE CURRENTLY.
ARE GOING TO DO THE.
OR ONE HUNDRED THE WHOLE ONE
HUNDRED NINETEEN MILES THAT ARE
MANDATED RIGHT NOW.
FROM MADERA TO.
WASCO.
.
I A WEEK WE ONLY HAD ONE I
STARTED I'VE BEEN AND I WORK OF
THIRTY FIVE YEARS.
AND I'VE HAD TO TRAVEL FROM
FRESNO TO SAN DIEGO FROM FRESNO
TO ALL THE WAY UP TO THE ORGAN
BORDER.
ALREADY NEVADA RENO. A LAS VEGAS
TRUMP ON OF THAT.
THROUGHOUT MY CAREER.
.
I WANT TO SAY THAT OF WE KERN I
I CURRENTLY HAD TO WHEN I BECAME
A BUSINESS AGENT WE ONLY HAD TWO
HUNDRED AND SIXTY SUB MEMBERS.
WE CURRENTLY HAVE OVER SIX
HUNDRED MEMBERS.
NOT ALL OF THEM ARE WORKING ON
THE HIGH SPEED RAIL THE HIGH
SPEED RAIL HAS A LOT OF THEM
WORKING.
IN WITH.
AND THAT YOU GOT YOU GUYS CALL
PHASE ONE THE WHOLE HUNDRED
NINETEEN.
MILES OUR PHASE ONE IS GOING
FROM MADERA TO AMERICAN AVENUE
IN FRESNO CALIFORNIA.
ON THAT PROJECT ALONE WE HAVE
OVER A SIXTY TO EIGHTY. PEOPLE
WORKING.
OF FACE TO YOU JUST STARTED.
LAST THURSDAY.
AND.
THEY'VE ALREADY A PLATE TEN
WORKERS AND PLANNING ON.
PLAYING ANOTHER EIGHTY.
OF THESE PEOPLE.
WITH THE.
.
OF MANDATE THAT THEY WANT
THIRTY PERCENT OF DISADVANTAGED
WORKERS WE'RE WE ARE BRING IN
PEOPLE FROM.
.
A WELFARE. OF MAKING YOU KNOW
SIX HUNDRED DOLLARS A MONTH TO
MAKE IT THREE OR FOUR THOUSAND
DOLLARS A MONTH. THESE PEOPLE
ARE NOW PAYING TAXES THEY ARE
NOW BUYING CARS THEY ARE NOT
BUYING HOUSES.
IN WITH THE HIGH SPEED RAIL
BEING.
BUILT AND IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY.
WERE YOU ABLE TO STAY HOME AND
WILL WATER OUR CHILDREN PLAY.
WHAT?
PLAY BASEBALL SOCCER. WHATEVER
SPORT THEY HAPPEN TO BE IN THAT
THE TIME.
AND.
WITH THAT ENCOURAGE YOU TO KEEP.
WILL SPARK VIA.
GREAT THANK YOU.
YOUR NAME YOUR REPRESENT
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
KEYSTONE ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATION RECOVERY HIGH SPEED
TRAINS I'D LIKE TO COMMEND THE
AUTHORITY SO. TO HELP MEET OUR
ENVIRONMENTAL GOALS WITH THE
MODERNIZATION OF OUR SYSTEM
REALLY TAKING CARS OFF OF THE
LANES WERE HAVE LESS POLLUTERS
REDUCE OUR CARBON FOOTPRINT.
IT'S IMPORTANT PART OF THIS
PROGRAM THAT DOES HELP MEET THE
MANDATE THAT YOU AND YOUR FELLOW
LEGISLATORS TO PUT ON
CALIFORNIA.
TO HAVE A VERY HIGH STANDARD
WITH REGARDS TURN BERMAN WE
SUPPORT THAT WE CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH THE AUTHORITY AND LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU. AS
WE MOVE FORWARD AND BUILD THIS
PROJECT.
THANK YOU.
SHAMELESSLY RIPS UP MISTER
CHAIRMAN RECESSED IDEAS ON
BEHALF OF THE STATE BUILDING
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL. OF
ALSO ACOLYTE OF THE COMMENTS
THAT WERE ALREADY SAID ON BUT
ALSO NOTE THAT A LOT OF
CONSTRUCTION WORKERS IN
CONSTRUCTION WORK REPRESENT IS
WE'RE HERE IN THE ROOM.
LISTENING TO THE DEBATE AND THE
QUESTIONS THAT WERE ASKED WE
HAVE TO LEAVE. BUT IT ISN'T
LIVES OR DUTY AND THEN ALSO
TRANSPORTATION.
ALL OF THOSE THINGS ARE EMBODIED
HERE IN THE WORK THE LEGISLATURE
HAS DONE WITHIN THIS PROJECT. IN
GOING A STEP BEYOND THE PROJECT
CARRIES A PROJECT LABOR
AGREEMENT THAT ONLY HELPS OUT.
IN DISADVANTAGED AREAS WHICH THE
CENTRAL VALLEY IS AND WHICH
OTHER PARTS OF CALIFORNIA ARE
BUT ALSO IN ASSISTING. A LOT OF
THE SMALL MINORITY CONTRACTORS
THAT AREN'T ACTUALLY ABLE TO BID
ON TOUCH HOW THE PROJECT BECAUSE
OF THEIR COMPLEXITY.
WITHOUT PROJECT LIVER THAT LABOR
AGREEMENT AND WHAT THAT
FLEXIBILITY IN THE COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING AGREEMENT BETWEEN US
AND OUR CONTRACTORS THAT ALLOWS
FOR THAT DIVERSE CITY. SO FOR
ALL THOSE REASONS THAT WERE
STATED BEFORE WE STRONG
SUPPORTERS BUSINESS PLAN WE
THINK IT CARRIES A LOT OF FISCAL
ACCOUNTABILITY. WE SUPPORT WHAT
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT IN TERMS OF
CARRYING FORWARD BUT WE THINK
THIS PROJECT SHOULD MOVE FORWARD
ONGOING GET MORE MONEY FOR THE
PROJECT. WE BELIEVE THE
REPUBLICANS CANDID AND TO HAVE A
LOT OF POINTS TO MAKE BUT THEY
SHOULD GET REALLY GET BEHIND
BECAUSE IT IT IS THERE ARE AREAS
THAT ARE BENEFITING MORE SO
GREAT LEAVES THEIR CONSTITUENTS.
THEY'RE ACTUALLY HAVING THAT
ECONOMIC IMPACT IN THAT BENEFIT
TO WE THINK.
ANY OTHER MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
THAT WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK.
TODAY.
BUT THE DRAFT BUSINESS PLAN.
SEEING NONE.
SO.
I WANT TO THANK THE MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE.
THE PANELISTS IN THE PUBLIC FOR
PARTICIPATING IN TODAY'S.
HEARING BUT I ALSO WANT TO THANK
MY STAFF.
WHO ARE VERY SHORT NOTICE AFTER
THE DRAFT PLAN WAS PUT OUT THE
WE'RE ABLE TO HAVE THIS HEARING?
AND BE ABLE TO HAVE A
COMPREHENSIVE APPROACH THAT GOT
THE TEAM HERE
WORKING WEEKENDS AND NIGHTS TO
BE ABLE TO PULL THIS OFF OF WITH
A REAL REGULAR DUTIES.
HEARING BILLS.
AND SO. KUDOS TO MY STAFF AND I
CAN'T THANK THEM ENOUGH.
IT'S CLEAR THAT THERE ARE SOME
TOUGH DECISIONS.
AHEAD OF US ABOUT HIGH SPEED
RAIL.
I AM COMMITTED TO CONSIDERING
ALL OF THOSE OPTIONS HAS SO THAT
WE MAKE THE BEST.
DECISION FOR CALIFORNIA.
NO WE CAN'T YOU CAN ATTRIBUTE
THIS.
EXTRA COST TO LABOR.
THERE WAS DOORS ARE SUPPOSED TO
DO.
IN ITS EXUBERANCE.
THIS JOB IS I SAID. MOVE
FORWARD.
WITHOUT ALL THE PIECES OF THE
PUZZLE IN PLACE.
WE HAVE TO RECOGNIZE THAT.
AND NOW WITH THE NEW.
UPPER MANAGEMENT TO TAKE.
THE THE.
THE RAINS.
WE'RE HOPING THAT PAST MISTAKES.
CAN BE.
AVOIDED.
WHO ON FORWARD?
THIS IS A GREAT OPPORTUNITY FOR
THE CENTRAL VALLEY AND.
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AND THESE
CEMETERY Ó SAN JOSE SAN
FRANCISCO COURT OR.
HOME.
BUT WE HAVE TO BE REASONABLE
HAVE TAP HAS TO BE ABLE TO BE OF
VALUE
TO THE PEOPLE.
AND RECOGNIZE OF EVERY DOLLAR
SPENT PASSED TO BRING SOMETHING
BACK.
.
THE.
WHOLE COMPONENT OF THE FUTURE
GHG REDUCTIONS BECAUSE THIS
PROJECT BUT WE'RE NOT
ACKNOWLEDGING.
WHY DID THE TOUR WHICH WAS
TOUTED AT ALL OF THE
CONSTRUCTION OF A COMMITMENT IS
BEING UTILIZED?
WHEN I WAS THERE.
WAS
EITHER VERY LOW EMISSIONS ARE
KNOWN MISSION.
EQUIPMENT WHICH WAS.
.
I THINK ONE OF THE FIRST TIMES
IT'S BEEN DONE OR ACCOMPLISHED
OR PROJECT OF THIS MAGNITUDE.
.
SO. WHAT WE NEED TO DO AND I'M
I'M?
ADAMANT THAT WE GO FORWARD.
WITH A PROCESS.
ACTUALLY.
HAS MORE OVERSIGHT.
MAKE THE TRANSPORTATION OR THE.
THE AUTHORITY HIGH SPEED RAIL
AUTHORITY MORE.
ACCOUNTABLE FOR DECISION MAKING
PROCESSES.
HOW GOING FORWARD?
HA AND AND.
THE PUBLIC SHOULD ALSO REMEMBER.
THIS WAS NOT GOVERNOR JERRY
BROWN'S HIGH SPEED RAIL.
REPUBLICAN TWO THOUSAND A VOTED
FOR THIS PROJECT.
BE IT ALL THEY MAKE IT HAS
EVOLVED INTO SOMETHING ELSE YES
AT HOUSE BECAUSE WHO COULD
ANTICIPATE.
WE THE COMPLEXITY OF THIS
PROJECT HOW ENORMOUS.
THE TASK WOULD BE.
OTHER COUNTRIES OF DONNA BUT
THEY DON'T HAVE THE
ENVIRONMENTAL RESTRICTIONS WE
DO.
WE ACTUALLY TAKE CARE OF OR HER
ARE.
OUR LAND AND DON'T MAKE RASH
DECISIONS THAT MIGHT HURT THE
ENVIRONMENT.
I LIKE TO REMIND THE MEMBERS OF
THIS COMMITTEE IN THE PUBLIC
THAT THIS IS A DRAFT BUSINESS
PLAN.
SO MAY DRAFT IS NOT CAST IN
STONE.
COULD YOU HAVE FURTHER COMMENTS.
BE SURE SUBMIT THEM TO THE
AUTHORITY SALUTE COMMENTS CAN BE
CONSIDERED IN THE FINAL PLAN.
EVERYTHING.
IS A WORKING DOCUMENT
CONSTRUCTION I SPENT THIRTY FIVE
YEARS IN THE CONSTRUCTION
INDUSTRY.
AND I'VE NEVER HAD A PROJECT
THAT DIDN'T EVOLVE INTO
SOMETHING ELSE OR.
HE HAD TO ADAPT.
I THINK THROUGH THE ABILITY TO.
ADAPT AND MAKE THINGS WORK IS
WHAT WE NEED.
ON PROJECTS LIKE THIS.
.
I'M LOOKING FORWARD TO.
A BETTER DEFINITION OF A BETTER
OF OF HOW. FINANCING WILL BE
DONE.
I DON'T WANT TO.
UTILIZED JUST CAP AND TRADE AS
THE CONSISTENT FUNDING FOR THIS
I THINK THAT WE NEED TO LOOK
MORE INTO.
PRIVATE INVESTMENT.
NOW MY NAME BEFORE COUNTRIES.
TO BE ABLE TO INVEST
INTO THIS PROJECT.
WITH THE.
UNDERSTANDING THAT NUMBER ONE
LABOR COMES FIRST.
OUR JOBS ARE IMPORTANT TO US AND
THEN YOU. LOOK AT.
MAYBE ARE OF VALUE MAKE AN
INVESTMENT INTO CALIFORNIA ALSO.
SO I LOOKING FORWARD AGAIN TO
MAKING SURE THAT THIS IS DONE
RIGHT THE AUDIT WHEN IT COMES
OUT.
LOOKING FORWARD TO IT TO
DISSECTING IT WITH MY STAFF.
AND.
BUT I'VE GOT TO TELL YOU EVERY
TIME THAT I'VE BEEN. IN THE THE
THE PRESENCE OF THAT PROJECT.
THE DATA DAY OPERATIONS ARE
BEING HANDLED ON IT A VERY
EFFICIENT MANNER AND YOU'RE
GETTING.
IN THAT ASPECT OF VALUE THE
TAXPAYERS ACTUALLY GETTING
ABOUT.
HOME BECAUSE IT'S SOMETHING THAT
WILL LAST.
GENERATIONS.
SO THIS WILL COMMENCE THE
HEARING.
OF HIGH SPEED RAIL CRAFTS VISIT
BY TWENTY EIGHTEEN.
AND I LOOK FORWARD TO MOVING
FORWARD SO THANK YOU SO MUCH